foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
chess the weight of a win draw or loss
is all on one's shoulders it's easy to
feel alone
those lonely days are over
[Applause]
the pro chess league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
they are having a party in France
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives the wheels came up wow she
just took down Hikaru Nakamura and look
at her she is jubilant entering its
Fifth Season 16 teams will reboot the
PCL Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion what what was that oh my
gosh
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
we win we win oh my God
welcome to week two of the protest
League week one was extra exciting with
mouse slips great chess and more but
week two starts right now I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me my
good friend International Master Tanya
South Chef Tanya week one was so
exciting what do you expect for week two
just more of that drop it I am so happy
to be back here because we had such an
incredible opening week of the pro chess
League we witnessed what is perhaps one
of the biggest upsets in chess history
with Josephine heinemann taking down
Hikaru Nakamura we saw these huge
swindles looking at your Magnus Carlton
with that big win against a Wonder Liang
what a massive turnaround nail-biting
tiebreakers so definitely this week too
looking forward to more of that and with
the high stakes matchups featuring the
teams with the same score is going to be
epic
it certainly will be and you mentioned
teams with the same score so let's show
these standings after week one we saw
eight teams win their first round
matchups including the Indian yogis and
the Canada chess bras we will be
starting with them today and Tanya the
yogis they were Mighty impressive they
won in only three rounds
what a hot matchup and that's going to
be today as you mentioned Robert the
only team to actually wrap up that match
in just three rounds the Indian yogis
were on fire against the Brazil
Capybaras but of course today the task
is Monumental up against them as they
face the Canada chess bras it's going to
be a tough ride
it certainly will be Magnus Carson
leading the way for the chess Bros but
we do have a double header today not
just Indian yogis versus the can of
Chess Bros we will also have a second
matchup uh featuring the uh some teams
that lost their first week so Tanya
Bueno team wins another team has to lose
let's look at the standings after week
one for the teams who lost their first
matchup including the Brazil Capybaras
the Charlotte cobras we'll see those two
duke it out today
three wins you make it to the protest
League playoffs so the teams are inching
towards that ultimate goal and things
are really heating up here today's match
very important for all these four teams
well you're talking about today's
matches there will be four teams playing
let's Dive Right into those matchups we
will start with the candid chess bra
taking on the Indian yogis two teams
that won their first round matchups
Tanya we know that three wins gets you
into the playoffs
absolutely and I think these two teams
were just on a farm in week one they've
got to get that same energy for today
and of course the Brazil Capybaras and
the Charlotte cobras now while it was a
tough one for Brazil in week one in week
one the cobras was so close to beating
the chess bras going to be an exciting
match up that one as well but of course
to start off we've got the Epic one here
with the Canada chess Bros taking on the
Indian yogis and I cannot wait because
it is such a huge roster in these two
teams
yes now there are some big names on the
candid chess bras and the Indian yogis
let's start with the chess bras no
bigger name of chest than Magnus Carlson
he holds down the fort on board one
Tanya my X Factor you know we look from
top to bottom the roster razvent priyotu
a grand master rate 2493 he's the X
Factor for me on the chess Bros who's
your pick is it Magnus or somebody else
Kyoto was so good in week one he scored
a very important two out of four in that
matchup as well as Aryan did now this is
the one thing that I love about protest
league right any tournament that Magnus
is playing you would think that he's a
huge favorite but it really switches up
in these theme formats and it's so hard
to predict what will happen all four
players in each of these teams have to
really perform today because it can go
either ways I think Robert the deciding
factor will also be depending on who
they pick to fight today who they're
born for their woman player will be and
how the performance goes on each of the
boards not just magnus's board
yeah picks are important here in the
protesting and that includes from you in
the chat and all our fans around the
world you can get involved with our week
two featured question it is how many
queens will the chess Bros sacrifice in
week two you only have two options you
pick one you use the command predict to
submit your predictions and win prize
every week and Tanya I'm gonna ask you
this question how many queens will the
chess bro sacrifice will be a one or
more that's option A or will it be zero
that's what option b reads under a half
week
wow you know Robert it would be also
interesting is sacrifice interchangeable
with a blunder as well because then it
of course might really switch up uh but
you know we did see Magnus blunder away
a queen on Day on in week one against a
Wonder now I don't know how many but you
know what I'm gonna go for the option A
that is my prediction I think we're
gonna see at least one both as Gambit
okay well we may see some sacrifices we
may see see some unintentional
sacrifices but either way Tanya says we
will see some and well we just talked
about the kid and the chess bras they
have an opponent today and it is a very
tough opponent the Indian yogis Tanya
you know a thing or three about that
lineup uh they made quick work of the
Capybaras in week one winning in only
three rounds and I love picking the
bottom Boards of course Vida Gujarati is
a good friend of ours but I'm gonna talk
about Vice Shelley she went one and a
half out of three in week one she took
down the top board super for the Brazil
happy bars she was really vital to their
success and wanted to name all shout out
before I pass their views arvind he won
all three of his games yet you know he
may be sitting out this week
hmm well it is a stack team from top to
bottom as we can see we've got the
mixture of the strongest talents from
the country the big prodigies along with
the big names with it leading from the
front there uh Robert you pointed out
vaishali's incredible performance in
week one and it really comes down to
these bottom boards the third and fourth
boards and how much they contribute to a
team uh to the win and I think that is
going to be absolutely key arvind was
such a star player it's going to be
interesting to see what strategy
ramesh's theme with its theme comes up
with today what is going to be the
player lineup where are their best
chances when they're facing Magnus
Carlson's team
and what other names on this roster
stick out to you because vidit at the
top we know prognanda Niha and raunak
these are three teenagers from India who
haven't played yet so uh when you look
from top to bottom here there's also
Grandmaster Elizabeth Pates what are
some of the names that you think will
have to lead them to the playoffs and
ultimately to their team success well we
haven't seen a lot of them in the
protest League yet we know that some of
the players are playing in the WR Chess
Masters so I'm expecting a lot of mix up
to happen as well in the team once that
event is over I think I think it won't
be too far-fetched to imagine with it in
the team he had quite a good performance
in week one as well between vaishali and
Elizabeth that's going to be an
interesting pick but I think vaishali's
performance really spoke for itself in
week one and uh going to be going to be
a hard call to mix that up we also see
aronia Ghosh now you might see he's only
an international Master but I think he
could be the highest rated International
master in the world he's current only
got a rating of 25 30. that is a mammoth
rating he is he did make a recent
Grandmaster Norm one of the big upcoming
talents as well as pranesh there so some
really really interesting names and it
all comes down to a choice that Ramesh
has to make as team captain you know
it's uh it's the choice of Plenty here
for the Indian yogis
it certainly is and well you have to
make certain choices for your rosters
because every single week you have to
follow these rules you have to include
at least one woman in your lineup your
total average rating cap is 25.50 but
players over 2 700 count as 2700 and
women over 23.50 count is just 2350 that
is to encourage teams to get the best
players in the world that's why the
Canon chess Bros have Magnus Carlsen
it's why the Indian yogis have vidic
Gujarati as well as vaishali you know
you want to have the best line of Sonya
I love this as well because it just
means that the team teams are more
evenly matched and you know you can have
you can have women players who are 25 50
but they will be counted as 23.50 and I
think this is also the reason why it's
hard for a team like Jasper to pick up
Magnus and Anish in the same lineup
because then they end up compromising on
the lower boards as well so there's so
much Team Dynamics and strategy involved
and these rules for the lineup of the
day really make things a very exciting
they do indeed and well lineups we know
what they will be today we start with
the Canada chess Bros versus the Indian
yogis so why don't we take a look at the
lineups that we have uh on paper well
Ward one no surprise for either side
Magnus Carlson and vidit Gujarati and
then on board two we see a new player to
the mix actually all of the candle chess
for us from last week return to week two
but Roundup said wani aronia ghost you
mentioned uh those names here they're
making their debut for the Indian yogis
wow I'm amazing to see this lineup for
today and I can already feel the nerves
and tension because as we can see the
Canada chest bras have stuck to their
formula why fix what's not broken it
worked for them in week one and they
return with the same theme while Indian
yogis have really mixed it up they have
that go for this for this matchup arvind
chadambaram and Garden Bailey have been
replaced by ronak and aroniak now ironic
is such a strong player as well in Blitz
especially it truly is his Forte he
became a grand master at all of 13. the
17 year old has been having some
phenomenal performances in the title
Tuesday he really enjoys these faster
formats he doesn't fear anyone and I
think that is probably one of the big
reasons that Ramesh decided to go for
ronak with this huge matchup aroniak I
was I was talking about him he is
currently at 25 30 and that is a massive
rating vaishali is Back so once again I
see with Jennifer and vaishali playing
in this match up Robert I think the
women bought that board four will play a
crucial role in deciding today's winner
Yeah you mentioned Josephine heinemann
earlier in the show she took down Hikaru
Nakamura it wasn't quite enough for the
Berlin bears but that's what you need is
some huge upsets from your lower boards
and we will start with these lopsided
matchups in the first round of action
Magnus Carlson would get the black piece
against vaishali that's a huge game for
the Indian yogis and then we look down
the roster or it's two and board three
those are you know players who make it
you wouldn't be surprised no matter who
wins those games but down on board four
Jennifer you with the white pieces she
got off to a slow start last week will
she be able to take down your very good
friend vidit Gujarati when she has the
white pieces that's a big question for
the chest
Robert you mentioned lopsided but do not
forget that where Charlie was the one
who took down the top rated player from
in the Brazil Capybaras she beat supi in
week one of the protest League of course
he's up against Magnus and that's a huge
match for her she is very inspired to
play against him I'm sure but she wants
to beat him and let's not forget she has
a brother out there pragnananda who has
been making life very difficult for
Magnus Carlsen in several of the
Champions chat story events I won't be
surprised if he's given her a couple of
pro tips on how to handle this one
yeah unfortunately you know when you
play Magnus Carlson it's a new day it's
a new game and you're still facing the
best player in the Chess World so let's
talk about how you win these matches
because of course you need to win your
individual games you need uh for Magnus
Carlson the chess bras you often need
your top board to swing and win every
single game as he did last week uh but
it's a team competition you need to
reach eight and a half points as a squad
now the Indian yogis did that in three
matches uh last week right you get four
but they only needed three to get to
that eight and a half points uh but it
is a first to eight and a half points in
this format I don't think we will see
the matches end early today uh because
in an all play all format where you have
super GMS on board one I think we're
gonna go the distance
I would love to go to the distance take
this down to the wire bring us the
playoffs the tie breaks the blitz that
happen if they tie on 88 but of course
the golden number here for the teams is
to get to eight and a half and they take
the match when Robert we've been talking
about what the math strategy is and I
think it has to be for each of the each
of the players on the team to really
contribute in week one for the chess
brush Jennifer you scored half a point
out of four games and I think having
that could be a big problem against the
Indian yogis uh meanwhile of course with
Magnus on the team it could be it could
be almost fair to say that we can expect
a hundred percent score from Magnus at
least on paper it's not going to be easy
but let's say he is able to do that it
comes down on the other three boards and
which team has a more balanced approach
today which team is able to produce the
players who score and contribute to the
match on every board
right so uh it's going to be
contributions needed from top to bottom
whether it's Magnus Carlson or Jennifer
you or Vida Gujarati to vaishali but we
will be getting games shortly we see the
players uh different locations for some
of them we know that Magnus Carlson was
playing from the chess Bra House in week
one I think he's back in Norway he has
been streaming and that means that for
the chess bras they'll have to hope that
Magnus Carlson isn't jet lagged that is
he isn't tired from traveling but he is
back home and he will take on vaishali
hmm different locations same hair by
Magnus I see vaishali as well ready on
the screen uh Robert of course where
Charlie is the big Underdog in this one
and the good news with that is that she
doesn't need to take any pressure just
needs to give her best every half a
point that you can save against Magnus
will be huge it's liftoff where Charlie
chooses to start with the King spawn
opening and Magnus making his intentions
very clear going for the Sicilian here
yes we are getting a rasa Limo just like
we saw in the 2018 World Championship
between Fabiano caruana and Magnus
Carlsen and after Bishop B5 he hasn't
moved yet and I believe it's because he
feels he has to play for a win and what
is this ton of E5 I know I have not seen
this at least not very often
this is just Magnus mixing it up he just
wants a game he is pretty clear that
vasali has some preparation if she's
gone for the rosalima and Magnus wanting
to make sure she gets none of that he
says you know what we'll fight on in
non-theoretical Grant non-theoretical
battle and that's what he's going for he
continues to Blitz that with the bishop
to D6 a strange square at first because
you're like wait a second you've got
these two pawns and I see one Pawn is
already lost did why Charlie just make a
blunder was that a mouse slip was she
intending to play D3 what just happened
why is she not making her next move
quickly so many questions and I'm
struggling for the answer
okay I think she still is maybe in
preparation but I think she's moving
slowly
um I'm very confused by this if we just
bring up an analysis board and go back a
couple moves here the movie E5 by Magnus
the whole point of this move is to take
away the D4 Square you have two pawns
staring there white doesn't have a Pawn
on C3 so after Bishop D6 she played D4
anyway it's a pawn sacrifice and H6
played by Magnus to take away this
knight jump uh Tanya unless white gets
some huge pressure against the F7 Pawn
is this enough compensation you gave
upon the center and vaishali is the one
thinking
that is the most surprising part you
Gambit upon you sacrifice upon it's for
the initiative this is not a classical
game you have got to keep the momentum
up on the clock find your compensation
one of the ideas that comes to mind now
time is of the essence here Robert you
can't make slow moves once you've
sacrificed upon already you can try and
trade off that Knight on D4 and already
try to put pressure along the center
break open with the pawn move C3 take
advantage of magnus's development of the
bishop on D6 with the queen x-raying
down the D file and it's on the board
and to me that seems like part of
vaishali's preparation D4 was not a
mouse slip no it wasn't but black can
solve two problems at once with Bishop
C5 making sure the bishop is no longer
hang here and protecting this Pawn so we
can see where the composition comes from
a white king safely castled
um the black pieces not developed this
bishop is awkwardly blocking in this
bishop on C8 the king side of course is
not developed at all but if Bishop C5
happens I feel like it's a moment Tanya
where white has to prove all that
compensation it is a full Pawn if you
take on D4 the bishop can take back
black spawn structure is not compromised
so black will be up a pawn but white
will have squares to jump into namely if
this Knight gets into C3 and D5 maybe at
some point a pawn pushed to F4 but Tanya
Magnus Carlson seems right at home quite
literally because he is in his home but
also in this position I don't think he's
too worried
when you're trying to win a game with
the black pieces this is exactly what
you want right Magnus wants to try to
create uneven ground an imbalanced
position where Charlie's already
sacrificed the pawn she needs to prove
her Initiative for it or she very well
might just end up in an in a middle game
where she's down upon and no
compensation so it's going to be all
about the next couple of moves the one
thing that comes to mind and notice how
important Black's resources are here
white can jump in with the queen to H5
and now you're threatening a mate in one
on F7 as well as the E5 Pawn but Robert
then black has a really nice defensive
resource of coming up with the queen to
E7 where you take control and defend
both these weaknesses so that's what
black is counting on and this is a big
moment for vaishali to really prove her
compensation will she be able to do that
I'm gonna be honest Tanya the fact that
she's spending so much time makes me
extremely nervous because she's gambited
upon and it looks like she does have
legitimate compensation but Magnus he's
seen this before whether in a game maybe
it's Blitz or just in preparation he
knows what to do and he's playing
quickly she's spending time with every
turn and that's the worst thing when
you're looking at it from a player who's
400 points outrated by her opponent you
need to play fast and confidently and I
just don't think she has that right now
she has many options she could play
Simple chess develop that if this Pawn
takes the Knight takes back and your
Knight's hopping into D5 we see all that
we acknowledge that white does have
compensation I'm just worried it's going
to fizzle out and she's just gonna be
down upon because she's spending so much
time doesn't feel like she's comfortable
right now
that would be the dream right to get
that night onto that D5 Square which is
just such a juicy post for the night and
then you can really start Imagining the
compensation for vaishali we completely
agree with you uh Robert the most
worrying thing about this whole
situation is that she's already used
three and a half minutes on her clock
she does play A4 so still making moves
that put pressure on black expanding the
queen side notice how the threat is not
only to go A5 but in some devious way in
some position you can plant that Bishop
on A3 and really x-ray down that
diagonal with a B5 push making sure that
black skin doesn't get to safety shot
Castle would be difficult and I think
Bishop A3 is always in the air in these
positions
yeah big moment here for Magnus and the
best news for vaishali is Magnus is
thinking so his preparation whatever it
was has run out and the fact that she
played A4 Tanya it kind of leads me to
believe she might be still within the
realm of her preparation maybe I spoke a
little bit too soon because A4 is kind
of an odd Choice like you're continuing
to push pawns forward we get why because
you want to disconnect the Bishop from
the D4 pawn and Magnus says go for it
kick my Bishop back it'll likely go to
C7 your E4 Pawn now is under attack in
addition uh to Black's D4 upon so it's a
messy type of position and I'm just
worried because the rapid game that
vashar needs all of the time she can get
and she is spending a lot of it now but
she does seem to be playing the best
moves her Advantage remains
wow I mean I am loving what we're
getting out of the opening already of
course it is a game that is lit on the
board right out of the opening vaishali
sacrificing upon playing for the
initiative I'm still worried about her
clock uh Robert this is a big one but I
think we've got action on the other
boards as well and a really important
important opening choices all around why
don't we go to the bird's eye view and
take a look at what the players are up
to
okay well we see in the top right it's
board two for the can of Chess bras
that's orientare taking on board three
around I like to call him Lavon aroniak
a ghost so we have aronia gauche with
the white pieces that's very early
stages in the top right honestly all the
other games Tanya are very early at
least they seem like that compared to
like one of the top left between Magnus
and vaishali somehow not many pawns have
been traded in the other three boards
but in Magnus against vaishali that's
where all the action is happening so uh
is there anywhere you want to dive in
right now it really is and you're
absolutely right if we look at all the
other three boards it just looks like
very sane positions out of the opening
and I'm all up for diving deep diving
into the Magnus board because really
that's where the fire is a very
important game there for vaishali Magnus
of course a big favorite in any game
that he plays he's already up a pawn uh
should we jump straight back to that or
do you want to go to aroniak's game as
well which by the way is not as calm as
it might look at first because I see
that black has a picked up a pawn uh
let's see if we can bring that up and
there we have it let's see if we can
bring up the board with aroniac uh sorry
this is not the one where white has
black has picked up the pawn but what I
was saying was that black does have a
lot of space here with that Bishop
coming into B7 on the diagonal trying to
advance the central pawns C5 always in
the air is Aryan happy with the opening
outcome
well he should be happy with his lead on
the clock because if we look at the
times he's up nearly two minutes and
what is white done white has pushed us
upon D4 and maybe we'll get a hanging
Pawn structure when black plays the C5
move that you're talking about but the
fact that Aryan is now thinking I
figured he wasn't going to play C5 he
plays A5 now that move not loved at
least at first by the engines here and
the reason perhaps why is when you play
C5 you've permanently given up this B5
squared of whites pieces that doesn't
seem like an important one but every
square is important in chess you always
want to look at the pros and cons of
your moves here and I feel like for
aronia he will not fee and keto his
Bishop he can do that but I feel like
he'll go back to D3 I mean C2 Rook C1
just play more towards the center and he
starts with a flexible move I like this
move Tanya he does not yet determine
where his Bishop goes because if the
bishop goes to B7 it might go up to H3
he's waiting for the right moment and
it's so important because if you do a
fan chart of the bishop on G2 or move it
to H3 that gives black the option to
bring his own Bishop to A6 really
cutting down White's King in the center
where white can't really go for a king
side Castle as it will control the F1
Square so an important decision thereby
aronia making sure that the bishop stays
on this diagonal I agree with you that
despite making that pawn move to G3 uh
aroniak wants that Bishop on D3 where it
can eye the 87 square and white can
decide you want to go kingside Castle or
queen side castling but I'll tell you
one thing Robert I will be shocked to
see a queen side castle by white hair it
just looks like black has so much play
on The Queen side already
yeah casting Queen said you're just
asking for trouble what no matter what
pond push it is all the pawns will be
coming after the white king and A3
played I think both sides are playing
this waiting game this is fascinating
stuff Tanya because if we just go back a
half move here had white played Bishop
D3 I think black might have played this
move Bishop A6 offering an exchange of
Bishops so what white wants is to get
this position but with the pawn already
on A3 because if we go to the game board
for a second that after A3 Bishop D6 was
played they're both playing a little bit
of a waiting game had black played
Bishop A6 we would have seen a swap with
the inclusion of this Pawn on A3 so it's
just funny how this happens whether it's
a capture on the C4 square or a trait of
Bishops but now why not Bishop A6 like
immediately your idea looks very strong
for black I love it you make white skin
a little more weak in the center and
don't forget black Orion what he wants
to do next is slide The Rook from f8 to
that e file it's an open E file start
looking down the board the Knight can
potentially jump to E4 at a good moment
black will have the brake C5 to open up
the center I'm kind of liking aryan's
position and the way he's handled the
opening so far as long as white skin is
in the center aronia cannot feel safe in
this one
no he cannot but he has his work cut out
from him he's down under five minutes so
I think he's worse on the board he's
down on the clock this is tough news for
the Indian yogis but why don't we zoom
out of this one for a moment just to see
what's happening in the other boards as
by the way in the top right Veronica
Retreats his Bishop to F1 that's a
mission that his prior move was not good
but in the top left I see the eval bar
is dipping Magnus Carlson against
vaishali over there the opening was an
enterprising one interesting chess
played by the Indian Yogi's board four
but currently the eval it's kind of
hovering slightly favorable for black
and then back towards the middle but I'm
looking at the clock as well Tanya under
three minutes for vaishali
is getting very tricky on the board and
on the clock for her as you are
mentioning that it looks like black at
least has managed to get King safety has
developed the pieces and usually these
are the compensations that the side that
sacrifices upon is looking for while
that's done what is working in
vaishali's favor is that the extra Pawn
are these double weak pawns on the D
file but Robert that said I think it is
a terrifying position for white we just
saw magnus's last move bringing the
Knight into the attack watch out for
that H2 score not just that the queen
and one second we just saw H3 which
could be a huge blunder because it
wasn't the pawn that was hanging the
Knight can't jump into H2 and win an
entire exchange that Rook on F1 is in
fact trapped
yeah it's not something you see every
day because normally you see a bishop
come with check and go after the king
but Knight H2 simply traps this Rook on
F1 and I understand why if we just go
back a move while she didn't want to
make him like G3 that looks very risky
it opens up this diagonal as well and if
you make a move like maybe Knight F3
perhaps she was worried that in the
event of some kind of night trade on E5
or king would get in trouble but that
was clearly safer I wonder you know
maybe did she completely overlooked
Knight H2 it's just not something you
see all the time and Magnus can win this
Rook on F1 it is stuck in this place I
think he's gonna do it he does it he
does it Knight H2 on the board and this
could have been a big Miss by vaishali
but whatever it was this spells absolute
disaster in this game for the white
pieces and very often it's not just the
result but also the way the tournament
the game develops and I think vaishali
will not be happy with the way she's
handled this one The Rook on F1 will
fall and we were struggling to find
compensation for that one Pawn that
black had now I think finding
compensation for that extra exchange
will be impossible in this position
especially against Magnus Carlson he's
not somebody who lets people back in the
game very easily and I think she's
considering do I take on D4 is there
some kind of queen D6 type of inter
mezzo hitting this trying to turn the
Checkmate the answer is there isn't
Queen D6 will be met by Bishop C5 that's
why instead Magnus says give me that
material and let's trade we're up in
exchange so let's trade pieces that's
what you're taught to do liquidate when
you're ahead and Magnus Carlson he knows
what to do better than anybody in the
planet he'll bring a rook to the open C
file as well first of course block this
bishop then bring a rook to the C file
and maybe actually defend your pawn and
then bring her up to sequel but when all
is said and done black has an extra Rook
compared to this Knight on F1 huge
Advantage for Magnum white is dreaming
of of getting that knight from F1 to F5
but it is a far way off and really tough
to imagine it getting there on time
where Charlie trying to push her ponds
trying to get that Knight all the way to
F5 to create some play but it just looks
like black is in time and I love that
move he's going for your idea your
philosophy your up material you trade
off as many pieces as possible if the
Queens are off the board Magnus Carlson
wins hands down but I don't see a good
Square you can't come on the C file The
Rook will slide down to the C file
winning another Tempo that doesn't help
uh this looks like magnus's game
yeah even with like Queen D1 Bishop C3
hits The Rook hits these pawns that are
in a row here it seems like at some
point soon maybe bishop H4 by the way
hitting this Knight to this Rook it
feels like Max will continue to trade
off pieces I think we can confidently
say that he is in charge in this one and
so maybe as you know this game is
nearing its conclusion we'll take a step
out because I'm looking at the bottom
two boards the bottom row there we
haven't looked at razvant preo to that
was my X Factor he has a big advantage
against Grandmaster Roundup sedwani and
in the bottom right Jennifer you she's
hanging in there against Vida guzrathio
that one is earlier so I do think we
should go to resident Pro 2 against
raunak sudwani because as we tune into
that one Tanya it's not even like white
has a single extra pawn and yet the
evaluation says plus two in resven's
favor
wow and I think this is a huge huge
board for both these players and ironic
in big trouble here like you mentioned
well the material is equal and white is
being given this huge Edge and the
reason for that is the white has got big
space has got the two Bishops so in the
long run white will be better white can
create a queen side passer as well we
can imagine a move like B5 coming in and
that pawn rolling down the board
meanwhile where is Black's counter play
it's hard to imagine the Black Knight
jumping in anywhere the bishop on F1
notice how strong it is not only
covering the G2 square but in certain
moments eyeing that A6 weakness which is
the reason that our eval bar loves prior
to his position razman doing well here
and this is scary stuff for the Indian
yogis
yeah and I think that Raonic he's trying
to use activity for his pieces he is
down on the clock but he wants some kind
of Knight E5 go after the C4 Pawn so I
think that Raza can safely preempt all
that let's get a fourth Pawn on the
fourth rank just take away that E5
square but no he goes Knight A4 he wants
the Knight into B6 where it hits the
rook in defense C4 but I think for
Roundup it's now or never you just need
to start bringing pieces over to the
king side otherwise you will never have
active play of your own
that's a really important move 95 as
you're pointing out it doesn't only hit
C4 but it also hits that E4 Pawn in the
center notice how the bishop on B7
suddenly comes into the game Knight B6
hitting the Rook a very natural move but
I see our eval bar doesn't like it what
are we missing can you just pick up the
pawn because the Rook on B1 hangs as
well
yeah it looks like perhaps you could
take this big but this this is a lot to
calculate D6 is hanging c8's hanging E4
can be captured right now the bishop
takes E4 it certainly looks like a
viable option and Raonic you know him he
is such a tactical brilliant kid he says
Bishop takes E4 give me that Eva barbs
they're all hovering around the center
so there's something better that I'm
gonna cheat I'm gonna very quickly cheat
and see what it was oh come on it was
Knight H4 going for the F3 Square over
here and even after King to H1 there
probably is this move Knight E to F3 is
trying to go after this Fork here of
course the E4 Pawn is hanging this is
wild stuff I don't blame brownie playing
Bishop pixie four and whoa F4 from
rasvin prior to he says take this Rook
I'll take your knight with Tempo against
your queen your Rook is hanging your
Bishop will be hanging back here this is
spicing up very quickly what does even
think happening is as if every single
piece on the board hangs F4 hits the
Knight black has got two pieces which
are Under Fire right now black can pick
up the rook and B1 but that would just
look like it loses a lot of material
maybe the best thing that you can do is
try to defend the Knight but watch out
if you move that night that gives
additional options for white to actually
step in with the Knight to D7 once The
Rook moves away Bishop D4 as you're
pointing out continuing the pressure it
is it is wild I'm trying to get my head
around all these complications and the
players have about two minutes to do
that ronak needs to come up with a move
and it looks like it's not an easy one
here no not at all just to finish off
this variation Queen H4 threatens
Checkmate you played G3 hitting the
queen and protecting this H2 square at
once E4 is hanging Rook at C8 is hanging
the Queen's under attack white would be
winning material and the game so you see
that Roundup was not expecting F4 he is
down to a minute and 40 seconds for this
complicated position by the way Magnus
Carlson did win that game against
vaishali no surprises there uh the other
games are still in full swing but I
think we have to see what Roundup will
play after F4 because Tony I'm being
honest I actually don't see that easy of
a move here this Knight on B6 is such a
heroic piece it defends the C4 Pawn in
addition to attacking this Rook this
Knight's under attack this Rook can be
captured but we're talking about how
that's good for white you get at least
maybe two pieces for The Rook here and
in an open board that will be good for
white he takes it
wow he picks up the brook and that means
that white can pick up the Knight
hitting that Queen gaining more time
with another Tempo the bishop on B1
hacks The Rook can see eight hangs you
don't have time to pick up that pawn it
is hard to understand what ronak wants
it looks like he's panicked with just a
minute on the clock Robert how hard is
it to defend this position
with four plus minutes for Razz and
priyotu it looks nearly impossible what
happens if white simply takes this Rook
let's do a material count
after Knight takes Rook white will
temporarily be up eight piece a bishop
for Just Two pawns and if you take the
Knight you lose your bishop and this is
what Raonic is going for but he is
trying to get this third Pawn uh for the
piece unfortunately for him the D6 Pawn
is also loose so just to show Rook takes
B1 oh wait wait wait wait quick tactic
Rook B1 there's Knight F3 check hitting
the king and forking the queen and after
Pawn takes there's Queen G6 check
rounding says not so fast
that is just incredible tactics on the
board and has ironic see in this rabbit
is this the whole idea because I can't
imagine him going into a position where
he's down an entire piece those pawns
will not be enough but even this
position with white having the two
Bishops it is Advantage razwan even
after these complications
yeah two Bishops are here and D6 is
hanging that's been a very important
Pawn because then white gets a passer so
this the players they don't know the
evaluation I mean this is looking very
sky-high That's The Power of these
neural net engines they said tell you
it's completely winning even though it
still looks complicated but that is why
rasmine pirito has paused he's seeing
Knight F3 checkpoint now he allows it
he's that strong himself where he sees
it he recognizes still good for white he
needs to bring his King up rather than
to the side over here bring it towards
the other Bishops and then take this
Pawn have no fear
oh my gosh and he does it he does it
what a beast he does it in seconds he
knows that the Bishops are strong enough
to defend that King and now once again
run it down to just a minute on the
clock he needs to find a way to get that
Rook into the game but notice how
White's Queen has taken away the d8
square has taken away the B8 Square how
will the Rook ever assist the queen in
the attack and that is the problem with
Ron Exposition imagine if that could
happen if the Rook could just jump over
the pawn like a knight that's not
allowed in chess and it looks like this
is huge trouble for ronak razwan on fire
calculating these lines till the end
well The Rook can jump to C4 but can it
because Robert take a look at this you
can go Rook C4 saying that the bishop is
Finn but you know what Ross once
calculated just to move ahead you give a
check with the queen today forcing the
king to 8-7 bad spot but the only one
and now the queen slides back to D3 and
actually wins that rook and wins the
game and with that blackstroke is
absolutely paralyzed on C8
and that is exactly why Roundup A5 but
that should only help White's cause
after A5 B5 played B6 B7 is automatic
you can also support the b-pawn with the
c Pawn as well
um E6 I guess what Roundup wants is to
quickly bring the queen behind the pass
pawn and hope that the a pawn is going
to be sufficient for counter play here
so that is why it's so important to have
a lead on the clock round it down to 22
seconds but razzmat preo to two minutes
45 seconds he can calculate here is B6
the right move should he play C5 and
lead with the c Pawn can he hit this
Rook just make that Rook decide where it
needs to go uh so he has options here
and Roundup does not have much time by
the way the other boards it's looking
like it's pretty level on them that
would be great news for the chess bras
because look at the board four there
Jennifer you against Vida guzron the
eval bar saying it's about level and in
the top right we see a double Rook end
game where orientari is up upon it may
be about level maybe a draw can be held
but it's suggesting that the chest bras
are in for a big first round
absolutely I mean a top right board
Aryan is the only one who can try in
this position having that extra Pawn we
see his last move he does give one of
them away but in the process destroying
White's a king side structure it would
mean a double Pawn uh if white was to
pick up the pawn on F4 and uh it looks
like just the chest press are on their
way to their first match when Magnus has
already defeated vaishali and what a
game by razwan priyutu he looks like
he's on the way to pick up that second
game point and a check here wow watch
out for that King on H2 Robert this
could be a mating attack just imagine a
check on the H file with the other rook
and that would be game over
yes and look at and go after the F2 Pawn
this is what these top GMS do is they
don't just allow an easy draw to be made
they say I still have chances here but
right now Ari antari is down to his
waning seconds he needs to find moves he
pushes Pawn to A3 if this Pawn F2 were
captured A4 would have been lost so Rook
A7 give up F2 get the a pawn and it
should just barely be enough for white
to hold the draw the king is safe enough
but that's why I think aryan's gonna
play moving Rook A1 just try to scare
this King
but it might be enough for aronia to
hold the position if he can pick up that
a pawn but it might not be enough for
the Indian yogis to get this draw
they're already down one game point and
it looks like ironic is on the verge of
losing as well against razwan so this
draw will not help the Indian yogis no
this one certainly will be a draw just
because you can't bring this other Rook
back far enough mating one Robert Maiden
one Rook H4 was a huge threat we've been
talking about getting that Rook to the H
file and in the process he threatened it
and won the other Pawn this will end in
a draw now okay so we know this one is
going to be a draw let's get away from
here we trust orientare and oronia gosh
to split the point and in the bottom
left it still is all rasmine priority
but viruku's he looks like he's on his
way to scoring a big win for the Indian
yogis against Jennifer Yu she's been
playing well but it might not be enough
so let's go back to prio2 and saidwani
because now all of a sudden preo2 down
to about 30 seconds and we know how good
Roundup is in bullet this Pawn is one
square away from promotion while white
has two passers and white is covering
the very important Queenie Square
it's getting a bit tricky you know these
kind of positions sure you know the eval
Bar says that white is completely
winning black is busted but it's not
over till it's over that pawn as you're
pointing out A1 and it would be game
over but luckily for white the bishop
can be sacrificed for the pawn and the
C6 B6 marching down the board it would
be just enough to win we're seeing this
line being played out you don't have
time to capture on B6 because then the
bishop will hop back and defend the
check instead C7 wow this is a blowout
what a conversion by raswan look at
those two pawns supported by the queen
queen C6 Queen dhx so many ideas on the
board and this is game over and that is
it ronak resigns and with that with that
in fact we already have a winner of the
round one it is the Canadian chess bras
take this round
right and we had to remember that it's
the first team to reach eight and a half
points so uh this is a big game in the
bottom right for vidic Gujarati because
while we know Canada will exit round one
with a lead in the match look at this
position it is Rook Knight and four
pawns per side you think that's even
material that should just be a draw
right no because black has unopposed
passers here on the queen side and
they're about to run over okay when it's
not mate there is 91 so you are able to
block this and vid it it needs to become
in mutual time trouble but Tanya
Jennifer you're down to three seconds
left and in a much worse position with
those pass pawns rolling down the board
well this would be a very important
point for the Yogi so with it needs to
deliver in this one you have to make
sure that the margin is as less as
possible so that you have a chance to
come back and we see visit them marching
down the board White Knight and Rook are
just so badly placed it's hard to find
any counter player the pawns are far
away from queening for white meanwhile
black just there with two steps a to A1
could not be stopped and with that with
it takes a very important loan win for
the Indian yogis and he takes a step
away from his computer but a big victory
for vidit Gujarati in that one we see
the score two and a half one half in
favor of the candid chess bras Magnus
Carlson he gets the job done it's not
very surprising when board one takes on
board four but Raz Von priyotu he is
maybe the unsung hero in the entire Pro
chess League he scores a huge win over
the more highly rated Roundup sedwani so
Tanya it's a one point difference I
think it's coming down to those middle
boards I'm just in I'm amazed priorities
play in week one and defeating somebody
like ronak a very strong player in these
fast formats not just winning the game
but the style in which he did it what a
game that was by prior to I completely
get your sentiment there uh Robert that
sure the chess bras have gotten Magnus
Carlsen with priyoto could very well be
their MVP
for sure well the Pro 2 he controlled
that game the chess Bros controlled the
scoreboard right now two and a half one
half but the players get a break they
get to reset then the second round of
action is going to heat up here at the
pro chess League week two matchup
between the Canada chess bras and the
Indian yogis we'll be right back
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
of the Canada chest bras wearing a botez
live hoodie so he's really bring Canada
back with him Tanya we saw him win game
one what do you think we have in store
what kind of magnets are we gonna see
today
I mean it's clear it wasn't just the
wind but the way he did it it wasn't
dominating fashion that went with the
black pieces and talking of fashion you
pointed out his hoodie I have to say
magnus's hair deserves this dream of its
own what even is going on there Robert
it is Unstoppable just like magnus's
performance yes the hair is the world
champion just like Magnus Carlson has
been the world champion he has won the
five-time world champion with four
consecutive title defenses a four-time
world rapid chess champion and the
current world rapid chess champion a
six-time world Blitz chess champion and
the current world Blitz chess champion
and he has been the number one rated
player in the world in classical rating
since July of 2011. the second longest
reign in Theater history behind Gary
Kasparov and of course he went 4-0 last
week started with a win this week he may
be unstoppable
uh it's I mean I'm just looking at that
record that's a lot of world chess
champion titles and uh of course he is
Magnus is good right and every single
point that the Indian yogis can try and
save against him would be would be huge
for the Indian team but currently we are
going into round to round one the Canada
chess bras did win but I have to say
Robert that was with the smallest of
margins
it was indeed and you could any single
round upsets can happen and if you look
at the round two lineups we see Magnus
Carlson orientare with the white pieces
against the international masters from
the yogis oronia gauche and vaishali get
the black pieces against Magnus and
Aryan respectively that's an uphill
battle but then we see that vidit and
rauna get the white pieces against prior
to and Jennifer you but Tanya I keep
saying it Raz van preo2 he's my X Factor
I think if he's able to hold off vidy
Gujarati where he has the black pieces
that would be huge for the chess Bros
chances I think you're absolutely right
I think that is the key game to decide
this round now as I see as a possible
strategy for the yogis to come back
would be to try to win on both three and
board four at least on paper with it is
a favorite in this one ronak playing
against Jennifer ronic again a favorite
in this one but he had a very shaky
round one Jennifer meanwhile if she can
hold on and she can start scoring and
make sure that Ronan doesn't take that
when that would be bad news while on the
top two boards I think we've got again a
huge favorite with the chess bras it's
hard to bet it's hard to bet against
Magnus so I think it really comes down
to that second board as well if we can
uh if at least if the Indian yogis can
try to get one draw in those top two
boards it's the only way I see them
making a comeback in this round
well right now Magnus Carlson may be
texting some friends uh looking at some
quick lines but the clocks are starting
so he better sit right back in this
chair here he goes he's putting the
phone away and
I don't know what he's doing on the
phone but uh either way maybe we
shouldn't uh give away his secrets on
his phone if we can avoid it uh but
Knight F3 uh played here by Magnus he
starts with the ready and well Tanya you
know aronia gauche I mean he's a very
strong talented up and coming player uh
what do you think his chances are like
against Magnus here
chances against Magnus are usually quite
Bleak let me just put it out there of it
but of course you know it is this format
anything can happen we have seen a
Wonder come up with a wonderful winning
position but again only to throw that
away so even getting a better or a
winning position against Magnus is off
the job done uh aroniak has a huge task
ahead of him what I can't tell you about
him is that he is an extremely concrete
and sharp player he has to make sure
he's not intimidated by the player he's
playing against go for those sharp lines
and keep a control on the clock talking
about the clock what is he doing why has
he not made a move already he's down by
a minute
yeah well Arun yuck he's thinking maybe
he's scared of magnus's hair which seems
to be going up up and away every single
time we see Magnus the hair continues to
balloon there and uh we're getting word
that uh on magnus's phone he's not
texting he's not looking at chess uh it
is the fair play camera so all players
in the Pro chest so you have to have
multiple cameras on they're in a call
with the Fairplay team at chess.com so
shout out to them for ensuring that
everything is safe and sound and whoa
what is happening in this game we're
getting the Swiss cheese Pawn structure
for white you're going G3 and then E3
and look at all these light squares but
I'm running with B5 and Magnus switches
diagonals with his Bishop instead of
feeding Kettering goes after the B5 Pawn
just an incredible opening from the
start and that's exactly what we saw
vaishali do but it didn't end so well
and now Magnus eventually just fan
shadowing and then getting his King to
safety very often white will break on
the queen side with the Apon advancing
trying to Target that early Advance by
the B Pawn uh Magnus first continues
with development I'm looking at magnus's
setup here where he's playing for from
and I have to say Robert it looks rather
messy just like the kind of openings
that we've been seeing from him but also
I think this is this is where he streams
from we see those other streaming chairs
where we often see his friends and this
is where he ends up playing uh and
streaming from so interesting to see
that little background there
yes and he's looking like Simba over
there his main continues to grow and
it's adult Simba he is the world chess
champion he is an absolute monster and
he just decided to strike with the move
of C4 just saying what are you gonna do
about this Pawn tension I'm not sure
that white is really threatening to take
on B5 you typically don't want to give
up a more Central Pawn for what amounts
to a flank Pawn a rook Pawn because once
this trade happens the a file will open
up this Rook an eight uh but he's just
going to oh okay well ronak decides to
take on so far I wasn't expecting that I
thought he would leave the tension and
you see Tanya the eval bar immediately
suggesting that white is much better
after black took on C4 and the reason
for that is that the B file has opened
up and it gives white more tempers to
finish development while notice how
Black's King side is still on the
developed is still it needs aronia still
needs to develop that Bishop needs to
get his King into safety while Magnus
now has all the temples and the chances
on the other side of the board to
continue putting pressure definitely a
surprising decision that by aronia to
take on C4 and he might have to pay a
price for it in terms of not being able
to complete his development
yeah that's one of those inaccuracies
that it looked like an innocent decision
right you just took a Pawn on C4 but
white gets The Rook to the open file
lacks Rook now sitting passive and A6
seems like it'll be easier to Target in
the future not to mention that White's
King is safely Castle Black's King is in
the center so if I were Magnus I think I
could just push my d-pawn forward why
not and he does just that and maybe
he'll even push it one square more to
block in this bishop saying your fianca
Bishop stares into my own Pawn this
should be good news for magnets I love
that idea so he does strike in the
center and as you're mentioning that
evaroniak was to continue taking out his
own Bishop to E7 white has the option of
asking more questions in the center with
the move D5 you never want to fix the
center with E5 after that trying to say
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna play
blocked and safe but that just gives so
many weaknesses look at those two
Bishops not only are they horrendous
White's Knight can at some point jump to
F5 and jump from H4 to F5 can go from D2
to E4 so many ideas in this position it
just looks like a strategically bad
opening outcome for aronia how does
Magnus end up doing this he comes with
his hair with his hoodie on and then 10
moves into the game and we're saying
aroniak is in trouble
because Magnus is Magnus he's gonna do
world champion things that I don't
understand and don't pretend to
comprehend but Magnus Carlson has an
advantage with the white pieces he's a
spatial advantage in the center is king
of his castle the black king is not and
I expect D5 to be up next and if you
take on uh D4 just to show this quickly
that white is still going to put a Pawn
on D5 most likely if you played Bishop
E7 then white continues with D5 and just
because a set of Pawns have been traded
doesn't change the fact that there are
these ugly Bishops in Black's position
and not to mention this that's not the
right Square E3 this bishop can come out
on the bigger diagonal so I do like this
position for Magnus he plays D5 quickly
and ronak takes on D5 I expect after C
takes this bishop 1 B7 will not be a
happy camper so Tanya Advantage Magnus
Carlson that's the statement we have
said countless times before and probably
will in the future as well but also take
a look at the clock what is this Magnus
effect not just a position but aronia
down by almost four minutes on the clock
Magnus meanwhile continues to take more
space in the center now with this e-pawn
having Advanced you always have to watch
out for a threat like E5 which is why
aroniac had to slide down with the Rook
to locate that square for the bishop on
f8 uh and he does it comes back nauru
comes to the center of the board you're
pointing out bringing the Knight always
watch out for an E5 Central break it
just looks like White's the one with all
the plans in the center and in this game
while aroniac with that dead Bishop on
B7 without that Bishop on f8 is going to
struggle to find improving moves yeah
and before we go to the bird's eye view
I just want to say this looks like a
benoni it but only gone wrong for black
because normally in the benoni black has
some counter play some C4 pushes maybe
some kind of G6 Bishop G7 but also feels
very slow at this point where white
pieces on their best squares so this
game will continue Magnus Carlson has
the advantage for now we'll see if he's
able to punish aronia for that bad Pawn
trade many moves ago but for now let's
go to our four board scene because every
single game the protesting is of equal
importance it's one point towards your
team's total score if you're able to win
so let's look across the four boards
here ton in the top right by shali with
the black pieces against orientari I
actually quite like her position it
looks stable but her clock management
once again bothers me Tanya she is down
several minutes on the clock I think
that's a theme that we'll keep seeing
clock is as much of a part of the game
as the board is in these formats you
have to make sure you don't fall back
too low compared to your opponent now
you mentioned the position looks fine
and at first sight it really does but
just in our heads let's just imagine all
the trades on D5 and I think Aryan is
going for that as we can see what will
end up happening is an end game where
black is left with an isolated Queen
spawn let's say if you pick up with the
queen you trade the Queens as well and
this kind of a position Robert White is
playing for two results because Black's
the one with the glaring weakness on the
board The Rook can come to D1 whether
you take it with the pawn whether you
keep the Queens on the board whether you
trade them off vaishali is going to be
the one with a huge weakness of that D5
Central Pawn and I think regardless of
whether the eval Bar says this is even
or not the position is not looking great
for black
and you see the Queens are off you
called it Tanya and one of the big
things about an endgame like this is
Rook fd1 is automatic uh this Pawn on D5
it's a Target and it may be lost at some
moment but black often says you take
material I'll take play bring a rook to
the C file and up to a square like C2
but that said also these pawns are weak
as well you kind of wish you could push
this Pawn back to A6 uh for now these
pawns are disconnected from one another
and they will be targets for the white
Rooks and with vaishali still down uh
almost two minutes on the clock I'm just
worried because the difficult position
to hold Even In classical chess let
alone a rapid time control where you are
down on time to your opponent
vaishali has a mammoth task of trying to
defend a difficult end game and we often
talk about pawns and weaknesses in terms
of Pawn Islands that's really the
easiest way to understand the side which
has few up on islands is the one that
has a better structure so therefore an
advantage and here we see orientarius
got just two islands now we all love an
island visit but it should not be on the
chessboard where Charlie here has got
free Pawn Islands one on the king side
one in the center of the board and the
two pawns are on the side so definitely
an end game that's going to be a bit of
a grind I think Aryan is going to push
this out till the end where shali might
survive it but she's got a lot of work
to do and good technique to show
meanwhile there is a lot of middle game
action on our board so let's bring up
our bird's eye view Robert and take a
look at what's going on
okay well we've looked at uh boards one
and two for the chest bras in the top
left and top right in the bottom left
vidit Gujarati the board one for Indian
yogis against rasmine preo2 that looks
like a very solid position so once again
rasmine priyotu it looks like he is
doing quite fine and in the bottom right
we have a very closed position between
roundocks and wani and Jenna for you in
fact the eval Bar says that Jennifer you
has a better position in the bottom
right that's board four for the can
chest bras just because she's the pair
of Bishops she controls some of the pawn
breaks but I do want to uh first look at
the game between rasvan and bit it
because Tanya rasmine prio to all season
long I mean it's only week two so it's
not like it's been a long season but in
these first two weeks he has been an
absolute star for the chess Bros with
Eric Hansen on last week he said that
resin was actually one of his first
pickups because he felt he was severely
underrated and playing from Canada he
gives that local Vibe and uh you know he
is someone that Panda really is happy to
have
and what a pick he's been in the protest
league so far and as as well as his form
today we look at this position with the
black pieces it really does look like
he's got everything under control with
it he's a very slow positional strategic
player and even though there might not
be crazy action going on it's exactly
the kind of positions that vidit enjoys
as well just maneuvering a little bit on
this side of the board just small pawn
moves and what he's done with that
Knight on D2 is heading to that Central
Square to E4 which will then ask
questions to Black Bishop now imagine
that Bishop falls back to E7 and White's
Bishop is the one who takes this long
diagonal stepping onto B2 and then
suddenly we'll start talking about the
queen coming to G4 threatening the G7
square and things are going to start
seeming to be pretty wild
yeah I mean it actually seems very
straightforward in White's favor after
that sequence because black wants to
Target this Pawn on D3 there's already
one Rook let's bring a second Rook but
as you're highlighting white will
quickly jump forward Knight E4 Bishop B2
Queen G4 black does need to be careful
here so what other moves come to mind uh
maybe you're not actually afraid of this
Knight taking this bishop so you tried
to bring the queen to E7 first just to
defend the piece and then doubling up
your Rook something like that is a
possibility but we can see by the time
consumption here resven not feeling
totally comfortable given this last of
Knight D2 I really like that from vidit
going to E4 and they say the hardest
moves in chess are retreating moves and
they're definitely difficult to spot and
there we've got Queen to C6 razman has
taken a decision and now it's really up
to with it does he put that Knight on e4
or go with the other idea of trying to
put it on B3 but I really like the move
Knight E4 you centralize it and razman
falling back with the bishop I would be
happy to make the move Bishop B2 but
that could be tactics we have to
constantly be aware of things going on
in this position Robert black is
threatening a devious Knight takes C4
because that pawn on D3 is currently
overloaded it is defending the C4 Pawn
as well as the Knight on e4 so you've
got to calculate what's really going on
after Bishop B2 Knight C4 the queen can
jump to G4 threatening mate but that
would mean black simply captures the
bishop on B2 and is a happy camper with
an extra Pawn so there with that queen
move to C6 that is a tricky way to fight
against with its plan of getting the
pieces into the attack smart stuff by
Rosman there smarts up by him great find
by you so Knight takes C4 is already a
threat regardless of if the bishop goes
to B2 because the Knight is loose and if
your best choice is to move this Knight
again did I think that razzmat really
did the right thing he brought his Queen
up one square he didn't really do all
that much in the position bringing the
queen uh to C6 but he is threatening
this Knight takes C4 and that's why
vidit has pause if your best move is
Knight G3 let's say a move like that
well and black maybe can just start
doubling the Rooks and going after the
D3 Pawn so I like what resmon is doing I
don't think for this position is
problematic I think it is quite a stable
game for both sides and that's an
advantage for black if you think about
it you had the uh you know second move
you usually are have a worse position on
the opening you're also the low rated
player the candid chess Bros can have
learned to just rely on Resident prior
to he is a cool customer
and that's exactly the kind of Dream
Team you need right you've got Magnus
Carlton leading from the top and in the
bottom board you've got a player like
Rosman who seems to be really holding
Ford and bringing in the points he's up
against Indian Yogi's FrontRunner with
it and it seems like with it's not going
to have an easy one here raswan with the
black pieces has managed to equalize out
of the opening black has got a clear
Target on D3 but with it once with this
Knight Retreat he's really trying to put
pressure on razwan's King here now
imagine the Knight jumps to H5 the
bishop comes to B2 the queen comes to G4
that G7 Pawn can start looking extremely
tender and that is big trouble it also
sidesteps the big tactic that we've been
talking about with that Knight C4 thread
so I like this move by with it Knight to
G3 uh eyeing the king side sidestepping
threats but of course Black's position
is super solid Robert there are no
weaknesses yet this is going to be a
long one the pressure is on with it for
his team currently down by around he
knows that they're looking at at him to
get the win
they are definitely looking at him to
get the win because if we zoom out from
this game where it remains a balanced
Affair chances for both sides we see in
the top left Magnus Carlson is
completely winning against aronia gauche
in the top right orientare against
vaishali that's a two Rook end game
where white has the healthier Pawn
structure and a lead on the clock but
the and the bottom right Jennifer you
with the black pieces against Ronald
savani in Advantage for her at the
moment but let's go to magnus's game the
world champion he always deserves of
attention put on his game he's head on
the board he's ahead on the clock and he
may be in mop-up Duty right now he
doesn't even look like he's excited but
right now white is up a pawn it's a
healthy outside pass Pawn that can go up
the board The Rook is under attack uh
May Rook B8 even traps and wins this
bishop uh wow this actually just looks
completely over
it does look at that Bishop on a head
that is not even worth calling a bishop
in this position it's got no future at
all now usually in the benoni structures
that black has black does sacrifice upon
but gets control of open files like the
open b line or the C line but here we
see it's Magnus who's up upon but also
has full domination on the only open
files in the board that gives him huge
Advantage he goes on to win a second
pawn and this uh was this came in with a
tactic where at least what black managed
to get that a pawn but I'm scared for
that Bishop on it where is this queen
going let's say you go to E1 white
screen can jump onto C7 hit that Rook
the position falls apart for black move
by move
yeah Queen D7 looks pretty good also
Rook a seven doesn't win just yet
because of Rook E7 but if you kick The
Rook over here and then play Rook A7
you're gonna barrel down the seventh
ranked Magnus Carlson yeah he just sees
it instantly he's going for it you can't
stop this Checkmate without sacrificing
a piece on B7 and a full extra piece and
pawn from Magnus Carlsen a will settle
thing
it's time to resign aroniac is
considering throwing in the towel he's
down to less than a minute and he does
it it was all over Robert as you're
pointing out Queen F7 is a massive
threat black has to give up a bishop
loses the game well with that once again
Magnus showing up for his theme and
takes the lead in round two
and Max Carlson was still seated he's
looking at the analysis just trying
trying to go over how well he played and
in the top right we've talked about
orientare against vaishali uh by
Charlotte you need to start moving you
are down to a minute on the clock
meanwhile on the bottom left vidit has
the upper hand with that Bishop the dark
Square Bishop implanted on the F6 Square
entrench in there going for checkmating
attack and the bottom right still
Jennifer you in the driver's seat but
why don't we tune in to orientari and
vaishali just because it's super
important right now for the Indian yogis
that she holds this game Tanya she has
been performing well in the protesting
week one she beat soupy she Drew another
game one after three was a fantastic
performance for her but right now it
looks like orientare is stealing a Pawn
on A5
he absolutely is and that is a very
healthy Pawn the A2 Pawn is going to
start marching down the board notice how
it's the same color Bishop once again
the mammoth task of defunding a very
difficult ending continues for vaishali
we were talking about her weakness of
the pawn structure she is paying the
price for it she she plays H5 and it
might look like wait a second she's
hanging upon but it would be the dream
if Aryan actually goes to pick up that
pawn giving up the A2 Pawn you don't
want to let go of this amazing intense
parcel that can potentially decide the
game I don't believe he wants to trade
the pawns he doesn't he pushes the pawn
down the board the idea is clear move up
The Rook keep advancing the pawn notice
how once the pawn gets to A7 it is in
fact defended by that Bishop on F2 white
will slide away The Rook from that A8
Square Queen the pawn and Robert that's
the winning plan it's actually that
simple so what black may need to do is
once all this happens because it's more
or less Force once The Rook goes they
actually let's put this on the board
because I don't really see how black can
get a out of it but let's just make some
moves just make some moves and then once
we get a position like uh we can't go A7
yet but I'll try to get there once you
get a position like this and The Rook
moves there may be some kind of Rook
takes F2 King takes and Bishop C5 check
and she'll hope that she can draw and
exchange down you see the evaluation
saying completely winning for white it
is especially with the pawn structure
the way it is but I think that's at best
foreign you may just see this exact
sequence because you can't stop this
Pawn from going up to A7
wow so this again looks like a very
difficult endgame as you're pointing out
the only defense resource it when that
doesn't look good enough either you know
that it's a tough task ahead of it which
means it once again comes down to the
other two boards and let's bring our
bird's eye view we see this one it looks
like aryan's going for the plan that we
pointed at and it's my eyes are drawn to
that Jennifer ronic match up there it is
a wild position on the board I love how
Jennifer has played it looks like she
has all the activity I don't care what
the eval Bar says right now loving that
centralized Queen on E5 that Rook on A6
which can jump over slide over to the
king side whenever it's required when
there's a trade on E6 it looks like she
has everything under control I say that
but then I also see the trumps in
White's position you've got this D5
Square for your knight that you can
always come into he wants to trade off
the bishop the only defender of that D5
square and imagine if that was to happen
Robert compare that white knight to the
black Bishop and suddenly you're not
sure which side you're picking yeah I
would love to have a knight on D5 if
these bishops come off the board so if I
am Jennifer you I'm thinking do I trade
here and then take on F4 I really want
to get rid of the Knight but I also know
that if I take on a four in Comes This G
Pawn as another attacker that Palm will
continue going up the board towards the
black king and Jennifer she's having the
vaishali problem she's down to about a
minute on her clock and I think you
don't want to play Bishop takes F4
because a pawn takes but she realized an
ion D5 would be very strong
it's such a practical choice but now you
have to start looking at King's safety
white can actually and I say that with
white skin being the one on H3 but
imagine if white does get this F Pawn
rolling down to F5 and I think F5 is
coming next you're suddenly threatening
a check on F6 with the queen coming onto
the dark squares you're threatening the
G6 pawn and it just looks like black
might have to be the one careful of uh
her king queen E6 check and this just
invites the move F5 I am itching to see
F5 on the board Robert yes an F5 the
best news for Jennifer is what you
called out Tanya The Rook on A6 was
helpful and whoa King and true Allah's
black to play F5 I think that if you're
Jennifer you do not want to see F5 from
White so you play F5 yourself I I know
that you give your opponent a healthy
protected pass Pawn but I think with the
rook and the queen in perfect position
you can blockade its progress but
Jennifer did a 20 seconds she
finds it yeah she's just moving too
slowly that's what makes me nervous for
her is even if she's playing good moves
you need to have enough time remaining
the two second increment that the
players get will be vital
super important well the players but
we've spoken about this increment it is
so deceptive because you can barely add
up on time it is just about enough to
make a move and Ron if they're keeping
the pressure in the center alive not
blocking because he's playing the clock
as much as the position now control over
the E file and though Jennifer found
that move F5 which stops the immediate
Avalanche of the king side pawns it's
still a very difficult position to
defend in 20 seconds right open E file
open G file as well but quickly let's go
to the bird's eye view because big news
and not good news for the Indian yogis
look at the bottom left of your screen
resverat priyotu that is The X Factor
for team candid chess Bros he is
completely winning let's go there now
The Rook is under attack and it's not
just the Rook Queen F1 leads to
Checkmate so if you slide your Rook over
thinking okay I'll protect my rook in
comes Queen F1 with a back rank mate
just to show that Queen F1 you have to
take the Rook comes next to the King The
Rook on G2 is boxing the king in and
that means it would be Checkmate on the
F1 square and that means for visit
Gujarati he has to bring his Queen back
with an in comes the black rook and all
of a sudden black is on the attack white
is temporarily up one Pawn but it's not
just about the quantity of pieces about
the quality of them with white on the
back foot The Rook coming in to win the
G4 Pawn next it's the white king that is
in big trouble and look at how quickly
priority plays
I just used
these things water stop
he says he sacrificed the bond and now
he's got all the initiative in the
attack I don't see how with it can't
keep that G4 Pawn alive this is a huge
moment for the Indian yogis with it
needs to find a way to save this one you
can't go with your H Pawn to H3 the
queen simply snaps it off a move like G5
you definitely don't want to me you
definitely don't want to go there with
the Knight jumping on to F5 and then to
E3 that starts looking super scary for
white with Gujarati in big trouble here
Raz vent preo2 rated 2493 he clearly is
underrated especially in these rapid
type girls he won the recent Charlotte
open he tied with OLX under bordnick so
he's had some over-the-board classical
success wait it's mate Queen F1 Queen
and with it
finding it and a smile there by Rosman
he deserves it what a finish and what a
beautiful Checkmate The Rook picks up
the queen The Rook delivers the maid on
F1 a huge point for the Canadian chess
bras by the super talented Canadian
Grandmaster there seriously maybe the
most like underappreciated player in the
world right now in terms of the protest
League everyone should want him on the
team and because if you were predicting
what would happen in our featured
question would there be a queen
sacrifice you hit the over Queen F1 was
a queen sacrifice so for all of you who
picked the over you could thank Rez run
preo to but we are going to head on over
to our one remaining game because
raunich said wani suddenly he is taking
a huge advantage in Jennifer Yu's time
travel because in the bottom right you
see the eval bar going up up and away
but it's maybe not so easy it's perhaps
the engine can be misleading here tiny
to the King on H3 there's a black Rook
on A2 but the eval Bar says completely
winning for white
yeah and that is what is so crazy about
this position right you've got your King
on H3 black species are active and look
at that Rook sliding down to D2 super
scary stuff Rook D3 coming in with a
check and it's just hard to understand
why the eval bar loves White's position
so much and unless there is something
direct happening I don't know a move
like H5 and it's on the board because
you just say that black has got one rook
in the attack the king will escape from
the check but wait a second how is black
going to escape with the check on G6 and
this might be the reason why black is
busted here King G4 H just forces
resignation the king is actually safe
from All Checks even though it's on a
very Advanced Square so a win for round
exoduani that is huge for the Indian
yogis because while they're trailing by
three full points it was a dominant
round for the candle chess bras they
needed this game from roundness and one
hoping to turn their fortunes around but
the chess bras they were superb in round
two Magnus Carlsen he wins with white
over aronia
wins an end game against vaishali no
surprise there but the biggest surprise
in the entire Pro chess League season I
want to say has been resident prior to
he wins with black over super Grand
Master Vita Gujarati so Tanya ronix and
wani he does get that one win for the
Indian yogis is it already too little
too late
it's starting to feel like that I mean a
3-1 win is destruction right now and
that gives the Canadian chess bras such
a big lead we see a Raz on priyoto and
you and I know Robert you've been a fan
of his from the start from week one he's
really showing how good he is here with
that win against with it a super point
but there's still two more rounds to go
but of course the Indian yogis have a
lot of covering up to do and need to win
and win big in the next round Rosman
prior to beat board one and board two
for the Indian yogis he is the GM Slayer
right now as is Magnus Carlson he always
is and somebody who is used to slaying
his opponent somebody who you know shows
up every single night on the basketball
court rather than the chessboard is Luca
dancers chess and basketball history has
been made as four-time NBA All-Star Luka
donches has Unleashed his sidekick
luke.ai on the chest world the new bot
joins this month's slew of AI chess Bots
that you can challenge right now the
loop.ai bot is still learning the ins
and outs of Chess but the more plays the
stronger it grows how strong will
luke.aib by well yesterday when it
battles your favorite streamers and
chess play quick that much was up to you
it's over but the loop.ai bot Still
Remains you should play it Luka donchic
does not play around he's one of the
best basketball players on the planet
but for now we will send us to break
when we return it is round three of this
match between the candid chess Bros and
the India yogis stay tuned we'll be
right back
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
play against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
es from over 35 lessons created for all
skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices today
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
in competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely days are over
[Applause]
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
they are having a party in France
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives the wheels came off wow she
just took down Hikaru knuckleberry and
look at her she is jubilant entering its
Fifth Season 16 teams will reboot the
PCL Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion what
what oh my gosh my friends it's the 2023
Pro chess League which team can Rise
Above the Rest they won't be able to do
it alone
we win
oh my God
the man you see on the screen in front
of you perhaps the MVP and no that is
not Magnus Carlson lurking in the
shadows that is Raz van priyotu the
third board for the Canada chess bras
Tanya he has been absolutely phenomenal
he beat board one of the Indian yogis
and bought two that win against with it
is going to go far in this match against
the Indian yogis you've been saying it
he's your man your pick for the chess
bras and he's been delivering and how
and look at him he looks calm and
composed uh so I'm loving the chest that
he's playing and it's going to be
interesting to see if he can keep up and
keep delivering the way he's been doing
so far and the chess Bros would love to
help them deliver them a playoff berth
this is a five-week regular season with
an arena Royale that's kind of like an
All-Star game on March 24th with the
playoffs eight teams making their way
through to the March 30th to 31st
playoffs and you need to win three
matches as a team to make it to the
playoffs he can to chess bras
they are about to win it feels like this
second match against Indian yogis it's
not over yet there's still the chance
for the yogis but they need to have a
great round in the next one but if they
can win this they will only need one
more match Victory to make their way
through to the PCL playoffs
Also let's just point out Robert that
currently the chess bras are at five and
a half which means actually if they win
the next round with a three run score
what they did in round two it's much
over so the Indian yogis really need to
step it up the Front Runners with it
ranak aroniak vaishali they need to show
up for the for the for the team right
now they have to win and I've started
this before this round they need to make
sure the margin is big enough to cover
up chess bras take this one home if they
win by 3-1 and we see the individual
matchups Magnus Carlson and orientare
the top boards for the chess Bros get
the black pieces against the top boards
for the Yogi so Ronald said wani White
against Carlson they did Gujarati White
against orientare that feels like a
toss-up Duo to me but then the bottom
two boards razvan preo2 with the white
pieces against vaishali Jennifer you
with the white pieces against aronia
gauche tiny the bottom boards need to
score for the yogis
is so tough I mean the only comeback
chance that I'm seeing Robert looking at
the lineup and the matchup is that if
with it can score a win against Orion
not gonna be an easy one but that's the
point that they're looking at and as
well as on the fourth board aroniak is a
favorite if he can score and a half
points somewhere between board one and
both three that is a dream scenario but
the way the Canada chess bras have been
playing they are the ones who've been
dreaming and delivering it's not gonna
be easy for the Indian yogis uh this
round three it's never easy when you
have to face Magnus Carlsen that is
runick said juani's opponent in this
game and we see the clocks have started
brownic with the white pieces so he gets
the first move Advantage he did Super
well with his team in the Olympiad he's
won some International tournaments but
there is no bigger opponent than Magnus
Carlson and will Magnus play the
Sicilian like he did against vaishali
will he play maybe a modern showing that
he wants to win as early as move one
what do you expect from Magnus we'll
even make a move
right now that's the big question he's
taken about 25 seconds for this decision
and I think it will make his intentions
clear uh I wouldn't be surprised if he
decides to go for the Sicilian one more
time we've seen Magnus go for G6 the but
the modern the hippopotamus structures
as well I think if he plays E5 if he
starts with the King's Pawn opening
Robert it's him saying I'm black I'm
okay with being on the defense side in
this one but that just doesn't sound
like Magnus I'm expecting something
something on the board he needs to make
a move he's down by a minute what is he
doing
I don't know does he even know his clock
has started sometimes you have a
different tab open you're not looking at
the board and well he doesn't really
seem like he is mentally invested in the
chess game he has just played C5 I think
that yeah you know he was uh just not
looking at the tab but he does play E6
with no more russellimos everyone has
come to expect Knight C6 against Magnus
Carlson instead he plays E6 and now
Veronica is the one thinking
he's thinking we saw a little eye
movement and that's usually the chess
players trying to understand what kind
of middle game approach they want what
are the openings that they want to go
for one thing's clear that ronak was not
expecting Magnus to play the second move
E6 he's slightly surprised but he knows
what he wants to do he's just deciding
what kind of setup he wants he goes for
the open Sicilian as we can see and
there we've got a sort of a Rosa tamanov
by Magnus there
yes and we have confirmation back this
was on another screen he wasn't looking
at the chess.com window but he is a
solid setup and he's not even really
down much time so thankfully for him it
was only a minute but he has played A6
so this is typical from black maybe you
play B5 you've given up all of these
dark squares but it's very hard for
white to get to them because the pawns
from black take away all of these night
jumps so
um I like the opening Choice from Magnus
ranick chooses a quieter approach with
the finchetto of probably just castle
and then black often takes on D4 brings
the bishop on C5 with Tempo against the
queen that has captured the Knight
yes these are all plants that are
available what ronic wants with white at
some point at an opportune moment but he
has to time it really well is to start
advancing in the center get that F Pawn
rolling Magnus not giving that chance
just yet he decides to develop the
bishop I've usually seen this after the
night trade because it does win a Tempo
this ship to C5 dozen white white to
actually fall back with the Knight to B3
as well hitting that Bishop on C5
gaining that Tempo so I'm slightly
surprised by Magnus is a move Bishop to
C5 and I can see ronak taking his time
so I'm not the only one who's surprised
yeah Knight B3 gives black a choice
where are you gonna move the bishop back
to E7 or very likely back to A7 as is
common in these sort of con uh Pelican
type Timon of Sicilian so I do think
that if the Knight comes back to B3
he'll probably slide back to A7 to keep
the E3 Square in his reach control a
very long important diagonal with his
Bishop but veronic also thinking about
the consequence of Knight takes C6 and
if a pawn captures back it's not easy to
figure out these types of positions so
he does take your advice on it he drops
back with the Knight and Magnus he gets
to choose his diagonal
drawback of black not making the most of
that opportunity to trade this Knight
and now every set of moves in chess has
its own set of consequences you were
talking about the bishop falling on the
long diagonal it would be very tempting
to go back to A7 control that E3 square
but in return you give another Square
for White's Bishop ronak will be looking
at developing his C1 Bishop now to F4
hitting that Queen now that black
doesn't have the option to play the move
D6 which would be the case had the
bishop stayed on that diagonal so right
now a big decision here for Ronald will
he keep up the momentum of having Magnus
on the back foot on every move
threatening a piece Bishop F4 would be
my choice Ron at making another approach
of centralizing the queen to E2 okay
well both players taking a bit of a
deliberate start to this game slow and
steady does to win the race so they say
so while they continue to ponder this
opening let's zoom out for a moment and
look at our other games in progress in
the top right Vedic Gujarati says you
need to win I'll win it for my team he's
a knight out on F5 he's playing
adventurous chess and the bottom left
razzmat priyota with the white pieces
against vaishali it's an early start to
that game that looks like a French
defense and of course the bottom right
has just begun and we have just seen a
couple moves there so why don't we hop
into the video game Tanya I feel like
vidit you know he understands what is
needed to win in team competition his
team won the European Club cup he scored
six out of seven in fact he won his
first six games there back in November
but how about this position where white
has these Knights on C3 and E3 the pawn
E4 I like it for vidit what are your
thoughts you believe in aryan's chances
here
well it is definitely going to be a bit
of a task because black does have less
space and the piece activity seems a bit
constricted meanwhile those two knights
can jump onto D5 can jump onto F5
currently Aryan is on the defense these
are exactly the kind of positions that
with it also enjoys where he has
complete control of the board it's not
chaotic everything seems to be the way
he wants it's still early days I see our
eval bar seems to say that white is
doing well and I wonder Robert if that's
because white has the flexibility to
start advancing those King side pawns as
well F4 is a move that comes to my mind
Bishop to C4 a nice little Retreat
targeting that F7 weakness as well it's
a good Square for the bishop looks
pretty safe there black does have a move
like C6 B5 but it only weakens the D6
Pawn further so it doesn't look like
something that Aryan would want to play
to try and dislodge that Bishop and
Bishop E6 is also very tempting sort of
thematic when there's a bishop on the
Italian diagonal Let's Play Bishop E6
but maybe vidit is welcoming this swap
for some reason uh I'm not entirely sure
that he wants to trade on E6 but if I'm
Aryan okay it's clear Aryan wants to
play F5 so maybe orientari is not just
trying to play for equality he may say
I'll play Dynamic chess I don't want to
be solid let me strike forward with F5
and open up squares for my pieces
I really want white to get in F4 rubber
it looks like the way that you expand
the pressure it's on the board but
exactly this one Bishop C4 and you're
pointing it out it is the point where
Aryan can get in F5 not only stopping
white spawn advances but just taking
full control of the center white doesn't
seem to have enough time to push that E
Pawn one step further E5 looks like
might just lose upon
and look at how quickly video had G3
ready he says let me connect my pawns to
one another this Knight on G6 has no
moves no safe squares for this Knight so
White's Pawn structure is restraining
the enemy pieces and if you take on e4
that brings another Knight into the
center and maybe that Knight would
Adventure on over to G5 next so fit it
quickly reacting here you said this is
the type of position that vidit is
comfortable in he is demonstrating that
that is indeed the case by moving
instantly the last couple turns
and he's got to do that because the
clock is such an important factor and we
see Aaron has a tiny tiny advantage on
that so he's trying to level that put
pressure on the center he knows that F5
is the point where he wants to force
Aryan to take a decision and now again
whatever Aryan decides will determine
the central structure if you take on e4
you only invite White's Knight into the
game Knight E4 Knight G5 ideas I would
be scared as black to let that Knight
closer to the king but if not with it
has a clear threat he is putting
pressure on F5 currently it is guarded
by three pieces white puts pressure with
three so it feels like black can still
hold it together and doesn't need to
make a decision just yet but it's the
type of video sort of transition in the
game where you trade everything on F5
and say I have a three on two over here
on the king side once we swap these
pawns off the board and black has these
double pawns so in certain end games
that won't be very good for black harder
to create a past Pawn an end game seems
far away but it all these Things become
relevant and E takes F5 isn't just about
trading pawns it vacates that E4 square
that you've been highlighting that night
will be very strong on e4 and maybe
eventually on G5 especially if the
e-file opens up so let's leave these
players our entire in a deep think this
is two Superstar Grand Masters battling
uh on that board but let's look across
our four boards we see in the top left
Magnus Carl centanya I know we didn't
dive into the other positions yet they
look a little bit more solid we might
have to go right back to Magnus Carlson
because he has a huge Advantage I think
roundex had wanted just blunder
wow again Magnus doing Magnus things he
wastes literally gives a minute
Advantage not looking at the screen and
then with the black pieces and just a
few moves from the opening and we see
our eval bar is screaming for Magnus
here Queen B6 huge threats on the board
Robert notice that Queen White's Queen
on E3 and the King on G1 lined up and we
see tactics are being set up here not
only is Magnus in with an obvious threat
of the B2 Pawn hanging but Knight E2 was
massive in that position just to show
that if you defend this beach upon
Knight E2 check is nasty your queen oh
can't take because the king is behind it
so the queen is pinned and if you just
take what seems like a free Knight you
lose your queen and if you say okay I
have no other choice to let me defend my
queen here after the Queens are swapped
uh black is just completely winning you
could take on C3 twice with check you
win this Pawn maybe this Pawn black is
just mopping up so Magnus Carlson he
spots after Roundup made the move F4 not
seeing this tactic and black is just
winning material so Magnus he could
simply just take this Pawn back on E5
the pressure is going to continue on the
Knight on C3 the pawn behind it it says
minus about four here or black and you
can see it on Brown Oak's face this is a
crushing Victory or Magnus in the making
yeah he looks devastated right now ronic
as he should be Magnus just creating
these tactics out of thin air I have to
say his chest currently is from another
planet as we've been talking he's up a
pond right now not the biggest trouble
for white white looks like on the edge
of losing another Pawn down uh down the
board with C2 on the fire as well and
the one thing that really stands out to
me Robert is Magnus on the words of
well-winning the third game that he's
just been winning in crushing style
today it's like giving the opponents no
chance at all
I mean seriously like he just played
Knight takes C2 in a second I would have
spent some time trying to figure out all
right is everything safe it looks like
the queen is a bit far away but he
simply takes upon attacks this queen
here the queen of B2 is now defending
this Pawn E5 two extra pawns for Magnus
Carlson and for renox and won him even
keeping the Queens on the board will not
be easy and if you have to trade Queens
like with Queen to B3 oh sorry go ahead
I I just I think I might have spotted a
mad trick in this position you were
pointing at Queen B3 and I think it
might be the only way because imagine if
you fall back with the queen to let's
say E2 or F2 all right you want to try
and keep the pieces on the board but now
notice how the black queen and the black
Recon C8 Target the C1 rook and the
Knight can jump Well normally to D4 but
to E3 and I think that might be an
option and I'm trying to work out the
geometry because it's so complicated
Knight E3 I'm giving up the night for
free but your work on C1 hangs and if
you first trade The Rook on C8 I will
pick up the F1 Rook with a check and
that is celebrations or am I missing
something nope I think your spot on that
is nasty and that's why perhaps Raonic
has yet to move he is understanding that
Knight E3 even if the Queen's not there
to capture Knight E3 will be next week
he resigns he just whoa ruined the tower
and Magnus Carlsen gave a little bit a
little shrug yep I do that to people
just another day in the office so Magnus
Carlson wins that's game over let's zoom
out of this one because the chess Bros
need two more wins and the match is over
if they reach eight and a half points
the match concludes so Tanya in the top
right still a struggle between vidy
Gujarati and orientare not too much has
changed just some liquidation there in
the bottom left of razzmat priyotu and
vaishali that one looks very interesting
full of minor pieces in the center of
the board in the bottom right Jennifer
you she's maybe slightly worse against
Aruna ghost that's what the Indian yogis
need they need to win that game and hold
at least in the others let's maybe dive
into resident Pro 2 against vaishali you
know how strong my child is you've been
uh her teammate of course you have
played her before but her position to my
eyes not looking so promising
it's been a tough day for ushali and
that's the other thing with this format
right when you start bad and then you
got you've got a loss and then you have
another loss it just becomes very
difficult to come back because every
round you're going to play against a
very strong opposition and look at this
after the first two games vaishali is
playing against the star of the
countertop chess bras Rosman priority
with white looking completely in control
but Robert I'm still reeling from what
we just witnessed in the ronix game in
the Magnus Runner game ronak is the
ninth youngest Grandmaster in the world
he won an Olympic medal he has had star
performances in title Tuesday he is one
of the biggest talents from India just
has won so many events open events a
very strong Grandmaster and Magnus
Carlsen just demolishes him with black
in 20 moves forcing resignation on real
stuff there by Magnus yeah Magnus says
okay you had a world's youngest type of
record you've won a few open tournaments
I've won that world championship I've
won the world rapid I've won the world
blitz so I congratulate you I respect
you but I am going to crush you when
given the chance so uh yeah Magnus I
mean of course nice to have him as board
one for your team and here in this class
between board three for the chess bras
and board four for the yogis I mean
these two players on paper they have
similar ratings right by shali is an
improving player uh she's 24.50 plus a
prior to he is a grand master his rating
took a hit in recent years but it's on
its way back up he's showing that maybe
rapid is even better for him in the
classical I love this bishop on B6 it
just makes sure that black pieces can't
move too easily but I also love Black's
Bishop pair on C6 on E5 because they're
aiming towards this white king and this
Knight can hop into square F4 or H4 so
telling you we need to find an attacker
vaishali I'm just worried once again
about her clock
and we've been seeing that narrative
from the start of the day with vaishali
running low on the clock but this is
such a crucial match for the Indian
yogis this board is super important we
see the score line there with the Canada
chess process six and a half to Indian
yogis at two and a half uh Robert it's
going to be all about whether vaishali
can grew up an attack on the king's side
you've been talking about blacks Bishops
in the center eyeing that G2 Pawn eyeing
that H2 square but it also means that
white always has the option to actually
try to trade out these Bishops and I'm a
little surprised here because where
Charlie does it voluntarily so she falls
back with the bishop but to me it just
seems that this trade would mean less
pressure for white
yes and it does get black though the d8
square that's the good news because this
bishop was uh being very frustrating uh
you don't want to have your Rook tied
down to the f8 square so it does offer
the trade she threw in the check first
to force the king to the corner that's
good for many end games if the Queens
come off so yeah I do think that white
can safely trade here uh the problem is
what next this bishop on C6 is super
strong this Knight May hop into a square
like F4 I kind of like the look of
Black's position but I also know in end
games if the Queens come off black has
only two pawns to whites three on the
queen side outside pass Pawn potential
or preo2
wow so a big decision you have a prior
to will he trade or will he fall back
with the bishop targeting The Rook on f8
but to move Bishop C5 might be tempting
but it only seems to be helping vaishali
because she can then offer a trade of
Rooks on that d d line by sliding down
to d8 so if not Bishop to C5 it is a big
question how does prior to want to take
take in this trade does he allow
vaishali's Queen to step up or will he
find a way to actually trade on his own
terms
you move like C5 not out of the question
just trying to get a Pawn on the V6
Queen C5 trying to get that Queen in
there as well and so it looks like uh
for preo2 and for partially big
decisions we made there but even on the
clock and well they are always do see
Bishop C5 so rookie Robert if Val bar
does not love this move the eval bar
disapproves Rook d8 immediately played
by vaishali so there we see the clocks
are being leveled a little bit as long
as these Bishops are on the board I'm
surprised by this because just compare
that Bishop on C7 to that white Bishop
it just looks like black can Brew up an
attack on the king side with this bishop
bear
yes and the Knight goes back to C3 I
understand that maybe Knight B5 in the
future also uh this bishop will need a
slide back in the event of B6 now it can
go safely to E3 where the Knight was
hanging before but black can bring this
Knight to H4 and say let's go all of my
pieces are staring at the white king if
only this queen could get in front of
the bishop and go deliver a Checkmate
down here but unfortunately it is behind
the bishop not the battery configuration
you'd like
yes the battery but the wrong way around
I think the game would be over if you
can just switch up the bishop and the
queen but first vaishali asks a question
to razuman what does he intend to do
with his own Bishop you've been pointing
out the bishop can slide back to E3 but
that also invites black snipe to jump
not only to H4 hitting G2 but also to F5
where once again that Bishop will be in
Target and the more I look at this
position the more it feels like priyoto
is losing control here he trades on the
D file giving up the D file for the
queen which allows Black's Queen to come
into the attack as well I'm getting the
feeling that razwan move by move is
giving a bigger advantage to vaishali
more to play for in the king side and
somewhere has lost control and that's
what we love about the protest League
someone like resident priyotu who beat
both board one and two for the yogis may
go down to the board four or the Indian
yogis by Charlie playing an excellent
game she can bring a Queen up as you're
highlighting that these Bishops are
superb but she takes a slower approach
with queen of six and I don't love it
she wants queen E5 if she could get that
move she's about to deliver Checkmate
but I do think white has time to put his
move Knight to B5 not like it's the end
of the world for black but you're
getting rid of the bishop pair if Bishop
takes Pawn takes Queen comes to E5
trying to deliver Checkmate then the
pawn and safely push to G3 once the pin
is no more because The Bishop's off the
board it's a great move for Resident
he's now up on time by about 30 seconds
Tanya I that's my main concern for
Vegeta she's playing quite well she has
an advantage here but to make difficult
moves without time it's really difficult
it is really really challenging
absolutely I'm gonna be shocked if
vishali decides to trade that stunning
Bishop on C6 and she doesn't she keeps
the bishop as she moves it to E5 and the
idea is Robert B6 is hanging at first
side but take a look at this if you go
Bishop B6 the queen that we've been
talking about joins the force the
battery this time is set the right way
up Queen F4 will be game over because
you can't play G3 to block that Queen
out notice how the bishop on C6 pins
that King on H1 my hair is going crazy
because the position is going crazy
and I think white has to take on E5 and
this is like ridiculous stuff because
the engine's saying No this actually is
quite decent for white that after Queen
takes E5 something like this white has
compensation you have a pawn and a
bishop for The Rook you have passed Pawn
potential but that is not meant to be in
this game the queen slides back to C1 I
actually really like that decision from
razran none of Black's choices are easy
here B6 is hanging the Knight comes in
F4 but it's not actually threatening
anything or is it the A3 Pawn is is
under attack but white can give up H3
for B6 if he so chooses Tanya this is
really crazy stuff right now
even if Bishop B6 is the right move it
is so difficult to play to just give up
the spawn in front of the king that's
keeping things together just so hard to
move imagine when a queen lands on the
H5 Queen H4 next it looks like you're
stepping into some kind of checkmates
here and this would be a shocking
decision uh Robert I don't know what
white will decide but it just feels like
in these kind of positions you want to
trade this Knight on F4 but if you do
that Bishop F4 can be so tempting you've
just given a lifelong advantage of a
bishop and black continues to step up
with the attack the attack continues and
none of white pieces will be able to
challenge Black's dominating queen and
the two Bishops so Bishop F4 can be a
humanly tempting move but I think in the
long run it's a bad bad idea
he does it he was too worried about the
pressure on the white king he could have
gotten away with that there was a
variation there it was ridiculously
sharp I'm actually sure that very
quickly uh because we had the position
on the board briefly but after Bishop B6
neither should Queen E3 this looks like
it leads to Checkmate but apparently
it's all smoke and mirrors except a
queen takes Bishop Knight takes F2 check
King G1 there is no Queen H1 mate
because the king would then take this
Knight so sudden somehow some way uh
despite a double check and it looked
like a checkmating attack white would
Escape that is really impossible to see
without the engine as your guide and we
have the eval bar off the side of the
screen he said takes this bishop here
plays Queen C2 and if quickly these
Bishops could get traded or now the
Rooks getting traded white will still
have a chance with limited material your
king is feeling safer and safer on H1
the more pieces that get traded
it's all about setting up that battery
the right way that we've been talking
about right along the diagonal of B8 to
H2 but it absolutely as more pieces get
traded uh razwan can breed a sigh of
relief there he's down to a minute and
45 seconds Robert the lines that we're
looking at giving up the H3 Pawn I mean
good luck finding that with just a
minute on the clock it is impossible so
very understandable decision by white
trying to trade off as many pieces that
said vaishali will try to grind this one
it's the best position she's had all day
yes Bishop pair looks good for black
king G1 nice choice but look at this in
the top right orientari down to his last
few seconds against vidit Gujarat who
himself only has about 20. so let's dive
into that one as a pawn as just been
able to dive into the E6 square and it's
going up and up for vidit in aryan's
time trouble
and this is looking super scary for
black right one you have to do the clock
and half
that pawn on E6 I don't see a way for
what blacks Knight to jump onto E4 that
Knight on C5 doesn't only got the E6
spawn but has full Center under control
with it moved by move centralizing his
pieces more and more black seems to be
paralyzed here the knight from F5 being
hit wow that is a committed decision and
queen G4 is a big threat here right now
coming in with a check and four seconds
for video he has to leave his H3 which
is a mistake apparently at a winning
move instead we see oh my gosh it's
chaos and Sue at this point Knight D7
with the fourth Tanya
one second he barely gets his move off
and oh
Monster clothes and wizard takes a huge
win for the Indian yogis what a crazy
game
oh my goodness a night Fork first an F6
to get the Rook but no it was just a
distraction to get this Knight Fork on
H7 winning the queen a great find from
vidic Gujarati but we will tune out of
this one as vidit scores for the Indian
yogis that's a huge win for them we see
in the bottom right Jennifer you and
aronia gauche that one is looking about
level based on the material remaining
and in the bottom left which is where we
left it seems like vaishali and Rosa
also stabilizing a bit so why don't we
head to the bottom right Jennifer you
against oronia Ghost we have not looked
at that game and even though the Evo bar
is in the Middle with the time both
lives under a minute this is starting to
look potentially vulnerable for the
Kings there's blunder potential in this
position
well currently black has an extra Pawn
but the position is absolutely wild as
you're pointing out there is a threat of
opening up the center and White Queen
can jump onto C6 putting pressure on the
black Rook as well as the E6 weakness
we've seen the kind of blunders that
time scrambles make possible arandari
blundering that Queen with a fork on it
six and it's going to come down to these
seconds currently we've got Jennifer
with just 24 seconds a wild position on
the board Robert this can go anywhere
although I think it's going everyone's
way right now based on how much time she
spent and Rook E3 was not it apparently
I wonder why Queen C4 let's offer Queen
trade black is up a pawn looking to
create a password that a rook can get
behind so what's Jennifer doing here she
trades Queens but she can't bring her
Bishop to F1 because E4 is hanging I
mean we've been talking about that extra
pawn and White's compensation was all in
trying to keep the queen alive and
building threats but now this looks like
an end game where black has got no
trouble at all da up upon the king comes
to the center of the board a bishop E6
Bishop F7 can be traded off so the pawn
lives and this is going to be trouble
for Jennifer you
uh she thought that she could oh
apparently that was could have captured
on D5 and then brought the king D6 that
would have been a winning or more easily
winning choice for ironyaka she wants to
keep the status quo oh or not she wants
her King up here but Black's King also
wants to enter and black skin is super
fast right now you give a check and the
King defends the C4 Pawn not just that
now King is going to be defending the C4
Pawn getting to that queening square hit
that Rook Advance with the pawn and this
Rook ending is absolutely busted for
white uh We've often seen when and that
is it Jennifer you knows there's no way
to defend this one and aroniak takes
that win so now with that it means the
Indian yogis have stepped it up to four
and a half against the Canada chess bras
at six and a half
wow huge win for Aruna ghost he goes up
a pawn and wins that game and now we
have a messy position oh that was a
losing check you give a check and
unfortunately this F2 Pawn if you're a
fan of the chess Bros Queen F3 E4 is
automatic dislodging the queen from the
F2 score this is winning on the spot
vaishali finds it
wow and that is it where Charlie is
winning but can she do it there's still
work to be done here Robert and that's
it she trades the Queen's off as well
she is up an entire Bishop in this end
game it requires a bit of technique
players are playing on the seconds if
she wins this what a huge huge
turnaround that will be we've been
speaking about prior to she will take
down potentially on the verge of taking
down the strongest player currently the
MVP from the Canada chess brought team
now it's completely winning she can just
bring her King back at any moment scoop
up this Pawn she's a pass spawn of her
own she could just go Pawn grab me take
them all this is unbelievable that
resmen priodo he looked Unstoppable he
beat Vivid Gujarati he beat Roundup he
was performing you know an infinite
performance rating because he was two
out of two and now vaishali wins with
black she was having a tough day but it
is six and a half five and a half and
all of a sudden Indian yogis are right
back in this
right back and how what a round this has
been and this is what we love about a
protest League that no result no
conclusion is foregone at all Anything
Can Happen what a turnaround we've had
with vaishali taking down a pre-order we
saw a phenomenal performance by her in
week one as well and here she scores a
much needed a huge win for the Indian
yogis and with it as well leading from
the front takes down orientari what
around this has been and Indian yogis
take it to round four with the smallest
of margins just down a point
yes the Indian yogis look down and out
but they score three wins out of a
possible four led by vidit Gujarati he
is their board one he will need to prove
his might in the next one against Magnus
Carlsen but right now vidit Gujarati
eroniak goes and vice shali with that
important win over razvan priyotu so
some big scores for Canada chess Bros
Jennifer you not on the scoreboard yet a
lot remains to be seen as Magnus Carlson
is seven out of seven a perfect seven in
the protesting thus far
wow that is super impressive but of
course it's Magnus so not that
surprising but the big question here
Robert for about a 1.3 billion people
back in India currently is can with it
stop the Magnus run
that is the essential question we can
only find out the answer to that one
when returned from this short break so
Tanya and I will be back in a few it
will be the candid chess bras and the
Indian yogis here in the Pro chess
League one point separates them you will
not want to miss this fourth and final
round of action
it matter that you have these serious
brothers and
and they were about Excellence they were
about winning and they understood
Checkmate was like that's what it's
about it's about winning this damn game
like we you're not trying to pretend or
or learn just learn you're not here uh
like just to be a spectator you're here
to win and if you're going to win you're
going to have to do the work you're
going to have to you do not just the
external world but the internal work
because your pride and your feelings and
all that that thanks no thanks that's
just going to go by the wayside
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Applause]
if the Indian yogis have a chance to
continue and complete this comeback this
man on screen videot Gujarati will have
to survive a might of Magnus Carlson
Tanya this is a familiar face to the
Chess World there's also a familiar
sight to you
oh here's a little fun fact with it in
fact is in Delhi right now and he
happens to be playing from my dad's
office which is two levels below from
where I am so I'm I'm hoping that he's
in a good mood after he finishes this uh
this matchup but Robert what a comeback
by the Indian yogis now after round two
it looked like it was going to be a
chess Bra Day it just looked like this
is a task that's super hard to cover up
with that round three comeback it looked
like the Indian yogis have opened up
that third eye and currently looking at
a trying to level or maybe even take
this match but there's a lot of work to
be done and I look at our matchups there
Robert and for me the most crucial board
in this one will be roz1302 against
oranyaka Kosh and I think the Indian
Yogi's chance there is to take a win on
that one with the white pieces yes
because the Indian yogis can't just have
a tutu split they need to score one full
point at minimum more than the Canada
chest bra so max Carlson with white
against vidit is capable of holding off
Magnus that's just not going to be easy
because Magnus Carlsen is Magnus Carlson
but orientari he gets white against runx
and wani raunek has been in shaky form
so if I'm thinking about this from the
chess bras perspective I want to put the
match away on those top two boards with
the white pieces but you are right two
out of two not likely on those top two
boards just because how strong the yogi
Grandmasters are there so it's about
those bottom two boards can the yogis
win with both of their players getting
the white pieces and Raz vent preo to
bounce back from what was a tough game
three he had two great games and then
one shaky one so which resvent prior to
will show up and which levonne aronia
ghost will we see because uh aronia
super strong player himself he's had
some great performances he gets the
white pieces and he did just uh score
even for important victory for the yogis
and can visit Gujarati stop a seemingly
Unstoppable Magnus Carlson he's
against with it and of course this is a
super huge matchup for the Indian yogis
with it is going to try to look for that
half a point which would mean so much
for him with the black pieces for the
team and the we've got the players who
are ready and set to go to start the run
this is the final round Robert I want to
ask Chad and I want to ask you what are
your predictions are we going to see
your playoff today
well we love playoffs as commentators
um now you want my honest take here I
think that the chess bras are going to
escape this round with a narrow win I
just feel like with white pieces on the
top two boards uh resident priyotu gets
black on board three I feel like that's
actually the lineup that they want is
they want to have uh the white with
their strongest two and then hope that
their bottom two boards can hold with
black but if any team can get it done I
really do believe in the yogis I I know
I just said the chess bras should be
able to escape with that narrow win but
the yogis they just proved in that
previous round 3-1 score uh they lost to
Magnus and the other boards won so maybe
that's the recipe for success is Magnus
will get his points you know give him
his roses but take down those other
boards
they need to give everything they've got
in this match the yogis to have a chance
against the chess prize now you
mentioned the smallest of margins for
the chess bra team but they don't even
need that a level round a 2-2 score
would actually mean chess bras get to
eight and a half and take the match win
so if this round ends in a draw that is
not good enough for the Indian yogis the
Indian yogis have to win with a minimum
margin of two and a half to force a
playoff and I would I really want to
hear from our chat their thoughts on
whether they believe that the yogis are
capable of it I am so impressed I'm so
impressed with the comeback already but
the work is half done uh and I see I see
our feature chat there while getting the
Magnus hair would be the dream
yes it would be the dream also magnus's
chess skills I would love that as well
uh I'm not sure which I would like more
uh but either one suffices but Magnus
Carlson he gets the white pieces he's
wearing that white hoodie with the black
pieces on it it's a bow ties live hoodie
shout out to the bowtest sisters always
creating great content uh but Magnus he
has been I think better in week two than
he was in week one and that is scary
news for the rest of the pro chess
League be on high alert that if Magnus
Carlson's form is improving throughout
the season and he's already seven out of
seven yikes
super yikes a Magnus level chest it just
feels like it's harder to get to and
there we see we've got the two players
on the screen Magnus level hair might
still be achievable with it they're
completely focused his task is cut up he
needs to stop Magnus on his tracks it
hasn't been done before and this is mind
game this is the inner game by Magnus
Carlson he chooses 1v3 against the India
number two player and very Gujarati has
a lot of experience playing against B3
not just because the Beast adibon
baskaran he plays a B3 himself but he's
playing against Hikaru many times I
remember in the rapid Chess Championship
there was some a series between vidit
and Hikaru where Hikaru did play B3 but
it actually had the upper hand in a
great position so this is principal
stuff you put your Pawns in the center
against
flank plate the fan Kettle is strong
making sure that the third Pawn doesn't
reach but so far its early stages will
Magnus play F4 and then the night out to
F3 kind of like a sicilian but on the
other side right instead of E4 and C5 or
the E5 and C4 it's kind of f4 and D5
it's a funny version more like in
English let's put it that way
and we see
it moves by black now we now we're
taught to take out the pieces with it
needs to start doing that soon he first
takes control of the B5 Square so that
the bishop can't land there targeting
this Knight when it comes out on C6 not
just that eventually Black's middle game
plan is to expand on the queen side to
try and create play there so it does
support the move B5 as well and we
finally see Magnus taking the decision
to first develop his Knight so no F4
there and it just looks like it's going
to be a slow game Robert uh one where
that we're gonna see few trades and a
long grind here
yes and Magnus Carlson has a big choice
right now does he simply develop his
light Square Bishop does he play the
move d4 as is typical to strike in the
center and get some space for himself
but vidit he's playing confidently thus
far and he has a
big lead on the clock so Magnus even
though he's the one who chose an offbeat
opening he's the one spending time as
well and he does go for D4 and look at
how quickly vidit replies with Knight F6
perhaps a temporary Pawn sacrifice
on in front of the king one step go E6
open up that bishop and now you notice
how that C5 Pawn cannot be defended and
it's actually a beautiful way to develop
the king side Bishop to the appropriate
Square by recapturing the pawn
and by the way 84 of the chat picked the
chess bras to win this mess you asked
the question the chat has answered it's
not very surprising because well the
chess Bros have a lead I don't think
it's like a bias thing even it's just
the fact that with a one-point match
lead and Magnus Carlson with the white
pieces I get it and B4 has just been
played kicking this bishop out C4 likely
next Knight D2 which is trying to go
after this Square Maybe
early stages here neither side with a
huge plus a just kind of calm territory
but magnets can almost pre-move C4 it
feels like a reverse Queen's Gambit
accepted somehow these structures that
we've got on the board so definitely
ideas of trying to create an isolated
Queen's Pawn with the move C4 that
you're pointing out you want to try and
trade a little bit on D5 and get black
spawn to come on D5 first Magnus
continues to develop the knight from
here can be headed to B3 and then
control the center also eyeing the C5
Square I do expect he goes for C4 you
were looking at this idea earlier uh
Robert it's on the board and I was gonna
say I do expect C4 at some point
he wants to take with his Knight why not
take control over more squares on the
board does Magnus want a queen trade
that remains to be seen because a lot of
people think Queens are off the poor off
the board playing for a draw not Magnus
Carlson he wins the most unwinnable end
games but Vivid off to a good start and
speaking of starts other games have
begun we have three games and now four
in progress uh the fourth board and the
bottom right Jennifer you and vaishali
it is a Petrov so we'll see how that one
continues in the top right Roundup said
wani with uh he Magnus and roundic have
an RN have the white pieces so we will
get that fixed uh the chess Bros have
white on boards uh one and two and then
black on three and four but let's just
Dive Right into uh the board two game
between Orion and uh Raonic just because
that one is looking quite interesting
and as we tune in Aryan
played a four night Scotch so all kids
in the U.S at least historically have
been taught that opening what do you
think about that opening in this game
Tanya
happy to play against the fortnite
scotch but that said of course it is
still a middle game everything to play
for that's developed really slowly I
like facing the four nights with the
black pieces I feel like it gives all
these Dynamics where the Bishops are out
of the control over the B file you get
the central break with D5 and usually a
happy camper with black of course Aryans
got his own plans currently he attacks
that Bishop on G4 looking at them at the
board that we have right now I think
Rana can be happy with the opening
outcome it looks like he's achieved
everything that black wants against the
Four Knights the Four Knights opening
you've got the D5 break you've got that
Rook on B8 the Bishops are developed I'm
kind of liking Black's position it all
hangs on whether white can get a strong
E5 in at some point gaining space
hitting that Knight opening that Bishop
on D3 and how dangerous is this move
yeah because if blacks is no E5 for you
and takes here we see double isolated
seat pawns and an Iceland a pawn so you
typically do not want to take on the E4
Square maybe it's acceptable maybe
there's a concrete reason why black is
doing okay but I think for the long term
it's not just about the initial
evaluation the initial assessment
neither player knows that but even if it
says okay slightly better for white for
the long term it's just an ugly end game
in the making for black
and he falls back with the bishop to H5
and you were talking about the drawbacks
of trading on e4 but now the big
question hangs how dangerous is the move
E5 because that's really White's main
idea and after E5 you hit the Knight the
Knight can fall back to D7 attacking the
pawn on E5 but then as you're pointing
out it is upon March down on the king
side it becomes a game that's played on
both Flags black has to watch out for
threats of G4 F5 coming in at all points
and the position can be very dangerous
will orientari decide to go for this
attack will he make the move E5 or will
he decide to keep the tension in the
center he answers your question so I
didn't have to he played E5 and when you
say A you have to say B F4 is mandatory
right now otherwise your E5 pawns are
trouble and black should not be playing
F6 this is just it would be a terrible
mistake after F6 the white Pawn does not
capture it goes forward with F5 to
follow now you have a healthy protected
pass Pawn on the sixth rank so instead
of F6 where like this you move like
Knight C5 potentially and the bad news
for white is the queen is over here on
C1 because if you want to play G4
already this queen is going to venture
into enemy territory and cause the white
king some problems so this queen would
rather be on a square like even like H2
just to help out the king Side Pawn
bushes but it is on C1 defending this B2
Pawn defending the bishop but that
allows black a little bit of time to
stay in this game so Tanya I think that
we'll see how Rona continues here all
four boards are equally important so
let's go to our bird's eye view because
um my eyes were drawn to the game not
between Magnus Carlson and Vita guzrathi
not between our antar and Rana where we
just left not even to board three aronia
gosh and resin Pro 2. there's a Pawn on
H4 and a knight on G5 in the bottom
right so vaishali she has the white
pieces in that game she kind of needs to
win for the Indian yogis to have a
chance and she is going forward with her
pieces in this game Tanya what do you
make of the setup or why and by
Charlie's lead on the clock and maybe
the first time I've ever said that
quite imagine that's almost 2 it's ahead
on the clock
about vaishali
chance to play H4 she's going to do it
she loves that H Pawn marching down the
board she's an extremely aggressive
player who loves complications direct
lines forcing ideas and that's what we
see she plays for the initiative she is
going for Jennifer use King making her
intentions very clear that said black
has her own trumps in the position
Jennifer can look at advancing in the
center moves like D5 trying to break
open with D4 eventually you want to
create your own play on The Queen side
this is a race to words each other's
King white will play on the king side
Jennifer you will Target vaishali's King
on the queen side and it's going to be
who gets there faster where Charlie's
looking at that H5 move as soon as she
can get it in and D5 on the board here
first she needs to answer the question
how is she taking care of the center
position ideas like eight six kicking
that night taking the E4 Square where
Charlie playing quickly and playing good
plays after 3 not only hits the bishop
on G4 but controls lacks knight from
jumping into E4
and black goes back to D7 because if
Jennifer had gone to school like H5 that
invites G4 with Tempo and H5 to follow
so the bishop slides back to D7 white
can play G4 but to what end where is the
attack coming from this Knight on G5
well it looks imposing it actually
blocks a lot of White's progress so it's
one of these positions where you both
enjoy the knights placement and want to
kick it out and put your own Pawn to get
rid of this Knight on F6 so uh what
other moves come to mind I'm trying to
figure out plans I think G4 is kind of
automatic but as you're saying black can
start a queen side pressure of her own
and it's not just a one-side affair that
the queen on d8 is tied down for the
time being this bishop on you said
that's the one bit of annoying news for
black
also it would be so nice for white to
play H5 immediately and start
threatening age six but then you have to
calculate tactics which arise after
black uh responding H5 with a move like
eight six and then vaishali will have to
drop back with the Knight the only
Square note is how that is at the edge
of the board age three and Jennifer you
will capture that H5 Pawn Win that pawn
I'm not sure where the tactics lead it
still looks like a dangerous position
but currently vaishali is trying to
think if she can make H5 work because
very often you sacrifice a Pawn on the
king side to open up lines there was a
time Robert when there was this a
general concept when in doubt play H3
you know it's a quiet little move always
helpful and that has been destroyed by
modern chess now when in doubt go H4
h586 and that's the dream
no it's a really good point because if
you read old chess books which I didn't
do but you can you often see they put
upon H3 just for prophylactic reasons
just to keep everything safe and sound
but no this is attacking chess and
vaishali she went forward she played
quickly now she's thinking and that's
not the greatest sign for her she still
has a slight lead on the clock one thing
I wanted to point out is this D5
okay I couldn't even finish my thought
she plays it but I was in this D5 Pawn
doesn't have a pawn defending it so
Bishop E5
simple chess threatens to remove the
guard and if this bishop comes out to C6
maybe this bishop is too far on the
queen side not helping defend key
Central squares this bishop slides up to
D3 puts full pressure on H7 Bishop takes
F6 removes the guard of not just D5 but
the H7 Square as well Tanya I'm actually
kind of feeling this for by Charlotte
she's playing very well this far
really nice move there getting rid of a
key defender in Black's position that
Knight on F6 which holds not only the
king side but the center together for
Jennifer I think it's very important to
push back this Knight on G5 it's a
committal move though a move like eight
six forces the Knight back to H3 but
then you create a hook on the king side
white can start targeting it by marching
not with the H spawn knob with the G
Pawn down the board so that is a
difficult decision to make but I don't
believe that Jennifer can let that
Knight on G5 survive especially with the
bishop coming to D3 and targeting that
pawn on 87. this middle game is going to
be wild even though it started as a
Petrov if the Petrov is an opening
that's known for a solid strategic
middle game not in this one not in this
one at all so let's zoom out while
Jennifer you is on the clock she's about
five minutes remaining Magnus Carlson
taking on virit Gujarati and I think
this is you know pretty much as good of
a position as you could expect in the
top left for vidit because we see both
sides having four minor pieces queen of
rook and six pawns so Magnus he's going
to try to work this position get some
kind of Advantage where one doesn't seem
to exist so let's dive into that game
where Magnus is trying to make things
happen and his last move you see Rook D1
to C1 after black just put a rook on d8
so Tanya it's clear that Magnus wants to
keep more pieces on the board he may be
lining up some kind of queen C2 a
battery with Bishop takes F6 on tap and
maybe it's just because White's Bishops
are better than their black counterpart
that's the key point in this position
and at first sight it looks so
symmetrical with the pawn structure the
minor pieces it looks like it should be
an equal middle game but actually it is
way deeper than that and way more
complicated and the fact that with it
has made the move King to f8 it just
expresses that that's just how difficult
it is with black to find good moves in
this position white has a clear idea to
penetrate with that Queen to that eight
seven square Queen C2 and it just looks
like White's the one setting up the
battery before black does the idea of
not trading Rooks will eventually help
white in creating more chances along the
C file as well Queen C2 comes to mind
right now again with the idea of going
maybe Knight E4 you know you don't want
to really trade off this bishop on B2
for the night unless you get something
immediately but I'm happy to trade off
one of the king side nights where key
Defenders 94 Queen jumping in uh it is
not as poison free as it looks for visit
right right now you're right that if
this queen can line up and get to H7
this could be devastating for the black
king but I really have to commend
British last king to f8 it's
understanding what is about to happen
and let me put my Kink towards the
center because it's actually safer there
than if this queen could line up with
the bishop and go for a check because
anytime this bishop capture the queen
captures back black is happy to have the
two Bishops advantage in the resulting
position so Magnus needs to come up with
a move it's actually not so easy both
sides don't have too much time it's
becoming a Blitz game I like white
because the Bishops are staring into
longer diagonals whereas the bishop on
Y8 staring into its own Knight and pawn
the bishop B6 staring into the enemy
Pawn which is safe and sound so I just
think a slight slight Advantage for
Magnus maybe you will start with Knight
E4 to develop his Bishop to E4 get this
Knight out of here open up some files
for his pieces it's one of these like
give and take positions
and we've been talking about all these
plans that exist for magnets that can
create a lot of trouble for black but
what with it also wants to try and do is
get an A5 break in at the right time you
were pointing out the move Knight E4
Magnus went for your idea Robert nicely
called on that and with it says I don't
want to trade because that allows your
centralized Bishop to create more issues
comes in with a knight and look at this
Magnus just insisting on a nitrate are
you pointing at a repetition here with a
knight falling back I don't think Max is
going to repeat because if we just look
where that Knight came from the Knight
what came from G3 and then over to the
queen side so uh in the United States I
think is the best move but I don't think
Magnus has to go 94 back uh he can think
about those like Queen C2 which we
mentioned before with the Knight just
being over on the queen side I just like
did it as playing this perfectly really
good defense from him and the yogis need
this so a while Magnus decides whether
or not to repeat I do think we should go
back to our bird's eye view every single
match as of equal importance in the Pro
chess league so if we look across the
other boards in the top right round
exodwani with black he's getting very
active with his Queen in the bottom left
aronia gauche against resident priyotu
that's just a complicated queenless
position where both sides have both
Rooks remaining and whoa okay let's Dive
Right In because I saw the last move
played by
um resident Pro 2 was Pawn to B5 and if
you look at it it's white with a spatial
advantage and then B5 gives white some
kind of actual Edge the eval is going up
and what happens if aronic just takes
this Pawn on B5 Tanya
yeah you can take the pawn on B5 not
just that pondra but you can also take
the pawn and C5 once black recaptures
with the Rook then you take the pawn on
C5 forcing a rook train and it looks
like you just end up with an extra Pawn
on C5 I'm slightly surprised with
priyoto's decision to break with B5 and
this is ironic's chance to take the edge
in this game which would be a huge deal
with the Indian yogis if he's able to
play this one with the white pieces for
two results yeah I mean he can just take
this Pawn The Rook takes back then you
take on C5 white is going up a pawn here
I think by force and this is what strong
players often do so I'm going to say
first of All Black's winning a pawn uh
losing Pawn excuse me but priority is
saying I don't want to defend passively
if instead of playing B5 and there
aren't really clear moves to make at
least not ones that you look useful
while at some point white is gonna try
to double Rooks on the B file uh in due
course so we saw B5 and then C4 played
but this just hands white a very
impressive last one it's going up to B7
where it could be protected by this
bishop Pawn takes politics simple trade
of pieces Black's Pawn structure is
healthier but white is up a pawn
that is not a pawn that is a star in
White's position I mean coupled with
that Bishop on G2 getting to B7 black
has got no way to put the Rook on it
that Bishop on G2 an absolute monster
which makes me think maybe black has to
think about stopping and blocking that
diagonal with a move like D5 you can't
allow the bishop to keep spitting fire
down the board the B7 Pawn with the
Knight jumping into B6 Knight jumping
into D7 is a clear idea a clear winning
plan that white has and razwan in huge
trouble here he's not only down upon
he's done a massive Pawn on B6 yeah and
B5 Bishop B4 bring more Firepower
towards the Queen's head Rook F to C1 up
to C7 all trades will favor white with
this pass Pawn that was I think just a
surprising decision by rasvin he was
feeling uncomfortable and I was trying
to say that strompers often give up
material for activity this was the wrong
decision in this game this could be huge
for the Yogi so Tanya I mean we gotta go
back to the bird inside view you see
what's happening
exactly I was just keeping an eye out
for that I mean take a look at that top
left board magnus's Queen has arrived
towards with its king there we've got a
queen on h8 this looks super dangerous
imagine if that Bishop from B1 gave a
check on G6 that's game over Knight H4
Bishop G6 would be completely done for
the if Almar says that White's attack is
going to Mark the info with it but I
don't see a clear way currently because
after Knight H4 you still have Knight to
E7 and that's why he's vacated that
square so that the Black Knight can come
to defend the king okay but the
evaluation bar went all the way through
the roof so I have to look at tactics
here where are they I think because the
evaluation or I didn't see myself Bishop
G6 check is actually the best move and
after King takes C6 I'll just show the
quickly you take the queen comes to G8
and the king is lacking Escape Square so
somehow a knight H4 check is next and
there will likely be a mate but Magnus
and that was a ridiculous thing to find
anybody's E4 he still keeps a huge
Advantage right the bar is still Sky
High in his favor the Knight moves where
is it going to move to the F4 perhaps
but this king is still in danger
I mean Bishop G6 what a move Robert but
impossible impossible to play and that
also when you're playing in about a
minute just hanging that Bishop but a
great concept that you pointed out E4
hits that Knight Knight F4 is an option
but as you're pointing out it doesn't
solve Black's problems what black really
wants to do is try and drive that Queen
away Bishop to D7 try and kick that
Queen out at some point and the Magnus
meanwhile has got a couple of moves to
build the attack I'm trying to think how
he can improve the position because it
looks like he's done everything right
ideas of Bishop F6 are screaming for me
I don't think they work right now but
the point is that after G takes F6 Queen
87 would have been a check Magnus plays
Queen 87 first and the eval bar does not
like this move it says equal I think you
were right and look Madness is not worse
he made two inaccuracies in a row he's
going for the G7 Pawn but after Pawn
takes Bishop takes E5 he's hitting this
Knight and G7 but can this Knight simply
Retreat back to each five year did
Madness completely missed that oh he did
look at him shaking his head he missed
the simple Retreat of the night
protecting G7 videgar's wrath he might
steal this game
and look at with it he knows it he knows
he's got the defense up but he's down to
11 seconds on the clock Robert and that
is a tough task with just 11 seconds
there's still Danger on his King but
with Gujarati is on the brink of winning
against Magnus here but time trouble
will play a party this king is still not
fully safe Knight F6 there might be
Bishop takes an E5 check so the king may
have six the king may have to March into
the sound of the board that looks very
scary what is going on into E5 check he
goes
okay this is blowing up he doesn't go E5
black could have fallen back with the
King he gives a check first you can
still go King F7 everything is safe
white doesn't have enough pieces right
now but where are you hiding king f8
queen h8 he wants to block it with a
knight if the bishop sticks in to put
more pressure on the pin Knight the
queen can slide up and defend Magnus
Carlsen is busted right now he is busted
the queen comes to F3 threatening Queen
d11 and defending the King on the f-file
which means that what can white even do
here the bishop has no squares the
bishop has no ego up to C2 but that
doesn't look like oh no Queen trade down
a piece this is just going to be a win
for vidit Gujarati who forces the Queens
off and now is in a completely easily
winning
minor piece end game where he's up one
oh
my God unbelievable
stuff with their win they've got six and
a half to six and a half and now it is
magnus's theme the chest brows that need
to be careful Magnus is down an entire
piece this is just completely lost and
with it needs to just show a little bit
of control on his nerves he's super good
at that Robert I am I'm in shock at the
turnaround that we're seeing and what
was it 82 saying that we're not gonna
see a playoff
84 said the chest bras would win but now
it's like the yogis are gonna win round
next and wani wins with black against
orientare villagers rothy about to win
with black against Magnus Carlson this
is resign time it's easy now and there
is a resignation we need to go back to
that moment very quickly in this game
before we head to the other ones that
Magnus Carlson Tanya we saw the Eva bar
Up Up and Away that in this moment here
Bishop takes F6 was in fact the winning
move if you take with the pawn queen H7
skewers the queen on B7 so if you take
with the King on F6 then the White Queen
goes to f8 with Chuck this King if it
goes over here up comes upon E5 and if
you block with a piece a queen to F7
there still is E5 check and where is
your king going the answer is nowhere
you have to take with the Knight and
this Rook on C8 is hanging at the end of
the line not easy to see with under a
minute under clock so we can forgive
Magnus Carlsen but there are all sorts
of tactics surrounding this black king
but let's tune out from this one just
because the other games are getting
crazy look in the bottom right where
vaishali and Jennifer you Jennifer you
down to her final seconds there's a
bishop on G7 the evil bar changes in the
Yogi's favor
and Robert bashali wins this there's no
tiebreak the yogis take the match they
need one one game point to actually win
the whole match and what a turnaround
that was in the Magnus with it game it
is unbelievable what we're seeing Bishop
G7 is a huge sacrifice if you take with
the king the queen jumps onto D4 gives a
check March is down to H4 as well it's
just unbelievable stuff happening the
bishop Retreats right now I actually
thought it was Black's move there wow no
the white moved the white bishop move
excuse me now the bishop besides the G6
good defense by Jennifer you right now
but F4 with F5 looks like a Crusher and
Jennifer down to her final 30 seconds
she has to make a move she brings in
Bishop E4 take it SEC three next two
it's on the board where Charlie doesn't
miss this tactic the queen will line up
with The Rook on the H file and give
give a mate on that h8 square this is
over and that 84 did get it right if
vaishali wins this no playoffs but it
will be the Indian yogis who take this
match it is Checkmate on the next move
this is an unbelievable comeback they
were down by three points it looked like
they were about to uh just lose in three
rounds they in fact win this is one of
the most epic comebacks in Pro chess
league history you see that game finish
and we have one game remaining and the
Indian yogis may win that one too let's
get more victories for the yogis this
King on f8 Resident priorities King in
trouble we saw him give up the pawn that
Still Remains a passer this is
ridiculous the yogis are so powerful
wow so the math score currently it
doesn't even matter Robert because take
a look at this it doesn't matter what
happens in this game Indian yogis are
the winner of this match and the way
that they started no one could have
predicted this end
rookie one should lead to a Checkmate
here in fact I believe is
that 4-0 it's 4-0 I missed a Checkmate
in two moves or maybe three moves there
but still this king is being hunted this
is going to be a 4-0 round for the yogis
I cannot believe it they were down I
believe
six and a half to two and a half before
they scored there's three wins in a row
in that third round of action and vidit
guzrathi scores a stunning win over
Magnus Carlson Ronald said wani we
didn't even see his game he won with the
black pieces against orientari and very
early on it looked like this one was
going to Yogi's way all four boards
clicked at the right moment that's what
you need in team events
I am absolutely stunned here and look at
that white picks up the other rook and
with that PIN you win the game and that
is it 4-0 to the Indian yogis and they
take the match against the Canada chess
bra team what a turnaround I don't think
I've ever seen anything like this before
Robert this is truly a Monumental moment
in chess history all we see is zeros on
the left side and ones on the right
Gujarati takes down Magnus Carlsen with
black Roundup said wani takes down
orientari with black and the bottom two
boards they were too much for the chess
bras the Indian yogis were LED there by
aranyak Ghost and by shali they both won
their game Tanya what an epic comeback
by the yogis that is incredible
that is truly a comeback of all
comebacks that we've ever seen I mean a
4-0 win we were talking about potential
playoffs and tie breaks and what the
yogis need to do and few believe that it
was even possible a four zero win taking
out Magnus Carson when Magnus is on
seven out of seven when he's just been
playing this other world chess with it
showing up for his team not just him
ronak savani who had a tough day so far
winning that critical game against Aryan
this has been a result that I really did
not expect best case scenario for the
Indian yogis was to take it to playoffs
but they wrap it up in round four in
style with a four to nil Victory on real
stuff there Robert out of words
wow and it was five and a half two and a
half after two rounds in favor of the
chess bras and that means that they were
outscored the chess brothers were
outscored by a seven to one margin over
the last eight games and I believe it
was seven wins in a row because the
chess Bros won that game in round three
first so look at this nine and a half
six and a half a balanced performance
three points for video Gujarati two
points around everyone yeah go saying
sorry you were talking about the chess
bras board three look at me I'm scoring
two and a half points a plus score for
aronia ghost for the Indian yogis and
vaishali for the second week in a row
has an even score on board four if she
is going to be punching above her weight
like this that means the yogis may be
the team to beat I'm stunned I really
can't believe it Tanya but the Indian
yogis they are the winners of this
week's matchup against the Canada chess
bras
far of it amazing stuff then vaishali as
you're pointing out punching when it
matters and of course prior to as well
he won the first two games today but
eventually going down in two games this
is what I love about protest League it's
not only it's not only competitive Chess
at the highest level but so
unpredictable every game can't it's not
over till it's over and that's what this
match showed us and today is not over
just because this match is over we still
get one more match the second half of
our doubleheader will be the Brazil
Cappy bars taking on the Charlotte
cobras the cobras are led by Daniel
nerdinski you will get to see Dania in
action that starts very shortly so we
have to take a break get the players set
and then reset for that matchup but
before we do we just want to give a
shout out to an upcoming event it is a
special event it will be the chess kid
bullet Championship chess kid is hosting
the second chess kid chip on
February 25th the tournament is open to
players worldwide as completely free to
play in top players receive chess kid
gold memberships and gift cards to the
chess kids store funmaster Mike will be
covering all the action at twitch.tv
chesskit and chess.com TV if you or
someone you know has what it takes make
sure to join the official chess kid Club
over at chesskid.com use the command
bull Champs in chat for more Tanya and I
will head towards a short break when we
return the pro chess League continues it
will be the Brazil Capybaras against the
Charlotte cobras you just watched the
Indian Yogi's storm back against the
Canada chess Bros we will be right back
in just a few do not go anywhere
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
match of a double header in the
Pro chess League
we have the Charlotte cobras taking on
the Brazil Capybaras I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess alongside me once again is
international Master Tanya sachev Tanya
can you believe now that we've had a few
minutes what just happened earlier today
between the Indian yogis and the candid
chess bras Robin it's still sinking in I
mean just about an hour back if someone
would have said this is how it will end
we'd probably be like are you absolutely
out of your mind impossible the chess
bras were leading after round two with
five and a half to two and a half and we
were talking about whether it will even
go to round four and then we saw this
massive comeback by the Indian yogis in
round four taking it with four to zero
each and every player got out the best
in them and they were that they showed
up for the team and took that match in
round four we were thinking best case
scenario would be a playoff
would that happen many believed it
wouldn't and it didn't but who would
have said that the winners would be
Indian yogis I am still in shock and
this is what I love about sports about
Chess that it's truly not over till it's
over and that's what the Indian yogis
showed today just a fantastic
performance by each of the players in
that final round it's a match to
remember it will be hard to forget and
it impacts the standings because three
match victories leads a team to the
playoffs and right now there's only one
team in the entire protest league with
two match victories one away from
securing themselves a playoff spot and
that would be the Indian yogis they beat
the Canada chess bras who now drop to
one and one will have to win two more
matches of their own but the yogis they
seem like they will lock up a playoff
spot and they may be the team to beat in
the entire protesting
and I think it just comes down to their
lineup and their ambitious young players
as well but today's theme taking on
Canada chess cross just something that
is you know with magnus's form being
seven out of seven going into that last
round with it with prior to spawn just
the way they wrapped up their match
against the cobras how confident they
looked how they started today and I
think this is also a huge huge
confidence boost for the youngsters on
that Indian yogis theme and Robert as
you said it that's the team that all the
other others have to look at beating to
get that top spot right now one win away
to booking their spot into the playoffs
and the teams that we are about to see
they still need three match victories
overall they lost their first week the
Brazil Cappy bars take on the Charlotte
cobras and before we dive into that
match which team are you most surprised
at lost in week one
I mean it's got to be the Saint Louis
archbishops right they
they what uh demonstration of Father it
was by the Shanghai tigers in week one
against them it was a crushing Victory
it wasn't even just about winning the
match but the style in which they did it
for me that is the surprise of week one
finding the reigning champions of the
protest League down uh in the bottom of
the table
and you mentioned the St Louis
archbishops because they have a top
heavy lineup they had lender Dominguez
in week one but usually they have five
out of carwana and one team that usually
is very balanced is the Brazil Capybaras
but they have a special surprise uh to
the league because they had an amazing
free agent signee so the Brazil Cappy
bars they show up today with that man on
screen in front of you vladislav artemie
of 2700 plus player in classical chess
2800 in fide Blitz rating an absolute
monster on chess.com he is now the board
one of the Brazil capybara's Tanya oh
he's also a multiple time metal winner
for his Olympiad team he's won the
European Championship he was a briefly
in back in 2019 when he was barely 21
years old I think Robert in the world
top 10 and currently as well one of the
players who's touted to get back into
that world top 10 situation he is known
for his not only just his Fearless play
but his immense position understanding
coupled with his ability to spot tactics
and create sharp positions out of
nothing and this has been a sign up that
could really change the destiny of the
Capybaras they had such a tough run in
week one they lost that match up to the
Indian yogis in just three rounds and
desperate times call for desperate
measures and this is them signing up our
tamiyev will he deliver will he be the
star player he really needs to do that
for the Brazil Capybaras to stand up in
the standings I was surprised that he
was not in a roster but now he is in he
is board one for the Cappy bars and
board one for for Charlotte is a good
friend of his we see on board one
grigory o'parin or the cobras they're
around the same age uh both from Russia
4-2 or the cobras is Daniel naroditsky
he needs no introduction he's usually
commentating alongside us but today he
will put on his playing cap he will take
on the likes of Sandra morenco Jose
Martinez better known as Jasper and
Julia Alvarado board for for the Brazil
cat bars board four for the cobras is
Gabriella and Tova so very strong
forward Forester both sides and Grand
Masters on board three so from top to
bottom Tanya these lineups are stellar
a hundred percent but it's very
important for the Capybaras to not just
focus on board one it has to be a
contribution a team contribution that is
what makes the PCL the protest league so
unique every player has to do their job
I and we saw that with the chess process
today Magnus Carlsen was not enough to
get that team win that is love our time
we have a star player definitely and he
will look at scoring big but Jose
Martinez Alvarado as well as mareko need
to make sure that they get their game up
the one thing that Jose Martinez has to
do Robert is not repeat what he did in
week one that came against vidit
Gujarati where he was winning he took an
early draw which with it offered Mind
Games there by with it and that is
something that will not get you the win
so Jose Martinez needs to learn from
that big mistake
and and he is always learning and well
everybody should learn have learned by
now what the format of the protest
league is we just saw a match earlier
today but if you're new here welcome
everyone plays everyone on the opposing
team the time control is 10 minute plus
two second increment rapid it's up to
four rounds why up to four rounds
because the first team to reach eight
and a half points wins the match last
week the Indian yogis were the only team
to win in three against the Brazil
Capybaras if it is tied 8-88 we will see
a repeat of the round four pairings with
the colors reversed but round one
pairings that's what our Focus will be
on right now we know that vladislav
artemiev he is the big addition to the
Capybaras he gets the black pieces in
game one against Gabriella antova from
the Charlotte cobras but as we like to
do Tanya we look down at the middle
boards all the way through to the bottom
it's not just about artemiev and Oparin
but look at those middle boards it's
Grandmaster versus Grand Master on
boards two and three
wow and it looks so even in these
matchups on both two and three specially
so it's really going to be about whether
the favorites the heavy favorites on
board one and board four are able to
score for their team or can The
Underdogs just steal that very crucial
Half Point Robert we're almost ready to
to go we've got the two players on our
screens and we start with the Queen's
Pawn opening by Gabriela antova yes and
Gabriel plays D4 or tembiev he plays
Knight F6 so we are just getting set
here in the first game of this match now
Nerfs must be there for Gabriella she's
playing someone about 400 rating points
a buffer she's a very strong player in
her own right well in the team event
that's where the pressure really builds
you want to get that half point you want
to take some pressure off of your
teammates and here she's already
thinking on her third move will she play
a London system with Bishop F4 well she
just play the normal stuff C4 is played
by her so why not I think that you know
the game will be determined not just in
the first five moves but in what opening
Choice she plays how comfortable she is
and so far just normal stuff
you say normal stuff just as soon as our
tummy makes the small move eight six
which can be so discon concerting for a
lot of players because 86 is very
important in certain structures for
black but it also doesn't commit where
the black Bishop is developing too we
see Queen's Gambit decline with Bishop
coming to E7 we see ragozin with Bishop
coming to B4 then 8-6 can be a move that
throws you off and we see antova slowing
down there it stops to move Bishop from
C1 to G5 controls that square so really
takes away that development point and
now black has the flexibility where you
want to place that Bishop does it come
to E7 do you go C5 does it come to B4
and Andover needs to make sure she
doesn't burn the clock too much at this
moment Robert because the critical
Commandments will come later on and you
need the time for that she decides to
liquidate the center she decides to fix
the center and now takes out her bishop
and this is very important because you
want to push that King spawn one step
ahead to open that Bishop on F1 but what
you want is your own dark squared Bishop
to be ahead of the pawn rather than
behind that that's right so development
is good for white right now at some
point black could consider the move
Knight H5 especially if white puts upon
E3 it's like a London system you need
space for your Bishop to retreat you
don't have it so I expect to move like
C6 it's always available and play just
to create a punch in here so this is a
reasonable start from both sides they're
just you know getting their feet wet in
early stages of the second match and
both teams need a victory because if you
win three matches as a team you make the
playoffs if you lose three you're
eliminated this is an elimination Swiss
so while these two players sit and think
let's go to our bird's eye view we have
two other games underway in progress and
we see in the top right Brandon Jacobson
takes on Sandro mareko so Grand Master
versus Grandmaster and then board three
for the Cappy bars Jose Martinez better
known as Jasper he takes on Daniel
naroditsky you know the one of the best
content creators out there an amazing
commentator who you and I work with
frequently and that one is early stages
but a weird start to back game so maybe
we'll just you know go to Daniel's game
quickly and it's going to be do as Danya
says not as he does moment because as we
look at the first few moves we'll just
go back it was E4 D6 and D4 Knight C6
and once the pawn push D5 Knight back to
being Antonio not something we really
recommend
Robin you mentioned one of the biggest
content created
that and I'm just wondering is he
playing for Content here because you do
not play like that with the black pieces
he comes forward with the Knight falls
back giving white a huge lead in
development but it looks like Daniel is
confident about his position and his
opening approach definitely intended to
throw off his opponent to take him off
uh The Driven path already into unknown
territory has he managed to do that
already I know he wants to develop that
Bishop to G7 bring his King to safety
with Robert losing so many temples in
the opening can really come to haunt you
yes because this night went up to C6
back to B8 but there is tension between
Pawn so that's what Daniel was trying to
do he usually plays a king's Gambit
defense we are seeing what looks like a
King's game of Defense except the pawn
is on E5 so instead of the pawn being in
The Bishop's path the bishop has open
space on the diagonal black can also
consider C5 at the right moment but
because white is ahead in development
you don't just want to push your pawns
and allow white to continue to
development so Bishop G7 looks very
natural very strong the king quickly
castled to the king side and now it's
about what breaks does Dania want to see
Jasmine playing very quickly here Dania
you make a move like B5 try to kick this
Knight out of here get the E4 Pawn so
it's an adventurous opening but I think
it's actually worked out just fine
hmm we will find out in just a couple of
moves and it's very important for white
to try to make to make use of this a
slow opening chosen by Daniel with the
black piece especially one of the ideas
that always white has is to try and
trade off that Bishop so Queen D2 Bishop
86 could be something that white can
also consider as you're pointing out
defend that ifo pawn and Daniel you're
good friends with him he listens to you
he agrees with you you guys are on the
same wavelength Robert you called it
that he goes for the direct idea of B5
and that really is essential after
coming forward with the Knight and
falling back you need to create pressure
so immediately asking questions and
perhaps white can make a move like A3
just against the threat of B4 and say
you still can't play A5 and threaten B4
because watch out for that pin along the
a file A5 is possible but it really
doesn't help black at all so A6 go one
square instead of two protect this
opponent B5 that means the C6 Pawn
cannot move either up or capture without
B5 being dropped So Daniel narodeski I
think he might be in like a cobra's
outfit I I can't quite make it out there
uh but I wouldn't be surprised if the
cobras put together a team uniform and
the team will have to be as unified as
possible that is actually a Charlotte
chess Center at Cobra's uniform yeah no
that is it if we can zoom in on Donya
for a second here we can see that that
is a cobra's um Jersey it's a look at
that I feel like that's that's Daniel's
Jersey every time I see him he's always
rapping and always in this so we can't
see that little Cobra logo it's an
amazing team spirit there and of course
he's spoken about this the logos the
strategizing that the teams have come up
with it's amazing and every time in chat
I see this wave of emotes with the team
logos Robert this is what makes it so
much fun and so exciting to watch uh the
protest League
and Don you're trying to focus on his
game while his teammates are focused on
there so why don't we let both of these
two they are going to have their work
cut out for them it's a tense position
we still have three other games in
progress in the top left that's where we
start our day Gabriela and Tova very
solid against vladislav or temiev
nothing major happening at the moment
they're just a pair of Dark Sword
Bishops off the board the top right
there is a lot of tension in the center
with a potential hanging Pawn structure
between Jacobson and Sandro morenco and
in the bottom right Tanya we see Julia
Alvarado she gets the white pieces
against board one Gregory o'parin
o'parin has some activity on the queen
side with his Knight venturing out to B4
and The Rook on C8 uh but for that game
it's going to be a long battle so why
don't we hop into board two between
Jacobson and mareko we haven't given
that board our attention just yet and
I'm really fascinated by that battle I
mean I'm actually I feel like I'm going
to learn something here because there is
maximum tension like on C5 and D5 and D4
and the double Rooks on the C file over
here whose position do you prefer
I'm not sure I'm just glad I'm not on
either side Robert because look at that
nightmare in the center pun intended
what are these Knights even doing now
just imagine if black actually jumps
with his own Knight to E4 with these
four Knights facing each other off you
don't get to and it's on the board it's
been played it's on the board take this
position in you don't get to see this
every day notice the Black Knights on F5
E4 and the white Knights on E5 F4 so
many tactics in the position the center
is still volatile I it's just hard to
understand what is going on and the
players have just got minutes to make a
decision and what is Sandro morenco's
background because I'm trying to figure
that out I see Brandon Brandon Jacobson
he's comfortable he's a pillow behind
him but what is happening behind Sandra
mareko there it seems like some kind of
cool artwork uh I don't know if he's
playing from like a studio of some sort
but either way you know he's gonna have
to make art on the chessboard he's going
to take down Brandon Jacobson who is
very tough well known own and quicker
time patrols a 2550 plus Grandmaster
himself so this matchup Tanya the middle
boards they're pretty level between the
two sides so if one of the sides can
start winning games there like if
Brendan you can take this one home with
white or Sandro with the black pieces
can spring as H Pawn forward and go for
that Harry the H pawn attack maybe the
Cappy borrows will have a much better
week too
not just that you were talking about
artwork behind sanjo I think we've
already got a pretty artistic position
on the board with what the points that
we've been pointing out and all the
subtleties you're talking about H4 is a
potential idea white always has to also
look at for a trade on E5 Bishop E5 D5
and the Deep on advancing forward
imagine that Robert if Bishop E5 D5 D4
comes in and the D file opens up the
kind of tactics that would exist on the
board and I think this is the reason
that Brandon has decided to bring the
other Knight back he says enough of the
artwork enough of the nightmare in the
center he controls the E5 Square so that
if Sandra decides to capture that Knight
white has got the other knife to jump
and take its post you cannot allow black
to break in with the center with D4
this is just too much uh for my four
eyes here because this E5 Square Ultra
well defended you can't push upon F6 you
would do that in some positions but
because your Pawn's already in H5 the G6
Pawn will be left undefended so the
Knight is there to stay I like uh what
Brandon has done this bishop on B7
staring into his own Pawn this bishop 1
G2 staring into his Knight on e4 oh my
gosh there's a lot to work out here I
think uh for now uh you know we can let
the players do that because if we zoom
out look at what's going on between
Jasper that's Jose Martinez and Dania
narodiski in the bottom left the eval
bar is not happy with the way Jose has
played and we do have a pretty critical
moment coming up because with that last
move Knight into D5 Tanya this E4 Pawn
might just be blacks for the taking it
done you're trying to work out if he can
grab that pawn and run
and that's the big question right what
do you have in mind after Knight E4 not
only does it grab a pawn but it
threatens to grab another Pawn on B2 and
Bishop B2 would be a massive threat on
the board and Daniel not shying away
from it captures it and Jose Martinez
showing what he wanted jumps in with a
knife poking the rook and the bishop
Rook moves Queen D5 forking one night
and the other nine these are some
problems for black to be solved but I'm
just wondering does black have time to
set up some tactics along the diagonal
as Bishop B7 a possibility or is that
just completely nuts well if we can
bring up an analysis board and show why
Bishop B7 I think might just be one step
too slow uh the problem is after Bishop
B7 Queen takes Knight Knight D4 hitting
the queen hitting the bishop I think the
queen can slide back to the D3 square
and the bishop is defended with the Evo
bar is hovering around the middle I have
no idea why this is crazy it's Mayhem uh
this Knight on B6 no longer defended but
999 4 is loose but this maybe just the
bishop takes here and it pawn takes wow
it looks so messy right like even this
position where temporarily a material is
level oh white is somehow oh look at
Daniel but robin look at Daniel he is
definitely thinking about these tactics
and this mess that you're pointing out
look at him he's not even looking at his
screen right now
I think Dania is trying to understand if
he simply takes this Knight on B6 and he
gives up uh this Rook for the two minor
pieces loses his Knight here what you
said is the most important point this
Pawn on B2 will be hanging so black goes
down in exchange but gets not just a
single Pawn but two pawns for it and
quick activity and Donna is under four
minutes you know we were saying in the
previous matchup by Charlie in time
trouble others were spending too much
time Daniel can have two seconds left I
still trust him he is the highest rated
bullet player on chess.com B2 is loose
Bishop F5 to go after the next Pawn
that's also available he has the upper
hand here the minor pieces with the
couple pawns is more valuable than the
Rook
Robert you're calling out the action
Daniel goes for the line that you were
mentioning sacrificing in the center of
the board to pick up that B2 Pawn what
does that mean the eval Bar says well
done Daniel but on the way he's burnt
his clock and that could be a huge deal
right now let's just get a material
count in currently white is ahead and
exchange but black has got a million
pounds well not a million with two Pawns
in exchange so if you do the math Robert
it's pretty equal to pawns and a minor
piece for a rook so it's five to five
but it seems like it favors black
because the piece activity imagine once
that light squared Bishop comes to B7
comes to F5 to Great squares for the
bishop to attack the C2 Pawn the B4 Pawn
can always be guarded with a pawn push
like A5 meanwhile White's Rooks they're
only as strong as the amount of open
files they have and currently they're
struggling to get the activity no open
files for these Rooks that is uh the key
Point here and why white is at a
disadvantage the Bishops uh for black
just great especially this dark Square
bishop and as you said the light Square
Bishop can choose its own diagonal and
choose its own adventure so Dania
narodisky in a great position with the
black pieces against Jose Martinez so
we'll leave Jose to figure out his next
move and we'll go back to our bird's eye
view because every single game we say
this every single round is of equal
importance in the protesting whether you
win against the opponent Sport 4 or
their board one that is worth one point
to your team you need to reach eight and
a half to win so we looked in the top
right though that has now clarified a
bit that's actually opening up uh still
not an easy position in the bottom left
we were just looking at Dania and Jose
so where do you want to go which board
four board one matchup should we tune
into
well all the boards the actions heating
up and I think we have to take a look at
that bottom right board I see our eval
bar gives a huge advantage to Oparin
what is happening here why is it so bad
for Julia because I see the position and
then I realize that Robert is that is
that that's a material imbalance block
has an extra Exchange
that is indeed an extra exchange and
pawn for black how did this happen well
let's just go over the last few moves
The Rook came to C8 the queen came up
and white was doing just fine but after
this decision with Rook E2 the bishop
came to C4 work D2 they actually Eva
likes what white has done but after
Queen E6 this move Rook A4 that's the
culprit in one turn the Knight on B3 is
under attack twice but after Knight
takes C2 and the Knight on B3 is not
under defense anymore so you take here
and after Bishop takes B3 this is a
monster Bishop 1 B3 hitting all the
pieces and well this is the best that
they could do and now she's just trying
to liquidate hope that she can have some
chances here but it's pretty
straightforward stuff for black up at
clean exchange and upon
and also why it's only active piece is
that Queen on B6 and Oparin wants to
Target that Queen and offer a trade a
move like Queen C6 one you can once you
can drive the queen away or trade it
into an end game The Rook will be the
decisive Factor White's Bishop on F3
really doesn't do much so not giving any
compensation it looks like Julia is
busted in this one Robert which means we
should pull out the bird's eye view and
take a look on the other action because
here it looks like the cobras will be
venomous what is happening take a look
at that top left oh sorry top right
board as well with Sandro against
Brandon that is a position that's wide
open I see white has an extra Pawn on B3
and open d-line an open C Line This is
wild stuff yeah as it will go to this
board two versus Board three matchup
Brandon Jacobson with the white pieces
we're liking his Knights shuffling
around but now he has no Knights
remaining and this Knight on F5 is
protecting a very important G7 square
there's no Checkmate there there's no
Checkmate on h8 because of the Rook
black actually has two minor pieces for
a rook and a pawn but the King on H7
doesn't feel that safe so I see the
evaluation bar off to the side I'm not
too bothered by it because if certain
trades happen let's say the Queens come
off I don't think that black is better
anymore at least their winning chances
will be hard to come by with limited
material remaining so it's a trickier
position than just minus two and a half
or whatever the evaluation Bar says and
right now Sandra mareko trying to figure
out his current move because Tanya
there's pressure down this line uh the
bishop is already under attack you don't
want to walk into a pin white does have
this extra Pawn over here which may be
used as a decoy and morenco plus Queen
B7 just going right after this B3 Pawn
while protecting the bishop I like that
move because you not only sidestep from
this horrendous d-line that you were
talking about with the rook and the
Bishops lined up but you also put
pressure on the B3 Square now imagine
the same position Robert and if black
didn't have that pawn on e4 black would
probably be completely winning that pawn
is actually White's friend because it's
stopping all the activity of that long
diagonal Bishop that would be the dream
but there's no way for black to actually
open up this diagonal to Target that
white king meanwhile white has set up
the battery along the A1 AJ diagonal
giving him a lot of activity the queen
can jump into F6 but right now Brandon
has a big question to answer how is he
defending the B3 Pawn because you can't
really step up on the board right you go
B4 it doesn't help one Bishop doesn't
grab it but the other Bishop grabs it
Bishop to B4 jumps in I'm actually not
finding a way to defend that pawn and
neither does Brandon so he simply
sidesteps with the rook and the idea is
that if you take on B3 you will pick up
that Bishop on D6 remember remember how
you pointed out Robert that Knight on F5
needs to keep the G7 Square guarded so
that will not be a possibility but this
walks into Bishop B4 and now I'm
securing your king your queen and the
Rook yeah Bishop B4 wins material on the
spot so Sandra mareko he can do what
Dania nerdinski looks like he's doing
trying to win with the black piece he
goes the wrong direction wait a second
let's go back what was wrong
oh my God he just he just shook his head
in disbelief that Sandro did not play
Bishop before he simply wins a rook for
a bishop and would win the game instead
he goes to E5 and I understand what
Sandra was doing he was worried about
the Queen the bishop he just did not see
or maybe he didn't think that Brandon
might have blundered but Rook D2 was I
mean it was a bad position at that point
for white it was tough position and now
Brandon's right back in this Sandro's
he's fine without this bishop white has
no attack that's the good news uh the
bad news is with limited material maybe
after Rook takes D5 and even a sacrifice
in F5 it might just be one where white
can hold the draw but wow Brendan's just
playing with fire every turn
wow and now once again he lets that
light Square Bishop live and takes on B2
an understandable decision also saving
the B3 Pawn what Brandon is counting on
is getting that pawn into the game now
we've been talking about getting rid of
that E4 Pawn but black has the option to
get the position the bishop into the
game through H3 H4 comes to mind Move
That Knight bring that Bishop to H3
create creating threats imagine if the
queen lands on F3 that would be game
over oh my God and Sandro missed that
move with the bishop but he finds the
move with the Knight with the plan
Bishop H3 Queen E7 Queen F6 Queen F3 and
Robert if we can just highlight the path
to victory for black here I'm slightly
surprised with this move though I have
to say that Bishop belongs on H3 maybe
he's going to F3 in the queen will go to
H3 that's exactly what Sandra Mariko
wants the Knight is also protecting F7
so you don't need the queen to stay
defending that square so it looks very
promising for him uh down under a minute
by the way Gregory aparn has one with
the black pieces for for the cobras we
expected that to happen when you went up
in exchange he was able to convert that
Advantage but this is a big moment
Brennan Jacobson he could have taken the
light Square bishop and said he took the
Dark Sword Bishop now finds himself in
trouble his b-pawn can't move any
further this queen going over to these
types of squares there might be a
lobster pincer Checkmate against the
white king this is bad news I would say
bear is with bad news Cobras for
Charlotte because this is just all the
pieces going right in here
uh I'm struggling here with white and
white would be terrified in this
position I mean even if you just move
your queen and he does that to try to
advance the beep on but it's not in time
what he's looking for is after Queen F5
he wants to offer a queen trade with
Queen F4 but that wasn't the only idea
that Sandro has Rook C8 and Brandon
missing a tactic again with the queen
and the Rook lined up he ends up losing
material now picks up the queen Robert
is this as easy as it looks or is there
work to be done there is a bit of work
because this b-pawn but look at this
you're trying to go H3 check the King
has no Escape scores if you take the
pawn queen G4 picks up this Rook so I do
think that Central America has under
control I want to turn our attention
back to the bird's eye view for a second
because the cobras are in huge trouble
right now so as we look at the bottom
left Daniel narodiski had a great
position but suddenly it's all Joss from
using the clock as a weapon just well
ahead on time and going after donya's
King on H7 I don't know exactly how this
happened it looks so proud promising for
Dania but there must be tactics related
to a sacrifice on H5 this king is In
Harm's Way this bishop is slicing
through the Rooks to that G8 Square
Tanya I feel like Dania is just a couple
moves from just being lost here as this
king is not safe at all
If I sacrifice and our eval bar hits it
and I'm just wondering if this gives
Daniel enough time to set up gown to
play with Queen to F4 but he chooses a
slightly more passive square with Queen
to F7 and drop it this lines up the
bishop on B3 tactics everywhere it does
got the H5 square but I think Queen F4
was the key move because you're
threatening a repetition with Queen C1
Queen F4 and that's why Queen C5 was
inaccurate the queen should have went to
beef I'm just going to show this very
very quickly that if the queen had gone
to B5 this queen probably had it maybe
be stuck in some positions with the
bishop being loose on the B7 square
instead the queen goes to F7 defending
the H5 Pawn but with the queen in line
with this bishop I still think you can
get rid of this Rook after so maybe Rook
takes H5 there's a GTA Rook H6 check but
Bishop takes F7 to follow
like does have many pieces for the queen
on the board Rook H5 sacrifices the two
rocks with the queen this is wild yeah
we asked earlier about Queen sacrifice
how about a double Rook Sacrifice from
Jose Martinez Queen takes H5 is not just
check but mate 95 gets in the way this
king is being hunted F4 the king will
take it will done to be able to escape
this one in time travel he's laughing he
doesn't even think so maybe you pick up
this bishop but this King should be in
grave Danger
wow and look at this Dania is playing on
four seconds on the clock his only hope
is that horse Jose's clock also runs
down he gives a check he can simply pick
up the bishop but Daniel will count on
picking up that C2 Pawn trying to create
counter play and yes it might be lost
for for black with white needs to be
careful still playing on seconds Robin
it's too soon to call out the result on
this one yeah what is it the bullet
Chess Championship all of a sudden both
players down to the final seconds the
two second increment will be important
the King on H6 is out on the open Dunya
he makes a move with just 1.3 seconds
left he wants to get after this Pawn if
the bishop gets it before he will have a
chance but Jose will not allow that this
king is in trouble maybe bishop E4 with
Queen C6 to follow oh it should be four
oh that is nasty because he stops the
Bishop from coming into D4 there's a
check on eight seven and now the king is
just he's gonna pick up the H5 he gives
a check from F7 wins the Knight on G6
and Daniel there uh throws his hand in
the air he knows this is all over the
Knight on G6 is spin this is heartbreak
this is painful for Daniel
yes and what a swing in this game it
looked like it was all narodesky early
on and now Jose Martinez is up a queen
and we do have a result Sandra morenco
beats uh Brenda Jacobson we expected
that given uh the queen and Knight for
the two Rooks but now it's going to be
another victory for the Capybaras oh wow
what Precision by Jose Martinez
just amazing stuff those last couple of
moves with the checks the bishop coming
into G6 the queen check picking up the
night after a pain and now finally this
winning the rook in the end forcing a
resignation by Daniel some very precise
chess there converting the win a huge
result for Jose and with this the Brazil
capabiras take a three to one lead
against the Charlotte cobras read the
one in favor of the Brazil capybars I
think they scored three and a half
points all of week one and they got
obliterated but now they come out with a
bang the grand Masters for the Brazil
Cappy bars get it done and then for the
Charlotte cobras only Grigio paren on
board one for the cobras he took down
board four for the capybara's but Tanya
this looks like a different Brazil team
this week
yeah and I was talking about Jose
Martinez's passive decision against with
it to take a draw in what looked like a
clearly better position today he left no
ground for any confusion in his
intentions that attack that he put up in
against Daniel naroditsky the way he
finished off
Jose Martinez is a man who's making his
intentions very clear today he is going
to be a big big factor for the Brazil
Capybaras and Daniel nerdinski likely to
be a factor for the cobras he did lose
that game against Jocelyn but he has a
chance to bounce back the players will
reset they'll get a break we'll see new
matchups on the flip side of that break
but we will return after a few moments
this is the protest League week two
matchup between the Brazil Capybaras and
the Charlotte cobras we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now chest clock app right here almost
there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can plank keep
that big butt down dude
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time lapse yeah okay you bring a clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get something to eat okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
oh
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just clock up right here almost
there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can plank keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time lapse yeah
you bring a clock oh I left my clock at
home dude you idiot I told you to bring
it let's just go get something to eat
okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
[Music]
all right let's go
thank you
[Music]
foreign
the Brazil capybara is out to a 3-1 lead
over the Charlotte cobras here in this
week two matchup in the Pro chess League
Jose Martinez was a star against Daniel
nerdinski but the biggest star added to
the Brazil capybara's lineup and maybe
the biggest free agent signing thus far
in the protest League season Tanya
vladislav artemiev we know him he's an
absolute monster
I couldn't agree more with that and I
think this is just what the Capybaras
needed after that week one performance
and credit to them to be able to do so
much damage control and make sure they
get one star player to lead the team and
that is our tamiyev and he showed what
he's capable of in game one he needs to
score big he needs to score heavy he
starts with a banger robot with that
game of Jose Martinez against Daniel
naroditsky what chess did we just
witness and more of that coming up in
round two always more to come and you're
right huge signing by the Brazil cat
bars teams can get up to eight free
agents throughout the year they have to
drop some players from their roster to
secure those players but we see that
vladislavartamev he scored a victory in
round one in round two he will have a
different matchup a more challenging
matchup at least on paper uh as he is
the top board for the Kappa baras he now
will face the third board for the cobras
he is going to take on Brandon Jacobson
so the top three boards the capybars
scored victories the board won for the
cobras won his game but we'll see in
round two now we see that artemia has to
play against Jacobson Gabrielle antonova
she lost her game to artemiev she gets
the black pieces against Sandra morenco
and that is not an enviable task Tanya
you lose to artemia and you get black
against mareko the pro chess League just
has these strong lineups from top to
bottom
it gets tougher and tougher there is no
rest for the wicked here at the protest
league and you have to be up for it we
saw that in the first matchup of today
how the players bounced back and
currently it is on Charlotte on the
Charlotte Cobra's theme Daniel nardicki
also has to bounce back from that last
round defeat he's playing against the
lowest Board of the Capybaras he'll be
playing against Julia he needs to secure
that point for his team but he
definitely needs to leave that loss
behind and it's also a big psychological
battle for the players coming out the
turnaround between the rounds it's such
a short time and how quickly they're
able to leave that behind
right you know you have to have a
short-term memory uh you just want to
get rid of that loss in round one and if
you're Brandon Jacobson you're playing
as vladis love artemiev that is as tough
of a matchup as you can get in this
league of course there's Sakara Nakamura
there's Magnus Carlson but artemiev is
right up there with those behemoths of
the online chess World our tembiev is
somebody that everybody knows well he is
a free agent signee and he is ready to
go with the white pieces
and he's been the biggest sign up of
week two of the PCL this season so far
so going to be interesting to see how he
does the in-game to one things for sure
Robert about Brandon in game one he was
missing a lot of tactical ideas against
our tamiyev he cannot let that happen
and we see a retting on the board so
it's going to be a slow opening
yes and this is our bartender's
wheelhouse he plays B3 here G3 These
Quiet fianchetto variations uh but he's
just such a classy end game player he
really is great at maneuvering he can
get into a tactical Skirmish and thrive
in it but he prefers more closed
positions where he can outplay his
opponent so for Brandon Jacobson he
clearly prefers the Wild games we just
saw his round one uh situation against
Sandra morenco there were like
sacrifices open diagonals things of that
nature and look at this he doesn't want
symmetry he brings his Knight to H6 and
likely to F5
that's why the night is headed it looks
like one second you're not supposed to
bring their Knight to the edge of the
board uh but it isn't going to stay
there for very long you want to get it
to the center and often even further on
to the center with D6 and E4 in the
middle game but you can't afford to
spend too many moves on the night
currently he is thinking about Brandon
well I saw him adjust his camera a
little bit I think there's uh it's
getting a bit shaky there so but
eventually he will decide or he decides
to bring the Knight to F5 I was thinking
to develop the other night as well
Knight F5 a reasonable move here and
meanwhile white will at the opportune
moment strike in the center with C4 or
even prepare and E4 at once
yes and Brandon you know he was he got
up from his bed I believe he is a
college student I think he's playing
from his dorm room not sure if he has
space for a desk but either way you know
he is just playing there uh you know
he's as all players are multiple camera
angles making sure that fair play is
upheld so I don't know where he ran to
but he ran right back in his night has
run around from H6 F5 to D6 it's like a
carousel in these parts I'm getting
nauseous just looking at it but it does
stop both of the pawn breaks you
mentioned with that pawn sitting on D5
Robert I was talking about getting the
Knight to D6 and then eventually to E4
bit I thought that it's a good idea to
move more than just the knight in the
opening at least that's what we had
learned right growing up do not move the
same piece twice this is playing with
fire against one of the strongest Grand
Masters in the world and we see our
Tamia has slowed down he decides to take
a think on what is the best way that he
can make the most of these plenty Night
Moves he wants to start getting that
Central break in he wants to go rookie
one break in the center with E4 and
Brandon continues to play with his
Knights and the reason for that is he
wants to get this a knight from D7 to F6
again binding down that move E4 imagine
once it lands on F6 you really take
control of the E4 Square
and you're calling it all Tanya you are
a prophet just like Daniel nerdinsky
these Knights are just scoping out the
center here making sure that no Pawn
trades happen and while the Bishop on G7
is developed the bishop on C8 is not but
it can go to somewhere along this
diagonal so the games are underway it's
not just this one between vladislav
artemiev and Brandon Jacobson we have uh
boards two for the Capybaras and Boards
three that's in the top right Sandra
morenco taking on board four of the
cobras Gabriela antova early stages
there kind of a queen's gamut accepted
position in the top right in the bottom
left we see an interesting Pawn
structure so it might be worth diving
into that game in a second the one
between oparan and Jose Martinez in the
bottom right we see a rosalimo sicilian
Daniel nerdinski with the white pieces
he'll need to bounce back for the cobras
but yeah the bottom left game between
Oparin and Jose Martinez that is such an
interesting position it's one uh we've
seen before it's not novel territory
exactly you see old Parts clock I barely
spend any time but White's Pawn
structure compromise but if we cut the
board in half time that you mentioned
this in previous games white has a four
on three majority over here on the king
siren four pawns just a three for black
Zone that has the repetition of being
super solid and strategic we often see
white wanting to advance that F on down
the board wherever you have the bond
majority you want to try to glance upon
Avalanche but notice how the bishop on
C5 for the moment makes Shaw with the
King on G1 that F4 will not be possible
so I am expecting black to use that to
the advantage and for Jose to actually
try to Target the E5 Pawn as quickly as
he can and he does it Robert with the
move rookie it which forces white to
defend with maybe bishop to F4 because I
wanted to say rookie one you know bring
your Rook to the open file but that
would make the F2 Pawn so tender I'm not
sure if there is a direct refitation for
it but I just feel that Bishop F4 would
feel safer but what would I know or
Byron says he's calculated it all he
doesn't care about Queen H4 he defends
it with Europe
yeah brings The Rook T1 can play Bishop
E3 maybe to defend this F2 Pawn if it's
under attack and just enjoying the fact
that there is an extra Pawn uh towards
the king side for white that means you
can go after this black king but only
once you get your king safe I think
Bishop E3 looks strong swap the Bishops
off play F4 in the future just expand on
the king side that looks really really
strong for Oparin but Jose Martinez
solid position from black side as well
no easy targets
I love that move Bishop E3 you target
the most active piece in your opponent's
Camp I'm also looking at attacking
possibilities here for a bar and you can
already start threatening mates on the
board by bringing the queen into the
attack a move like Queen H5 but it
doesn't really get anything because
black could have just blocked the mate
uh the idea of taking up on 87 with the
move G6 actually in fact gaining Tempo
so instead operand goes for your idea of
trying to trade off the Bishops and
let's point out if black actually did
pick up that Bishop on E3 The Rook would
come to E3 capture that bishop and it
would be a huge Rook lift because
suddenly we can imagine a lot of attacks
on the king side with Queen H5 The Rook
coming into G3 that could be a nightmare
for black uh so apparent making sure
that doesn't happen and meanwhile
launches that King side March down the
board with the Bots wow so for Jose
Martinez this could be a bit scary and
someone who is rooting for Jose more
than pretty much anyone would be crick
or mechatarans we have the captain of
the Capybaras quicker mkhitaryan joining
us crick or my friend how are you doing
hey Robert how's it going
well I think that the question that
Tanya and I have you know as we exchange
our pleasantries is you ask how it's
going how's it going for you I mean your
team lost in week one but here in week
two off to a great start
yeah we had a tough match last week
uh and today we had a a pretty good
start we had some very tough games
especially on board two and three of
course that I think are more the more
uh the more the most important ones in
the first round and they both went uh
our way so it's a pretty good start but
of course it's a long match with four
rounds so
we're waiting to see what's happening in
the second round now
it's a big round cricket and before we
get into the chest the big news for
protest league has been the first major
sign up mid-season with getting our
Tamia on board how did that happen tell
us a little bit about that decision by
the Brazil capybaras
uh well I mean uh I had kind of an idea
already to try to go for a big uh player
depending on how the first match went of
course I had to think before because of
the rating limitations
so then I started to think and I mean he
is a player that I always been a big fan
of I think is like amazingly strong in
this rapid and Blitz formats especially
so I was really happy that we were able
to to bring him in after some talks
hmm a huge huge signing for you and it's
playing out well thus far but when we
zoom out to our four board scene because
krikor in addition to being captain of
the Brazil cat bar as you manage them
you also play for them and You're a
Grand Master with a fantastic twitch
channel so we'll of course get your
channel some love in the chat but as you
look at our four boards here right uh we
see in the top left is our temmieve
against Brandon Jacobson uh you know
solid start or artemium I like his
position here uh what about your board
four tell us a little bit about Julia
Alberto and about her position that she
has against Daniel narodeski
uh yeah I'm just seeing the the position
now I saw it was a sicilian uh wrestling
variation I think she's been very
experienced in this kind of uh in this
line especially I think she has played a
lot of this with black already against
suffer position of course she has like
very tough first and second round that's
how it goes in the in the Pro chess
League but uh actually I kind of like
her position because I think White's not
uh not I mean F4 is not coming so fast
if you play that H5 maybe I don't know
if I'm in time to play that I have to
also look for B4 also
but generally I think these positions
are uh pretty decent for black but
actually not H5 could be
a little bit delicate on Knight C4 and
B4 I don't know
but I think she's very comfortable I
think she likes this kind of position so
that's what matters most if you're kind
of feel good in the position if you have
some experience already in this kind of
structures because it's very tricky you
know this position can go
wrong for white and for or for black
suddenly easily it's very tricky
position they play so many games in
these lines and still no one knows what
to do how to play exactly so it's very
tricky
and we've seen so many uh positions just
like this from Magnus Carlson games
Tanya you've commentated on so many of
them I don't know really when is the
right moment to strike with F4 as
critical has been indicating that might
just open up this Beast of a bishop on
G7 uh Knight C4 now taken out so what's
your experience like here what are you
thinking about this position
I completely agree with krikor I think
Julia's got all the reasons to be happy
with the positions as long as white
doesn't get that Central break in
because that would only make her Bishop
super strong and Daniel understands that
he develops with the queen uh and I want
to ask you krikar what do you think it
is that Julia needs to be careful about
here because I look at her clock is that
a little boring for you she's down to
about five and a half minutes and wow f4
on the board
yeah I mean it's uh when he got a you
know a big difference uh rating
difference like this of course it's not
a pleasant uh feeling to be uh behind on
the clock but I think that's what
happens uh quite a lot uh Dania usually
is kind of practical player so he
usually plays quite fast which was very
nice for us to see him get into time
trouble and last game of course is a
beast and also in time trouble but I
think usually he's he's ahead in the
clock and that that's when he's mostly
dangerous and that's a similar uh I
think
martinis also feel this way he also
plays test and wants to put his
opponents in time trouble so that's how
I think that game went uh already in the
first in the first round
but basically for now
uh is happening fast apparently
please Bishop H6
but now maybe and this could allow F5 no
is that something you'd be worried about
in the position
F5 is possibly annoying now
I I hate this light Square Bishop for
black right it's not doing anything
besides stopping the knight from coming
to C4 and after F5 your knight on C7
can't get to E6 so I feel like Black's
minor pieces are just gonna be worse in
this closed position and white has these
Knights and activity against the king
yeah you could also take on E5 but
probably that's not too much yeah five
looks very strong now actually five
looks annoying you probably have to take
on E3 and then
play F6
maybe it's not that bad actually is it
I don't know
it's one of those positions where I feel
like it does look unpleasant for black
but you see strong players say yeah it's
not that big of a deal I'll just go up
into my shell and try to survive this
and Dania understands the gravity of the
moment right he hasn't moved yet he
hasn't played F5 even though it's
probably the first instinct he had was
to make this push because he's not
certain if he should release the tension
sometimes it's more valuable to keep
this tension between pawns maybe even
take the pawn offer the bishop trade you
see the queen gets out but so does the
White Knight so I feel like both sides
will have their chances in the event of
fe5 whereas F5 feels more controlled hmm
yeah possibly but then the Knight on C7
is gonna jump at some point if you take
any five so he did take 25 but
apparently is a decent move according to
Bill
evil bar but Queen five what is he
wanted to do no matter F3 maybe and I'm
gonna have four Queen H6 those kind of
ideas yeah that F3 I'm back
to E7 yeah
Maybe
I think you both are saying the same
thing and I agree with the two of you
that the night coming to E6 it's now
freed up whereas if why to put F5 the
Knight on C7 would have looked bad but
what does E5 here
just to trade so Krick or is saying we
need to trade but then Queen H6 and
Knight G5
and it's on the board by the way she has
gone for Knight D5 and uh suddenly this
queen 86 Knight G5 how do you fight it
and of course Daniel plays it instantly
now I got my player my player got
checkmated because of me I say Knight D5
well quicker No One's Gonna blame you
but yeah this was a tough position for
her um with the Knight trying to come to
E4 she offers a trade but now the trade
also has this bottom B6 under attack not
to mention Knight to G5 with mate so how
do you defend against this you might
have to push this f-pawn to F6 or F5
even maybe
before yeah I don't know maybe I don't
know
but even here it doesn't look the end of
the world I think the problem is just
you have a bad light score Bishop but it
doesn't look losing right hmm maybe you
can go right
you're right yeah
still playable yeah definitely playable
and once you take on D5 the bishop
starts playing I don't know
if you play that five yeah
yeah I think she's in this and quicker I
gotta ask you you know we know that you
have a lot going on now but is it
stressful to watch these games if we
just bring up the bird's eye view
quickly and look at the four games uh
you know we will let you get back to it
being captain and streaming but are you
nervous looking at your four boards
right now
I mean the first round I was very
nervous because you got so many time
troubles and the
Jacobson against mareko game was so
tense he was going our way but it was a
very complicated game both players in
time trouble so yeah as as they say
watching is sometimes more tense than
playing
but uh I haven't uh I didn't stop to
check the other games exactly right now
see what's going on but it's very
stressful to watch it's even worse than
playing sometimes
well I think we're going to leave you to
your stress all alone sorry about that
crit core you know you know I love you
but uh we are gonna let you go for now
but we'll talk soon Buddy and good luck
to your capybaras
thank you nice seeing you Tanya and
Robert bye
Gregor is honestly awesome like I have
so many you know fond memories of him
he's such a good person such a strong
player even though he beat me in our
winner stays match way back when that
was fun uh but he is saying he is
stressed out as the captain of the
Capybaras and the reason why is on this
game it looks like a clear end game Edge
or white a healthier Pawn structure
control of an open file and I think that
Julia she's hanging well but Daniel with
a two-minute lead on the clock and the
better position I think we trust his
winning chances here
well let's say we do trust his winning
chances as you're pointing out
especially the clock playing a big role
here uh but Robert I think the good news
for crick or if you pull up the bird's
eye view will be the top right board as
we're gonna see now and I see the eval
Bar says that Sandro has a huge
advantage and that's because take a look
at those nights they seem like they're
just dominating dark squares with that
pawn on F7 Under Fire as well and I
think this is a huge game for Capybaras
to make sure that they strike against
the lowest Board of the Charlotte cobras
yes and look at the clock I mean if it's
not just the position which is
apparently completely winning for white
at this point it's the time and there
must be asbestos there must be a
sacrifice on F7 because the evaluation
bar in a position that has equal
material doesn't get that high unless
there's a sacrifice or something that is
just direct so if Rook takes F7 there is
a B4 at the end of this because the Rook
on C8 is left undefended so this is just
wow yeah just straightforward it's a
powerful approach you can even take
first and play B4 you win this Knight on
C5
but that's a nice
F7 and one second uh Gabriella has gone
for it and after Rook F7 before picking
up the Rook on F7 uh Sandro instead
decides to play B4 immediately hitting
that Knight the eval bar approves of the
line that you were mentioning Queen D5
and now she's gonna pick now he's gonna
pick up the Rook eventually trade the
queens and win tonight this is going to
be a material and exchange up for white
and I don't see any compensation for
Gabriella in this end game no she's
gonna be down what a rook and a pawn for
just a night something like that and she
loses on time but the position was
hoping you look at Mariko we see a fist
bump celebration yeah he is pumped he
knows that he's doing this for the big
boss quicker mechatarian and Sandra
mareko scores a second consecutive
victory for the Brazil Cappy Barras
they're now into a 4-1 lead
amazing stuff and I think the
celebration is not just for winning this
game but also the way he did it even
game one against Brandon was full of
tactics and it looked like Sandra was
ahead of them and even this one he
demolishes a black with just the final
blow of Knight F7 so he's very pleased
with his play today so far
yes and look at the top left
artemiev the big free agent signee for
the Brazil Cappy bars look at him go he
is up in exchange for just one Pawn
Black's pieces are not well coordinated
there may be a pin along the back rank
this Rook has an open file to go to as
well so Brandon Jacobson down to a
minute both sides at about a minute
Tanya it's getting into that bullet
territory but artemius also one of the
best bullet players on the site
but that doesn't even matter right
because the clock is not the main
problem here black is down a full
exchange as well as pressure on the D5
Pawn now we've been talking about Rooks
are only as strong as the open files
that they have and of course our tummy
have shifts it to the open file the open
C line bringing the Rook into the game
always watch out for a check on C8
because that won't be a check it will be
a mate currently the bishop on F5
luckily guards that square but once
white gets his own Bishop to G2 starts
attacking the D5 Pawn you've got threats
across the board and it just looks like
this exchange up is going to be more
than enough uh and Brandon once again in
huge trouble and Robert this is what I
was pointing out Brandon just looks like
he's missing a lot of tactics today
which is so unusual for him we know how
strong he is at all time controls but
today it's not going his way and
artemiev can trade Queens if he wants
I'm not sure if he instead wants to
bring his Queen up and is Rook to see oh
that's just winning because F7 is and
the Knight is also loose
this wind's on the spot oh wow but our
time we have Mrs
for this end game because you can't jump
in with the Rook to the seventh Rank and
start targeting the B7 pawn it can't
survive for too long you can't push it
up the board but the Rook will go behind
the pawn and win it and win the game
eventually
okay so our time you have in the
driver's seat right now B6 uh that pawn
is only gonna survive for so long over
here you can also switch gears and go
after this Pawn on D5 it's going to be a
win I believe for artemia if it seems
like it's up his wheelhouse so while he
is working let's go back to the bird's
eye view because something big is
happening in the bottom left of your
screen it's a back and forth Affair but
right now it looks like Gregory
o'parin's back is against the wall
because Jose Martinez the Beast that he
is and that bar has dropped and gone
back to the middle up and down it was
never at the highest point that was
still left over from the previous game
but we look here there's a king on F7
there's a king on F2 there's a past Pawn
on D4 going to D3 Tanya I think black
should just just push it
I mean you've got that pawn push and
baby as gases says D3 is just so
tempting you're threatening to go down
the board with D2 D1 and it's on the
board and White's the one who's got to
answer the question what does he have in
mind and the eval bar seems to hate
White's position more and more you can
even go D2 now why stop nothing stopping
you the bishop has to fall back to
defend that pawn from queening but that
would mean Black's Rook can also slide
up the board from eight seven all the
way to H1 it looks like Oparin in this
one is busted what a match this is
turning out to be by the Brazil
capybaras
unbelievable turnaround from week one
and the King on F7 covers everything the
G8 Square the G6 Pawn the bishop on E6
is defended everything for black every
piece doing its rope to Perfection this
C Pawn can Rumble down the board as well
not a single check against this King
this queen would need to be on the back
rank but that Queen cannot infiltrate if
you have Queen D6 thank you very much
let's liquidate black is up how many
pawns right now I believe it's just one
but it looks like two
I mean look at that pawn on D2 that is
not any simple Pawn a queen trade would
just go into a lost end game and now
it's not just a Pawn on D2 but the C
Pawn advances to help his monstrous
friend on D2 C3 C2 is Unstoppable as you
mentioned white is just unable to build
an attack against Black's king and the
pieces the Harmony in Jose Martinez
position is so strong to stop any
defense he's just been advancing the
pawns Unstoppable watch out for that
made on f8 some Precision there offering
a queen trade if that happens it's lost
I'm expecting resignation already cannot
see a way for white to continue playing
you can just trade off the Queens as
well bring your Rook to D7 pick up that
pawn uh or else you can continue
marching down the board with C2 doesn't
choices there take one one Pawn a queen
appears and a win on time and on the
board look at that there's Jubilation
from Jasper he is pumped and he gets the
stretch Flex his muscles and he is
leading the Capybaras in this match
they're up six to one and as we Zoom
away from Jose we look at the other
boards Daniel nerdinski in the bottom
right getting the job done and in the
top left vladis of artemiov is already
won his game for the Brazil capybara so
Tanya it's a bit of deja vu because if
we bring up the scores of this round we
will see a familiar sight the top three
boards for the Capybaras they win their
games and Daniel neradiski just like
gorilla power in the round before he
takes down the board for the Cappy bars
but three to one in the first two rounds
in favor of the cat bars it's now six to
two
I'm just amazed at the job that krikor
has done with this team because it looks
like a brand new team that we're seeing
this week too of the protestly Brazil
capaveras were destroyed by the Indian
yogis in just three rounds and it looks
like they're back with a vengeance uh
this week taking down the Charlotte
cobras currently with a score of 6-2
they just need two and a half points to
wrap up the match
the cobras I mean they are getting
pummeled it feels like an artemia he was
the PowerHouse free agent that joined
the Capybaras but Jose Martinez and
Sandra morenco they are also awake and
playing great chess we had quicker
mkhitaryan join us he was saying that he
believes in his team he's nervous to
watch I don't think he's that nervous
right now but don't go anywhere because
while we take a break remember that
earlier today the Indian yogis they
stormed back from a huge deficit kind of
like this one against the Kansas chess
Bros so we'll see if the Charlotte
cobras can make it two for two in the
day in terms of comebacks will return
shortly to this protesting matchup
between the Brazil capybars and the
Charlotte cobras be right back
foreign
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
in competitive chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders it's easy to feel
alone
those lonely days are over
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
they are having a party in France
[Applause]
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and nights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives the wheels came off wow she
just took down Hikaru Nakamura and look
at her she is jubilant entering its
Fifth Season 16 teams will reboot the
PCL Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion what what was that
what was that oh my gosh
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
we win
oh my God
welcome back everybody Tanya you look a
little bit different and you kind of
look like Vivek Gujarati did it congrats
on that epic comeback for your Indian
yogis how does it feel to win the match
and to beat Magnus Carlson in the
process
you know when something is uh less
likely and then it happens then the joy
is more and we started the match very
poorly like we were trailing by five and
a half to one and a half
and at that point like
the rational just says that Magnus is
there iron is there that they have a
pretty easy route to eight and a half
but from there we just you know lead
very well we fought very hard and I
think the cherry on the top for me was
for sure to defeat Magnus because I have
had many good positions against him but
this time I managed to convert
yeah it was an epic comeback by you and
your team and while the Charlotte cobras
they need to take something from your
team's Playbook because the Indian Yogi
stormed back from that deficit now that
Charlotte Cobra is down six to two and
vladislava artemiev Sandra morenco and
Jose Martinez all a perfect two out of
two so heading into this round of action
where the top forward or the happy bars
vlades of artemiev he gets the black
piece against Daniel naroditsky did it
you know both those players well
the onion needs to strike what does he
have to do how can he make it happen
I think the most important thing is to
kind of still believe that a comeback is
possible for me when I was playing I
remembered that arjun's team was leading
seven to five in the last match which
they played against MBL and grishop and
from there they managed to make it a
blitz Library so for me that was like
kind of an inspiration so uh the same
thing goes for the cobras they still
need to believe that they can make a
comeback and okay I mean they have
nothing to lose at this point
yes they don't and they just need to go
all in but that's difficult in chess
right when you need to win Games you
start losing your objectivity somewhat
you take risks that are more speculative
than objective so as we see done you get
the white pieces do you think we're
gonna see one of the crazier Dona
openings or is he gonna just play his
normal stuff against such a strong
player like artemia
I'm very curious because Artemis is very
very strong he's very strong in this
rapid format
and I've seen
um Daniel his main strength is when it
comes below a minute or so so if he just
manages to keep the pressure throughout
the game then I believe in the tense
moments he is the better player but he
has to keep the pressure throughout the
game to force the mistakes basically
and so what do you make of his opening
right now because not a single horn has
been traded no tension between the
pieces he started playing for the long
game as you were highlighting but
artemia that's kind of his strength too
right he's somebody who loves
maneuvering chess and he loves end games
himself
yeah
um I think Daniel just wants to get a
game uh from the opening he himself has
admitted many times that opening is not
his strongest suit and as long as there
is some slight pressure where there are
a lot of chances he would be happy
um
so I think what you cannot allow is to
give artemia a slightly better position
because then without any counter play
that's that's his favorite type of Chess
when the opponent has no counter play
he's very good at it you have to be
careful just first initial few moves
early middle game and the last few
minutes I think that's the key part
which will decide the trajectory of the
game I think
and this has the feel of Jana parmishing
its Magnus Carlson this early A4 push
the Rook sliding to B8 uh so far so
steady in this position and something I
tend to ask and you know with it you
just had a big comeback for your team is
you know how much do you just ignore
everything from your remaining boards
and like are you able to strictly focus
on your own game or in the back your
mind are you thinking well I need my
board too and my board three and my
board four to score like how good are
you at tuning the rest of the world out
when you're playing
I think I'm very lucky because my team
they
there are some very good players for
example vaishali uh she has been scoring
upsets a lot so far so you know I I know
that I can rely on them so yeah I am
hoping that they will do well uh but
during the game I can't really follow
their matches so there's no way that I
can follow the matches or score it
doesn't help at all when I'm playing I'm
just focused on my own game and after
the game my first thing I do is like
check their results and usually it's
good news it has been good news and
let's take this moment while Daniel
nerdinski he's spending some time in the
position we have other games underway so
we can pull up our four board View and
see the other games that have started
Gregory o'parin in the top right against
Sandra morenco not a single Pawn has
been traded there yet and Sandra morenco
he's won both of his games for the Cappy
borrowers that's been huge for them and
the bottom left Jose Martinez he's also
won both of his games for Brazil he
takes son Gabrielle antiva so um did it
which of these two games is more
appealing to your eyes
openings have some I have some notes on
it so
you can pick any game and then I would
love to comment on it all right well
let's go to Jose just because he had
that huge win against Gregory o'parin
when board three is taking down the
enemy board one you know you're in good
shape and well white is just Castle
White has these double pawns teach me I
want to learn from you video give me
some of those notes
so this H3 move is very interesting
which uh Jose played it's kind of trendy
it's basically fortnights and now if
instead of H3 white plays D4 if you can
just make it on the board
Ed 94 this is the main line and Bishop
B4
takes takes Bishop D3 right this is the
main line and if you see if you compare
this position to the game you can take
the Live code
yep
and it's just the same position with
colors reversed just you have this H3
move included so it's a very subtle way
of you know playing like basically
you're black but you have an extra move
with H3
rest of it is same you're too smart for
me but the pawns you know I get what
you're saying it's actually a really
instructive stuff where you should and
Magnus Carlson uh when I was just in
Oslo commenting the champion Chester he
actually was saying that while we're at
the uh doing Pub trivia he was some
people were talking about Chess and he
was saying that you need to think about
positions from the other side it's
actually really helpful for top players
so you're right that it's just the
position with colors reversed with H3
thrown in but now that we're here and
the pawns are undoubled uh we have an
extra Pawn towards the center or white
this Pawn on D4 and for black we have a
more outside Pawn
do you tend to like these positions from
either side or if the eval Bar says
something but let's ignore that for now
give me that super GM knowledge
um I would have not played 97 I think
it's a bit passive you have to play like
Queen F6 Bishop F5 uh I don't really
have a preference as such uh in this
line
um but I think David and he's a big
expert uh in this structures uh for me I
I don't mind either colors but right now
I don't like this Moon Knight E7 I think
I think it just gives white easy Play
Bishop D3 next boost C4 is gonna come in
then you know the the moves are flowing
whereas for black it's not clear how you
develop I think that's always a bad sign
when your moves are not flowing
because the B7 Pawn is loose over here
so that Bishop on C8 can't get out you
97 was in part played to get Bishop F5
but you might have to play a move like
B6 first just to develop that Bishop so
I'm with you B6 C4 looks available white
just has better control of the center uh
yeah but yeah I think so far not you
know you couldn't really ask for more
not too much yeah yeah yeah it's very
slight pressure I guess we can move to
the other games because this is
relatively a bit dull
I love how honest you are so you already
have your commentator uh cap on you from
player to come to let's go to the bottom
right game between uh Julia Alvarado and
Brandon Jacobson because in that one uh
that one looks way more exciting because
we have is it classical Sicilian it's
the classical Sicilian it was a Richter
Rouser uh we have Kings on opposite the
board Pawn pushes so fit it again you're
gonna have to give me that super Grand
Master knowledge here uh which side do
you prefer thus far
I like black because for me I became GM
just because of classical Sicilian so
I've played like over 250 games with
black and I have great memories and the
funny thing is like if you just go to
the beginning just to like move Knight
C6 that's okay what defines classical
Sicilian
uh just I'll be very short and if you
think about it the main line is night
off which goes A6
but if you when I was young what I was
taught that you have to develop pieces
and for me Asics did not make any sense
and that's how I picked Knight C6 like I
mean why is everyone playing night off
you have to develop your pieces Knight
C6 go go for the king
and that's why I liked it and it gave me
many wins but now I know that it's
sub-optimal but in Rapid it's a great
weapon
oh I like that so with it played by the
rules he listened to his teachers how
are you at home who were watching you
listen to your coaches you develop your
pieces you play towards the center and
speaking of playing towards the center
D5 played by Brandon Jacobson clear he
wants to open up this bishop towards the
F3 pawn and if he could sit his Bishop
in the center that would be good but
white can also hop a knight into D4 and
things like that so I did it you're the
expert here you know you played this uh
classical Sicilian your whole life D5
break is this good or does it give white
some chances
I think only if you can play usually E5
or if there is something very concrete
um it should be like good for white
otherwise if if you manage to play ed5
Bishop Define cement it uh as how Peter
liko likes to say cemento and then it's
very very uh good uh but right now I'm a
little bit confused as I don't see why
white is supposed to be slightly better
which is according to the eval bar
I don't see something very obvious uh
for example Ed Bishop D5 Knight F5 there
is Bishop F3
so I mean yeah I'm a little bit confused
maybe Knight B3 I don't know I I maybe
is D takes E4 not a threat because a
knight takes E6 in some positions I know
it's a little bit difficult for some of
our viewers to see but the queen and the
Rook line up towards this Knight so if
this Knight's out of the way uh this
Knight will be loose back on D7 so maybe
there's some move here I'm tempted to
just go like this in a must win uh
situation from I guess black needs to
win he's on the cobras but I I'm just
throwing my pawns forward and she
doesn't she just plays a little bit more
restraint yeah and you can see right the
evolution bar just dropped
once you get like your Bishop you have
to be very precise to punish but right
now it's like a dream classical Sicilian
for black
yeah as video was saying Knight F5
Bishop takes F3 that's the problem is
both Rooks will be under attack so black
gets to steal that pawn with interest so
I don't really know is H4 H5 too slow
that's so that's all I know I don't know
any Theory here but I know you're
supposed to throw your pawns up the king
side
I mean yeah a bit little bit of caution
like just Bishop B2 you know Knight E5
Bishop V2 just you have to be a little
bit safe as well and like I just had an
overview of all the games things are not
looking so good for the Charlotte team
isn't it no they're down six to two well
since you mentioned the overview let's
zoom out to our four board scene here
where it's four point lead for Brazil
they need two and a half points they can
win in this round and well I guess
you're saying the top left Dania looks
like he has a slightly worse position
against artemia as well
exactly I mean that's exactly what you
should not get against rtmave as I said
risk-free slightly better position he's
not going to give you chances here so I
have little Hope from that board uh
Oparin has you can see like it's little
bit you know
anti-positional like I think because of
the tonight situation he has gone this
F3 F4
but objectively he is also not doing
that great
so yeah I'm a little bit worried for uh
the U.S team
yeah the cobras are in trouble let's
actually go to that board too uh sorry
board one for cobras is board two uh for
the Capybaras that one is interesting
uh because there's that Knight on E5
which looks super duper strong but as
you were just saying of it there are a
lot of holes in the position on these
light squares or white because the pawns
are in dark squares
I think the beauty of this portion is
that you don't need to do anything with
black like if you make a move like 94 or
something you kind of force white to
play Bishop E4
and then dc5 you help him open up but if
you just maintain the status quo I don't
see a clear plan for white if you place
G4 G5 it's for the weakening and then
you can capitalize on it so you just
need to you know keep the pressure keep
the momentum like CD4 maybes also move
with the threat of Bishop B4
you have to keep an eye out for it but
I'm not sure if it works now but even if
you make a waiting move it should be
fine
yeah no it seems like black is very
solid hanging Pawn structure not that
big of an issue because black has
counter threats because white has pushed
so far but it's what you need to do if
you're the cobras you need to play
Advanced chess to mount this comeback
and well did it I appreciate you hopping
on with me covering some of the games
talking about your win over Magnus uh
it's been a pleasure and we look forward
to seeing you more in the protest League
yes thanks Robert see you
and we will be rejoined by Tanya Sasha
very kind of hurt to step aside for a
brief moment there allowing Vita to
occupy her chair but video Gujarati the
hero for the Indian yogis today taking
down Magnus Carlson and sharing his
thoughts about the match between the
Capybaras and the cobras so Tanya hey
welcome back it's the real Tanya
I'm back Robert and it was so nice to
hear his breakdown and his thoughts in
the position I think he's gone back to
celebrating the Indian Yogi win I can
hear him on the phone now but big action
here and as you were talking about this
I think a really important Point made by
with it that the Charlotte Cobra is the
most important thing for them is to
believe that they can make this comeback
right now
yeah but if we look across the four
boards and their evaluation bars in the
top left good news for artemiev and the
Capybaras in the top right uh hovering
about even but still maybe slightly
better for the Cappy bars in the bottom
left that one looks pretty level but
Jose Martinez is the higher rated player
and he's up four and a half minutes in
the bottom right that is the one that
the cobras are likely to take if there's
any game because they're up three
minutes on the clock is Brandon Jacobson
in the bottom right his position also
looking good vidit was happy with the
classical Sicilian so uh Tanya I don't
know which game to dive into I feel like
all of them have a lot of tension on the
board
it just looks like a lot has gone wrong
for the cobras today they somewhere have
lost their venom and it looks like this
round if it doesn't go that way as we
can see across the board it's definitely
uh feels as if the Capybaras are the
ones who are leading on all of the
boards and I think the position that
really stands out that could go either
way is the Sandro Oparin matchup at the
top right one with the Knight
down on E5 it's planted itself there
could this be a big enough advantage in
White's position to try and just save it
for the cobras or will the double Bishop
pair be the ones who will do all the
talking here I'm liking Sandra's
position Sandro has been so informed
from the start of the day I like that
Knight on E5 but it really doesn't have
supporting a supporting cast behind it
there's no light squared Bishop you
can't put pressure on F7 it's a lone
camper and it might not just be enough
for Baron you know what needs to be done
you mentioned in an earlier Sandra
Morocco game can I take this E4 pawn and
throw it off the board like let's get
rid of that pawn again so we can use the
light squares to our advantage but
somehow America has a light score Bishop
for the second time of the day and upon
E4 that blocks the Daniel still uh as
you mentioned the Knight can't attack by
itself at some point you may need to
take on C5 and try to use the D file but
if you allow a bishop to C5 then E3 is
tender and will need some cover so
mareko up on the clock Grigio parin is
trying to find some wiggle room for his
pieces here but I don't really like the
look of this what if I even take and put
my Bishop on D3 even that looks pretty
Pleasant for black
yeah that looks like a nice idea and you
just stopped the only open file the
d-line which will open up if black takes
on E5 and he goes for your idea Sandro
trades off that Knight on E5 and plants
that Bishop on D3 with this bishop you
can just compare it to White's dark
Square bishop and you can just tell why
is it that the eval bar just likes
Black's position a little more more
piece activity more control over the
game just feels like more space and that
F1 Square always watch out for tricks
down the board on that F1 Square we saw
that actually but it lost that game
against rasmine priority because of a
position like this with the white king
being unsafe so what uh Tanya is
mentioning at some point you can play F6
chisel open this line and go for the
white king this bishop on D3 is an
absolute Beast it shuts down the D file
and takes away play on the F1 square and
the f file for white so we see a swap of
Pawns you could take this Pawn on A5 but
it's not just about Pawn quantity H5
Harry the H Pawn here
as it happens H5 on the board he's
taking your advice he's definitely
taking the right commentators advice
here but normally when I suggest moves
in their main iffy territory it just
feels like he has a free hand against
the white king and this Rook can lift up
to G6 you can of course play on The
Queen side as well at any moment to go
after this loose Pawn but I feel like
this oh my god did that just happen
again he just made Rook doing it I was
just sort of like suggesting kind of a
random move but he's stopping Bishop A3
which maybe was a source of White's
counter play in some positions I mean
Sandra mareko is a man possessed right
now
Robin I have to say not just him I mean
this would be a good time for you to go
to the lottery market and pick up a
decade I don't know what you're doing
but rookie on the board and as you're
pointing out it is a position for two
results we see an opposite color Bishop
on the board and often we think wait a
second isn't that just a draw but it's
all about the peace activity and
currently it's all blacks pieces that
are doing the talking on the queen side
on the king side H4 can be on the board
but right now with that last move B3 is
weak he lines up both the Rooks
attacking this big weakness and I think
Opera is in big trouble in this one not
good news for the Charlotte cobras who
are looking for a comeback not at all
Queen E6 look at the king side look at
the queen side double threats with H4 I
mean telling you this is a Master Class
by Mariko right now he takes on B3 he's
still down upon if the bishop slides
forward the A3 Pawn will be lost give me
that second rank I want to go after the
white king and this bishop on D3 is a
menace and look at oparin's clock down
under 50 seconds oh
[Music]
Rook will jump to B1 spinning the queen
winning the queen and this is bad news
you have to keep that Bishop guarded he
goes with the queen to C1 and defends it
H4 is in the air the queen can jump in
to look at this idea Robert Queen jumps
into H3 and I'm again threatening Rook
B2 and I'm gonna call myself a prophet
right now remember how I mentioned to
you that F1 Square can be super
dangerous for white check and mate so we
might just see that the Queen instead
slides up to F5 same idea different
order yeah yeah he goes right for this
and E6 this is desperation rather than
an attack yes you open your Bishop
that's the good news and that was a
mistake by Mariko he could have played
Queen H3 with the same Checkmate he
gives white some time will there be a
rook G5 will there be a rook takes H5
these are available to white but look at
the clock Tanya it's not just the board
it's the clock as well
oof and he goes Rook F2 and as you're
mentioning a very difficult position to
defend with white with just 25 seconds
meanwhile Sandra's super happy with his
clock management a great position but he
needs to find that final blow he needs
to wrap it up and not give white too
many chances too many attacks on G7 so
Robert it's close but it's not over yet
not over yet but if we zoom out for a
second we will come right back to this
game Jose Martinez if we look at our
four board scene here he is delivering
Checkmate next the bottom left bishop
and queen lined up on those dark squares
I think we're going to see a resignation
there is no stopping the queen go in the
corner we just caught it resignation has
occurred so we're back to oh but these
players are not playing this game this
is the one between uh Paran and Morocco
but Jose Martinez won that game with the
bishop and queen lined up on the dark
squares so uh that's bad news for the
cobras it is now seven to two in the
capybara's favor
72 the one board that gives hope to the
cobras is the bottom right that we see
where black does have a big advantage or
a valbar tells us and the reason for
that is I'm still trying to understand
the Knight on D4 is attacked right now
and I think there were tricks down the
board with that Bishop jumping into the
game which requires desperation from
Whiteside uh Robert what do you say
tactics all all over do we jump into
board four right now
uh sure let's do that because Sandra
mareko is still thinking we can always
zoom out if action is happening at other
boards but Julia Alvarado she was going
for some King side pressure she is
getting that right now so this Knight on
D4 is hanging none easy choice if you're
Brandon Jacobson you need to win even if
uh you lose the game it's not really any
different than a draw at this point you
just need to score a victory so Queen
takes D4 you can pick that up but you
know Rook takes H7 is about to happen so
what's going on here
this is an absolute mess of a position
what's going on here I don't know the D6
Rook is hanging uh The Rook on H7 will
be hanging once you pick it up Brandon
has picked up a piece already one thing
is for sure Brandon needs to score for
his theme the Charlotte uh the Charlotte
cobras are looking for a win on this
board and Rook into 8-7 big question
firstly for black how does he respond
and now we see he did decide to play the
move E4 so blocking down the bishop that
is an interesting choice White's Bishop
on D3 can't pick up that pawn The Rook
on D1 is hanging you can fall back with
the bishop to E2 hitting that Queen on
D4 yes you can slide back just to put
pressure no she grabs this whoa
wait a second Bishop C4 check
oh my gosh Bishop C4 he didn't
he's back in the game he takes F3
there's Bishop D3 and suddenly white is
on top so he just allowed her not just
to get into the game but she has the
upper hand this is Bishop D5 hits The
Rook ew
it's on the butt well you can pick it up
but now E2 and the pawn will be
unstoppable so you can't just pick up
the Rook with Bishop A8 but you could
slide with your own Rook hitting that
night hitting that pawn on E3 with Rook
E6 instead she gives a check on e4 I'm
not sure if that's a good idea Robert
because it blocks the e-line for The
Rook to come into the defense with
rookie six rookie six still available
she miss rookie when she gets passive
and now black has the upper hand it's
her time trouble that is causing her not
to be able to survive so Brandon
Jacobson making some quick choices
because he's trying to punish her on the
clock but he allowed her to escape there
we bring up and now sport ever so
quickly Tanya was calling for a great
winning move after Bishop D5 E3 there
was Rook E6 The Rook is under attack and
once this Knight is captured the pawn is
stopped that was overlooked by her a
couple moves in a row but she is going
after this pawn and Tanya this looks
like a position that white should be
able to hold I see her time trouble I
know Brandon Jacobson is a bullet
Mastermind but this bishop could sit on
D3 The Rook is free to go in the e-file
limited material I feel like white is
holding on
it really does look like that and it's
all going to be about whether Julia
believes in the activity of her bishop
and her Rook combining with the king's
player on the queen side targeting
Brandon spawns the a6b4 pawn the king
needs to come to B3 needs to go to A4
but firstly it is going to be about
where he decides to move the Knight she
gives a check she's going to pile up the
pressure on the G6 Pawn she does it
black steps up with The Rook C3 trying
to trade off as many pawns as possible a
good decision when you're trying to hold
a position for a draw a hundred percent
because we might see a swap if the white
king goes up to A5 we will even see the
bishop sacrifice itself because if you
can remove all the pieces there do not
take this Knight that's the one way to
get yourself in trouble is in a pure
rook and pawn end game because black is
up a pawn so just move this bishop
somewhere I don't know where D5 looks
healthy and I'll trade the remaining
pawns this should be a draw but uh time
travel is going to remain for white
it is objectively the position might be
equal but it doesn't matter what the
objective evaluation it comes down to
this time scramble and can Julia hold it
because it is such an important Point uh
for the team if she can just keep it
together the topic borrowers would be
super happy with that result meanwhile
action everywhere Robert down to seconds
in the Artemis game it looks like Daniel
nerdinski in big trouble three-part oh
and it goes back up so both sides are
making their fair share mistakes it's a
tricky end game in mutual time travel
but there was a win there for our Tammy
if he missed it apparently
and now you just come up with the King
you stop all the pawns the Pawns of
Advance as much as they can but there's
no more going forward because look at
the king and the night the Knight will
just jump to E4 keep the E4 Square
defended lacks E Pawn cannot Advance the
F Pawn is stop the Jeep on a stop the
only thing is what happens when black
marches with the King to the other side
and that's what white needs to take care
of uh Daniel here moving with the King
and I'm not happy F3 it's winning F3
King takes King and F2 the king comes
back and King E2 this unfortunately
we're down there disc you could see it
on his face he's upset with himself but
this king is going to help the pawn
promote Daniel nerdinski resigns
artemiev and the Cappy bars win their
match with a round to spare it's very
unfortunate for the Charlotte cobras
they were in for a tough battle
regardless but Dania he's really upset
with himself it looked like throughout
the game artemi valplayed him and we
still have one more game going it
doesn't matter for the match results uh
but Julia Alvarado she is trying to hold
on in a pawn downed Rook end game it's
likely she's going to lose but this
match is in the books Tanya look at the
top three boards for the Capybaras three
out of three two and a half of three and
three out of three for our temmiev
mareko and Martinez
and the whole team has changed Robert
the dynamic Dynamic change
Jose Martinez scoring a massive three
out of three our time we have scoring a
three out of three Sandra with two and a
half just amazing play there hola this
is the team that lost in three rounds in
week one and look at their comeback
taking down one of the big favorites off
the protest League the Charlotte cobras
in just three rounds right and there was
a win there for Brandon Jacobson uh
unfortunately for him I mean he somehow
he got this win uh in the end game it
was Julia Alberta's time trouble that
did not allow her to secure the half
point but it's a bit too late for the
cobras because it's eight and a half now
to three and a half for Charlotte I
wonder if that counts like if you think
about it the match is over when you
reach eight and a half this game was
still in progress did we count that for
the scoreboard I wonder what the
protesting rules are
well it's an interesting question but
definitely from a team perspective this
is the time for the captain to celebrate
he mentioned the big decision uh that
that they took with artemia and what
he's expecting from the team today it
has been a fabulous performance by the
Brazil Capybaras and I never thought I
would say this after week one but Robert
this is turning out a team to watch out
for certainly because if their top three
boards are going to score like that it's
going to be hard for any team to stop
them and in week one they were stopped
in three rounds the match concluded in
the Indian Yogi's favor now they're the
victors in just three rounds and the
Charlotte cobras with two match losses
they're on the brink of elimination if
they do not win next week they're out of
this protest League season so we are
going to bring in Jose Martinez Jocelyn
for an interview and we are going to be
back with the superhero the Superstar
for the Brazil capybars Jocelyn will not
want to miss his thoughts we'll be right
back
foreign
[Music]
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more
chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it is a pleasure to be joined by the
board 3 of the Brazil capybara's Jose
Martinez Jose first of all
congratulations and my first question
for you is what changed between last
week and this week where in week one you
lost in three rounds and today you were
dominant in winning in three rounds
Rover
um yeah the first match against the
Indian jokes was I think a little
disappointed
I think we changed almost all the the
how to say the list of players we the
first match we play with the GM super GM
fear with me and myself and
the irritable market so to this match we
changed actually almost at the the whole
whole list and we invited or the captain
invited the super strong gym that is
really a good good fact because you have
more confidence uh
you have a leader in the team because
every team has a really at least one
strong player you can see kind of that
just brass I don't know the joggies so I
think uh we play with our best cards our
best uh players and I think also we were
we were today in a good shape because
maybe I couldn't play bad I couldn't
lose the first game for sure because I
was I was almost bad but I think we
the three players also Julia play a
really good game the last one we play a
really good match I think or have a good
day so that happens when you and all
your team has a good date so that things
can happen I think
it was it was an awesome match no doubt
about that and in the middle we saw you
celebrate as well with the fist bump and
just pumping in the air I want to ask
you is the joy more heightened when it's
the protest League it's a team event the
Dynamics so much at stake what does that
feel like
yeah I celebrate because I know against
who I'm playing I was the the first
player or the the first who need to play
against the two strongest players of the
opponents team so
I play first against the Danja and then
I play operating so I I need to to do my
best to just don't
play Bad No at least one point of two
was really great uh performance but I
didn't expect that actually the first
game I was bad you I think you see the
the whole game and the second thing I
think it played really solid operating
takes some risk and also he needs some
tactic I think
because it's really difficult to to beat
these kind of players like in a row and
more
I helped the team because uh yeah you
know you can expect out to me if he can
do it like really excellent performance
also Sandro he's the best for the second
best I don't know of Argentina he's
really
excellent players
I'm just to the team if if you can be
the two top players of the opponents
team you you need to celebrate like it's
no more excuse it's earlier
I'm doing all for the thing yeah it's
not a individual okay we love it
yeah Jose you know the way you were
celebrating you remind me of like a
football match so are you a football fan
yourself
um since Peru didn't qualify to the
World Cup and football uh I'm really
disappointed but yeah I was a really
really good fan actually I didn't see
too many football matches or matches uh
are you talking about soccer no sport
yeah yeah I'm talking about soccer you
call it you call it football you know I
know how you say it yeah in South
America we love soccer yeah but actually
I don't have time this month to so to
start to see the best matches in Europe
so I was just doing some chess and
something else but I love chess yeah I
love uh soccer I love soccer when Peru
has a good or the best teams has a good
a good matches
wow and you guys are talking about fun
so I have to ask this question I see
that t-shirt on you Jose it says chess
is more fun with tacos and that's
definitely what the coffee bras seem to
have today in their match fun and
entertainment what's going on there was
that an inspiring t-shirt
yeah I like this t-shirt because
I received this t-shirt when I was
playing some GM tournament in USA
actually in New York if I remember
correctly and I'll also love Mexico I
was the last year 2022 three months in a
row in Mexico like like for OTV
tournaments I enjoy the lifestyle in
that the country so is there is no a
better shirt to use than this because
this is a combination of Chess and the
second country I love like it's Mexico
the first is Peru for sure but basically
like my second home
oh it's great to hear and Jose we have a
featured question from uh Tobin plays
which is what is special about this team
and do you think the team has it what it
takes to go all the way and win the
protest League
um
about our team I think we have a really
good uh really good list of players RT
maybe is actually a best of the top of
the top of the online players he can
like play every format one since one
minute from one minute to to classical
chess he's good in every format so he's
a really excellent and actually he has a
lot of experience so
if he continues to play with us we can
we can do really good I will try to to
bring my good form to don't disappoint
at least my
my goal is don't lose any game that's
why I'm playing solid but if I can win
some games okay but I want to just uh
don't give points yeah and try to be
solid and I I trusted the team I throw
the every GM can play the two women
players at Grandma's room and players
and so
it's um yeah I trust my teammate I don't
have a actually good as a specific
expectation but we can we can do good in
the next matches
for sure Jose and before I let you go I
have to give a shout out to your channel
so first of all uh why don't you let
everyone know your channel that you
stream at and my question before he
leaves are you playing Arena Kings
tomorrow
yeah for sure it's my
I never uh I never like uh forget or uh
I always play around against because
three plus three always my best I think
uh I'm control maybe bullet I I'm I am
waiting the bullet Chess Championship
from just come but I don't know when
we'll be but three always my my best
life informat so I love to play and then
Arena Kings yeah Hikaru always play
morning so many good good players uh we
can build good fights and it's also
difficult to to to be the first in that
tournament because Hikari is always
winning
um the last way I won but yeah almost
every week if you can win every other
necklace but yeah it's fun to play some
no increments like everyone
well Jose where can we all follow your
stream let everybody know where they can
go press that follow button right now
yeah my twitch channel is GM job spin
with double M because I don't know who
is still the adjustment with one M but I
think he has he's my final list I don't
know how
I don't know who can like name Jim
Justin because it's difficult Jasper is
a really nonsense word It's a
combination of letters Jose Peru
Martinez it's like a mix of that
his Jaws is three letters of Jose and PE
it's Peru also there is
from Martinez so it's a kind of I don't
know who has that that negative yeah I
mean he's watching now
at the end
okay we'll make sure that everyone
follows your channel Jose thank you so
much for joining us and congratulations
once again it was such a great display
of chess
oh thank you to both thank you for
organizing and yeah it's it's an honor
to play this for this team because yeah
every team is really good and they
invite you like you can feel like you
you can do a really good chance in this
tournament really big tournament
for sure thank you so much Jose we'll
see you next week and more from the
protest League
thank you
honey you gotta love Jose there right
like just so much team spirit uh you
know he is really happy to be on the
Brazil Capybaras and they're even
happier that he's on the team because
look at his score a perfect three out of
three they won in just three rounds
I love the attitude love that t-shirt
and he was playing against two very
strong opposition and winning that just
how much it meant to him and also doing
his bit for the Brazil capybara's
amazing team spirit there also what he
mentioned about how it's just a brand
new team that we're seeing this week and
this is what makes the protest league so
special and unique the teams can make
such a turnaround and Robert that's the
narrative that we saw all day today I
mean let's remember the first the very
first matchup that we had with the chest
press taking on Indian yogis what a
turnaround that was at the end of the
match many had written off Indian yogis
in that one and it all came down to that
final round four that 4-0 win no one
could have predicted that and then that
finish and now the Brazil capybara is
coming back and turning around the
entire field that they have for the
protest League after that disastrous
week one eight and a half to three and a
half that is destruction which actually
means that the Charlotte cobras are one
strike away from being knocked out for
sure well the Brazil capybars they score
their first match Victory as Jose said
it's pretty much a new team they brought
in artemia and as we look at the
standings through well one full week and
then just the matches that we had today
we see the Indian yogis they were able
to come back and win their match against
the chess bras and the Capybaras they
move to one and one as well and on the
bottom of the standings there is going
to be one team that sticks out because
only one team has lost two matches thus
far
it's the Charlotte cobras so uh Tanya
not a good day for the cobras they're
one match away one match loss away from
elimination
and that is huge pressure on Daniel
naroditsky's theme and definitely today
has been a disappointing performance
they need to re-strategize they need to
rethink how and which players they want
to put forward they've got just one more
shot and that said of course the Indian
yogis need to win just one match in fact
Robert to make it to the playoffs and
this whole week of the protest league is
going to be about that teams getting
closer to that big top eight spots for
the protest League top eight position to
make it to the playoffs and there is so
much at stake every day there is that is
true and every day Tuesday through
Friday we have a double header in the
Pro chest league so tomorrow two matches
will be available for you all to watch
we start with the Norway gnomes and
their epic first week win thanks to go
Wayne Jones and a mouse slip they take
on the levitov chess Wizards I have to
say I love those look they really pop
out at us and they won their first match
so uh Tony let's start there in the
matchup of teams that won week one who
do you see as the favorite between the
Gnomes and the chess Wizards
it's a tough one to pick you know gnomes
have got their own star players it's a
team that's that's captained by Anna
Rudolph and it is they've got John
Ludwig hammer on as well and David
Howell we might be seeing David make an
appearance this week as well but the
lavator we're dominating in week one
they produce some very magical play on
the chessboard you were talking about
having their logos I'm loving it it's
extremely Harry potter-esque if I might
say it was it was destruction by the
levitov you asked me to pick a favorite
it's so hard these are the two teams
that won their matches they're evenly
matched it all comes down to every
player making their score count you
can't just rely on one top board you
can't just rely on having one star
player each of the boards matter as you
say Robert every board counts and then
we've got the passes the Garden State
passes James candy the third it's his
theme taking on the maniac streams by
the way I have to say the shrimps is a
very popular logo with our chat I was
going to say that might be the best
overall logo that Maniac shrimps they
are maniacal on the chess board are they
unfortunately let a match went slip away
go Wayne Jones he won his game against
the maniac shrimps they were that close
to getting match Victory so we'll see if
their lineup can secure match victory in
week two but that's for tomorrow
tomorrow's a new day Tanya I just want
to thank you so much I mean it was so
fun covering these matches with you
I loved it today was a day honestly
Robert just packed with surprises at the
start of the day few would have
predicted this turnaround and this final
result but that is what is beautiful
about Chess and spot you can never never
predict expect the unexpected it's been
so much fun calling out the action with
you today
expect the unexpected you heard Tanya's
advice well we expect you all to return
tomorrow for the protest League we want
to first thank you for joining us today
it really is an absolute pleasure to
commentate this top level chest for you
all so please come back enjoy you know
hit the follow button if you want but be
back for more protesting tomorrow same
time same place we'll see you then
foreign
[Music]